foreign
[Music]
okay
foreign
[Music]
thank you
hey everyone Jim Daniel nerdinsky here
we ask the chess.com Community to show
us their best games from the cgc
qualifiers and we're here to highlight
some of the exciting chess that our
awesome community members cooked up in
these competitive cgc games so here we
have ckca who put together a phenomenal
end game display to defeat a very strong
and experienced British Grandmaster he's
got the white pieces in this bishop end
game and he starts by pushing his Pawn
up to F4 in order to make it more
difficult for black to push his kingside
pawns black response with E5 looks like
whites only made it worse but down comes
the bishop to C3 this is an amazing move
because it attacks the E5 pun the pawn
cannot move because it's pinned to the
bishop so black is forced to defend it
with his King but now white advances his
Pawn majority on the queen side and when
the moment is right after A4 G5 white
very patiently plays G3 defending the
pawn on F4 and only when the moment is
right when white has pushed his Pawn all
the way to B5 he transition to the pawn
end game occurs and well white can take
on E5 instead he decided to take on A5
that is also perfectly sufficient giving
him two extra pawns on the queen side
and the rest is very simple dropping the
bishop back moving it to the best square
and promoting his pawns great end game
display by ckca this has been GM Daniel
near this key with another Community
highlight from the chess.com Global
Championship qualifiers
your subscription makes shows like this
possible which is why our twitch
subscribers will never see ads on
chess.com
connectyourchess.com account and Twitch
account at go.chess.com connect accounts
and bang boom voila you're done 100 AD
free Bliss forevermore whether you're
following our events on site or on
stream type the command connect in the
chat and thank you for helping bring
these shows to life
you guys play chess you want to talk
about it let's do oh yeah where do you
play chess at you know okay when I say
chess the first word that pops into your
mind
protect my queen Hikaru intelligence
strategy tactics Toby Maguire oh my God
you saw Pawn sacrifice if you're on
Tinder and you're scrolling and someone
has a chess player on their profile as
that swipe left or swipe right
is good right yeah then yeah instant
swipe right okay super into that right
I'm into it you're ready probably
whatever the swipe is I don't not
interested so you're not interested in
chess players I'm not into chess players
are on Tinder oh I get that in fact that
checks out if I ask you to name one
chess player in the world can you name a
chess player
yeah no not gonna on the Taylor Joy
Capital boy name another one oh Casper
of Casper
eight dollars spasky
holgar
Carlson and
on holy you get 50 bucks dude oh my
God we just lost 50 whose idea was that
[Music]
laughs
foreign
[Music]
Toronto the one hotel Prides itself on
its rustic feel and being friendly to
its environment this week its doors are
open to some of the best players in Pro
chess each in search of their share of
the five hundred thousand dollars at
stake It's the final week of the
chess.com Global championship and it
starts right now
yes I was born in Vancouver but as
wonderful as Andrea and Vancouver are
it's pretty tough not to fall in love
with the city of Toronto
natural beauty abounds inside Toronto
and pretty close by
largest city in Canada the people here
have been playing chess and clubs in
universities and in public parks
what are you doing
for well over a century
and now this wonderful place plays hosts
for the very first chess.com Global
championship finals
facing elimination for weeks eight of
the world's best players have survived
to continue their quest for the
queen-size share of the one million
dollar prize pool
and it's just made Sensational this is
the most shocking day that we have ever
had
my friends you're in the right place
it's time for the cgc finals Toronto
Canada officially has it all
thanks Andrea and Alexandra yes Toronto
has much to offer and it's not far from
some breathtaking views but today we're
inside the one hotel in downtown where
the stage is set and the players are
ready to begin the quarterfinals of the
chess.com Global championship
welcome inside the gameplay Hall at one
Hotel Toronto we're super excited to
have you with us and hearing from you in
chat all day I'm Danny wrench alongside
Grand Master Daniel narredixi nerodinski
we have James Canty here an
international Master Levy Rosman these
gentlemen are amongst the small army we
have brought to Toronto here for the cgc
finals and fellas your opening thoughts
now as we get settled in Toronto for
some great chess ahead
Danny where do I begin I'm in a
beautiful city I'm covering an amazing
tournament and I'm doing it with the
best company imaginable all of you guys
are awesome I'm super super happy to be
here it's an honor to be part of this
small village and I can't wait to jump
in and then you said the best can't wait
to jump in we in Toronto lots of good
food good people a lot of money on the
line here big trophies big chess man I'm
excited yeah I don't think people
realize just how much has gone into this
like you guys look fantastic the
production looks fantastic this whole
set looks just absolutely incredible
there is half a million dollars being
given away in the next six days in this
event I can't be more excited mine is me
almost losing my suitcase at the airport
we got past that now we're here I'm
ready for chess let's go you look
fantastic Candy's chain looks fantastic
for those new to the cgc we are playing
rapid chess and we began this tournament
months ago with thousands of players we
are now down to eight and you will soon
notice we have three players not with us
in Toronto and a new one that's been
added to the mix more on that in a
moment but right now let's take a look
at our bracket guys here's our final
eight they will be competing in eight
game matches over the next two days
let's move to the top half of the
bracket and Zone in on Hikaru Nakamura
now the reigning Fisher random world
champion he'll be taking on yons just
off Duda Wesley so will take on Dimitri
on draken moving to the bottom half of
the bracket you see a niche Geary taken
on his good friend tame or verjavov and
then nihal sarin will take on the last
minute fill in Sam sebian Friday and
Saturday we will move of course to the
semi-finals ultimately we're moving to
Sunday and Monday where the championship
and ultimately a global chess champion
will be crowned
I I am so excited Donya let's start with
you your initial thoughts on the field
how strong these eight players are what
they had to go through to get here and
what pops out to you about the bracket
well what pops out to me is the fact
that my favorite types of tournaments
are ones where you cannot predict a
single result every result is up in the
air and why does that happen that
happens because the players are so
evenly matched and are so known for
upsets and that's exactly what we see
here in the finals of the cgc we're
going to try to predict some of the
matches but I think we're all going to
look like fools and I think that's a
that's a great thing and that is the
reason everybody should be on the edge
of their seats no matter what match
we're watching absolutely of course so
the matches up being eight games at
least two or eight game matches here are
absolutely like unpredictable to say the
least somebody can go 4-0 and then the
next day it turn around and we have an
Armageddon so it's actually really crazy
to see even in the format standpoint
yeah this is the culmination of months
of work right we made this event 64
players 32 invited 32 went through
essentially The Hunger Games to get here
and now there's eight guys left right we
have a fast time control so we don't
have to sit here talking about
hypotheticals for six or seven hours and
we have a mix of the Mainstays at the
top of the game and a couple of young
stars as well so what more can you ask
for right you said it well Hunger Games
of Chess I like that Knockouts people
love them uh and I I can't wait as well
I mean you said we can pick favorites
but really every one of these matches
could go a direction that no one sees
coming so as we mentioned due to some
Logistics five of the players will be
here in Toronto they are here in Toronto
the other three will be playing from
Belgrade Serbia let's actually check in
on that and give the fans a view of
where the players will be sitting here
are where the five players in Toronto
will be joining us from we see that a
couple of them are already at their
chairs Wesley so not here yet Anish giri
is there Sam Sevin yet to be here Hikaru
Nakamura just took off his headphones
and Jan schistuff Duda they will all be
in Toronto let's take a look at where
the three players in Serbia will be we
see Dimitri on Dragon the only one not
arrived yet taymore of her job off
getting dialed in dialed up and Nihao
Sauron getting ready to play it's uh wow
it's gonna be wild so guys as we look at
the Players five in Toronto three in
Belgrade we have some cases in which the
players will be in the same room
obviously with one another and some
where they're going to be playing online
as if it was still the online qualifying
portions Donnie as a player which would
you prefer well that's been entirely on
my form in the tournament if I'm in good
form then I want to see my opponent
sitting across from me as Bobby Fischer
said I want to see my opponent's ego
crack and I make the good moves I want
to see the impact that it has on my
opponent's facial expression and the way
they're are behaving but if I'm in bad
form I don't want to have anything to do
with whoever I'm playing I want them
away in Belgrade I don't want to see
them and I don't want to see them
crushing me so depends fully on whether
I'm in good form whether I'm in bad form
yeah it's always always in front of them
for me like you just want to see what's
going on see their face when you make
that move or like your face when they
make that move on you of course so at
the same time I'd have to be in front of
them just to see everything go down to
body language as well and see how we
grow up Street chess and also playing in
front of the parks Etc right you want to
see that and everything from there so
I'm I'm in front of you guys I'm going
to take a different angle so we've all
played over the board chest but chess
absolutely exploded over the last couple
of years and for the viewers at home you
might have gotten into chess online but
for those that have played over the
board it's a totally different
experience for your nervous system so
you guys have nailed that component my
question here is we have five people
right behind us in the venue where
you're kind of supposed to be
technically right this is Toronto and
everything like that but you have three
people in one location in Belgrade so
can they get in that same headspace
chess is this odd game you can play in a
hybrid format from a remote location but
are they in the same headspace seeing
all of us here surrounded like will
there still be that intensity I don't
know I know you when you have 200 Grand
on the line for first place you better
get in the best tattoo space whether you
like it or not no matter where you're
playing from there's a ton on the line
so all right well as you saw in the
bracket everyone's been talking about it
Sam sevian has indeed replaced Lavon
aronian Lavon unfortunately had to
withdraw due to personal reasons but
yesterday Nemo caught up with Sam to
talk about the fact that he's now
finding himself back in the cgc here in
Toronto
you know I always want to win I usually
like to take it one match at a time so I
win that one I go on to the next
come to Toronto welcome to the cgc are
you excited for this week uh I'm
definitely very excited it feels really
good to be here all right so as a last
minute replacement in the field do you
think that works to your advantage or
disinvested I think this is both because
he was probably preparing he wasn't
preparing against me and I wasn't
preparing against him so we both just
have like one two days to see what we
can do how is preparing for a rapid
tournament like cgc different from
preparing for large over-the-board
events so when I'm preparing for an over
divorce event I'm trying to pose my
opponent problems that they couldn't
solve in a long game while in a rapid
tournament I can play some tricky lines
which figure out how to play against it
[Music]
Eddie will tell you all
about your games and one of the
interesting things that we actually
found out about you is that you play
most accurately on Wednesdays by far did
you know this I definitely didn't know
that okay well apparently you play by
far the best on Wednesdays thank you for
joining us
[Music]
great stuff there from Nemo here are
some other things of course to know
about Sam sevi and he's 21 years of age
we see his path getting here to the cgc
finals with that unique unique result
there in the round of 16 that he lost
yet here he stands and then that last
fun fact is where I want to throw to you
Dania his insights fun fact is that he
plays his most accurate chess on
Wednesdays well last time I checked it's
Wednesday here in Toronto Dania your
thoughts on that it's Wednesday nehal
has no chance this is going to be 4-0
Victory I mean 90 94.4 percent come on
that's absolutely ridiculous but in all
seriousness Danny perhaps what impresses
me the most about seven is the way that
he has sort of refashioned his style
over the past couple of years I remember
Sam as a little kid in California he was
tremendously talented but he was all
tactics and in the last couple of years
as Sam has climbed to 2700 where he
stabilized he has added so many new
facets to his game his opening
preparation is better than ever I mean
his prep during the cgc was wild and
just his positional understanding the
stability of his play he has done all of
the right things checked all the right
boxes in order to remain at 2700 so he's
a scary opponent for everybody I don't
think anybody is thrilled to see Sam
Simeon as a replacement to Lavon aronian
he's gonna be a tough not to crack yeah
I completely agree in the round of 32 he
knocked out the blitz champion of the
world Maxima Shayla Gruff he beat the
guy right to get to the round of 16. he
didn't have a great match against Levon
but when was the last time this is a
question really for the audience when
was the last time there was a
quarterfinals and one of the
participants just lost in the round of
16 and they said no no actually he
didn't just lose come right back all
right you get a second chance it's a
very unique situation I'm very keen to
see how he's going to adapt to it
because it's like he legitimately just
has a free pass yeah yeah as a player he
was out now I'm back in right is what
he's saying I mean that's absolutely
crazy to see you know Sam only losing to
like what I like to call him LeBron
aronian right so he's losing to LeBron
or only only guy to lose to right that's
very good and then also beating mvl my
number one French man he's playing some
great chess now that he's gone and he's
back right he's like I'm back from the
dead I'm back right now we're about to
see what happens with this 200 000 on
the line it's going to be wild of course
we know that Sam sebian playing Nihao
sorry but there are other matches coming
up as well so let's dig into the
schedule and talk about what is ahead
here on the first day of the
quarterfinals right there at the top
Hikaru Nakamura will be taking on Jan
shisto Duda the match where both players
are in Toronto the only one Wesley so
takes on Dimitri on draken taymore
verjavov takes on Anish giri and then as
we've been talking about nihal sarin
we'll be taking on Sam sebian guys which
is the most interesting matchup to you
I'm gonna start with you candy you get
to pick your matchup of the day first my
matchup is a Nakamura Duda there of
course uh it's gonna be very difficult
for for Judah but he has taken out um
you know Magnus Carlson we've seen the
World Cup he's beating Sergey kuryakin
right as well so very strong he's also
2800 rappers so lots of things to see
there from Duda and there's head the
head match up on Nakamura is ahead in
the fast time controls Nakamura is
extremely quick we know this it's scary
the time gets lower he gets stronger
it's very very scary stuff to see half
man other half we don't really know yet
right so it's a very scary thing facing
Hikaru and uh you know dude is going to
have to bring his best game against Levy
obviously uh Canty just took the one
matchup of the two guys here maybe
stealing some Thunder but what's your
matchup of the day yeah of course that's
going to be the the biggest question the
one that can'ty just described but
listen I'm going to throw it back to
that Sam Savion mashup right like he
just got another opportunity at
Redemption and he got to progress in the
event he didn't go to any losers bracket
which is what usually happens when
you're losing an event he went forward
and he's playing against nihal Sarah
nehal sarin has a very unique quality
about him he's a young talented player
from India he's a teenager but he's
almost never played games against so
many players in the field and I believe
that's even the case today so what's
gonna happen is the guy with the golden
ticket gonna win or the guy that just
beat the world number two in three games
is going to win I have no idea it's a
shame that the youngsters have to play
in the first round by the way they grab
two of the top storylines but there's
two matches left I'll let you choose
your flavor listen I think one of the
narratives that we're ignoring is that
it's more our job of has been
consistently underrated for really the
past couple of years we always you know
we don't really talk about him and then
hey he gets third in the candidates he
qualifies for the cgc I mean his chess
resume over the past year has been
incredible Anish giri is the face of
stability the face of solidity so you
know to more job of not somebody to be
ignored in this tournament and I'm going
to be keeping a very close eye on how he
and Anish giri do against each other
well I'm more than happy to do a quick
preview of the last match remaining
Wesley so was the Fisher random World
chess champion until about a week ago
will he find his form here in Toronto
Wesley of course a very very strong
rapid player and and someone that no one
wants to play in these formats but he's
taken on this guy Dimitri on Drake and
who you talked about someone who maybe
flies under the radar and tame over a
job off Dimitri on Drake and has been
who's who title Tuesday royalty if you
will for the last several years and now
he makes it all the way to the round of
eight the quarterfinals in the cgc so
can't wait for that matchup as well all
right guys but we're pushing close to
the start of the quarter finals so let's
bring in the two commentators who are
going to be having the call for these
two first two games we have Amon
Hamilton and Robert Hess how excited are
you guys to finally get going
thanks Danny for the warm welcome you
know I'm Grandmaster Robert Hess and it
is my first time in Canada but we do
have a local here Grandmaster Mont
Hamilton so mon how does it feel to have
such a prestigious event on your home
turf well I'm happy to show everyone
around of course thanks Robert and of
course uh welcome to everyone who's
watching welcome to Toronto you know my
city happy to call it home and uh you
know what an exciting production and
broadcast that's getting underway I
can't wait to get into the matches today
Robert for sure we heard some of the
highlights from our colleagues across
the way but let's talk about the format
for this event we know the players but
it still remains a single elimination
knockout unless you're sam7 and get that
second lease on life it's eight games
this time around though I'm on so what's
the difference in the mass strategy yeah
eight games is such an interesting
format because it's over two days so we
will not see any matches conclude on day
number one we could see a big lead by
one player and then immediately a
comeback from another player so it's
such an interesting format there will be
no knockouts on day one and honestly
Robert I'm ready for some exciting
comebacks I'm ready for you know the
unexpected in this event for sure and it
can be an exhausting event the 15 minute
plus two seconds that's a fast-paced
time but you'll you better have your
nerves in there so we are going to call
game one of all four matches shortly but
for now we're gonna kick it back to
Danny and the Gang
thank you Robert well guys the other
thing we're going to be doing here all
week is turning in our picks to
production for each match and then we're
going to be keeping track of our score
so make sure you pick wisely to kick
things off chat we're going to ask you
to make your pick right now between Sam
sevian and Nihao sarin do so in chat let
us know who will win for now let's share
our picks and our thoughts on what is
perhaps the most intriguing match of the
day with Sam sebian coming back here to
the cgc against Soren Dania you get
things started your pick in that matchup
said I'm a big fan of both players I
think this is going to be a very close
one I actually think this one might go
into Armageddon that's how closely
matched the players are but nihal sarin
he has displayed just ridiculous
consistency and success over the past
couple of years especially in online and
Rapid tournaments I'm just think about
how he played in the SEC think about how
he played in the RCC the cgc whatever
ends on the C whatever ends with the
word chess Serena has been incredibly
successful I'm gonna have to pick him by
the tiniest of tiny margins it it's hard
to pick against sarin he's a rising star
from India he punched his ticket to the
cgc cleanly if you will but I'm going to
surprise the world and actually say that
yeah I also think he's going to get
things done here he's he's going to take
down Sam stevian and uh it's it's it's
unfortunately going to be an end of the
Cinderella story there I actually think
uh so yeah nihal is is the guy there I
mean India is a Powerhouse right now
it's very scary facing the Indian teams
and they got the C team is 2700 right so
very tough facing those guys I'm going
with Neo yeah I I really preferred when
I didn't have to make pigs you know I
just like to recap the games but this is
this is just
this is just a close one and I I'm the
kind of guy I don't make the same
mistakes two times all right I said that
in the house uh siren story was gonna
end when he played against dingley run
and then he beat him in the minimum
number of games alright so I learned my
lesson and I believe in the hills are
and I have to choose somebody in that
match so it's a shame like I said they
have to play in the first round but I
guess I gotta go with nihal I'm actually
gonna stick with my pick of Sam sebian
by the way I got a little bit thrown off
there everyone I do think the Cinderella
story is going to continue I had lunch
with him yesterday he was relaxed he was
poised I think seven is gonna shock
everybody and actually keep this
Cinderella Story alive throwing throwing
now to Robert and Amman guys we're
bringing you back to take things away
not just for your picks but for the
first matches of the day well no wishing
washingness over here Amman you go first
who's your pick in this matchup damn
putting me on the spot already Robert
well listen I don't mind agreeing with
the majority of our colleagues over
there I'm also going to pick Nihao in
this match you just think about how he
got here and taking down dingley ran of
all people is a pretty nice statement to
get a few people supporting you in your
camp sure I understand all the hype
around Yale starring but I'm going to go
with Danny and not just because I want
to keep my job I'm going Sam savian he
is has a second lease on life he's
refreshed he's happy to be here and I
think he'll carry that with him I know
the chat pick nihal sir and they support
you Amman it's okay but nihal seems to
be the heavy favorite amongst the
predictors here so that all makes sense
but we are going to start with a
different matchup the day begins with
Hikaru Nakamura and Yan chest of Duda
defide Fisher random world champion in
Nakamura but the 24 year old who has
actually a very high rapid rating in
yoncest of Duda indeed Robert and you
know we have to point out that that
rapid rating is actually based on his
performance so far in the cgc so you see
that High Rapid rating but that just
shows you how well he's been doing in
this tournament and obviously the
head-to-head you know Nakamura he is the
favorite in this match on paper but you
know those classical results you have to
put it in perspective this is rapid
chess Robert as the time control gets
shorter of course Nakamura himself is so
so talented but yeah stuff Duda he's an
incredible specialist in the rapid
format and I don't think I've seen him
turn in a bad result yet no and he
knocked Magnus Carlson out of the World
Cup he's beaten him in the Champions
chest door so why not beat another world
champion nakara Nakamura and you see the
players they are sitting across from one
that's the only match up Amman where we
have the players here in Toronto in
these quarterfinals so what do you think
the Polish fighter is he gonna land some
punches well first of all you say polish
fighter I was looking at those pieces
there on the on the camera shot Robert
and are we seeing maybe some Polish
peace set the chess.com piece I say red
pieces for black white that's an
interesting choice there and yeah you
mentioned it across from one another
what what you know the intensity of this
match is probably unlike any of the
others
and that was our tournament director
Judah talking to a car talking to
players getting things set so the games
can begin and hikara Nakamura we know he
is as experienced as anybody online and
for Duda you know you mentioned the
pieces I would be distracted by those
pieces like that actually is catching my
eye in a way that I wouldn't be happy
about if I were playing the game so
maybe it's his preference here and maybe
it is that Polish pride yeah I think is
a chance because as we know the players
did get to you know come in Orient
themselves you know uh set the pieces
even set some of the music that they'll
be listening to so I think it's very
interesting that uh we're starting with
the match that's here in Toronto Robert
and here we go the chess.com Global
Championship quarter files are underway
E4 played by Nakamura E5 the response by
Duda and a Petra so he's going for a
more solid approach in the early stages
rather than his you know fighting
opening the night or yeah polish Fighter
the username however you have to keep
things in perspective this this is a
long match they're eight games Robert
starting off with the Petrov of course
with the black pieces totally
understandable you don't want to just
come out of the gate swinging high
flying and you know blunder into a quick
loss for sure and I'm wondering if the
art of preparation might almost be lost
in akara Nakamura he was playing Fisher
random chest the pieces were scattered
on the first and last ranks but now he's
back into the territory of the
candidates these two faced off against
one another Hikaru did win a game
against John chest of Duda when Hikaru
had the white pieces but he was worse in
that game so Duda has proven that he can
handle hikar Nakamura in here in game
one we see trades yeah only the e-files
open and white has this Rook on the
e-file so probably a slight Advantage
for Nakamura in the early going indeed I
think that's to be expected from the
Petrov you often get that slight slight
Edge and it's so slight you know the
engine can see it the engine can
appreciate it but you know even myself
looking at this game I'm seeing a lot of
Trades however a very aggressive move
here Knight to G5 finally we see the
potential for you know if Bishop takes
G5 we might even see the pawn recapture
and that could be the first real
imbalance in the position because in the
Petrov it's so symmetrical to start off
we're kind of waiting for that imbalance
what's it going to be who's going to
take that first decision for sure and we
just see the Knight go out to E3 so dude
did not capture on G5 he wanted to keep
the material balanced and Bishops and
knights the same for each side but white
is kind of gaining the momentum here
this Knight can swing into G4 and the
problem with that move G6 those dark
squares in front of the king become
weakened indeed yeah and I guess the
reason that I think in this position
dude is so comfortable doing that is he
still has that dark Square Bishop so at
some point he could reroute that Bishop
to f8 to G7 or as you highlight it to F6
to G7 as well so although they are
weaknesses I think he's got that Bishop
so he feels comfortable yeah he needs to
be very very careful here and well
Wesley so and Dimitri on draken one
player in Toronto one player in in
Serbia that match is getting underway
right now so Amman we see the opening in
Nakamura and Duda look at these two
players and Wesley so I mean he has the
white pieces what do you expect
well Wesley coming out I mean he's he's
definitely a player that can switch to
the D4 right you know we definitely
expect him to come out with Pawn E4 but
he has tried some D4 in the past and I
wonder with this long matchup you know
eight games Robert are we gonna see
experiments from these players are we
going to see adjustments because I
always think in that longer match style
format that the player who can adjust a
bit better is usually the one that has
that success and this might shock many
people but Dimitri on draken actually
has a head-to-head lead against Wesley
so I think Dania summed it up well that
on draken he's probably the most
underestimated player in this field
indeed Robert but you know what I think
he's the most underestimated by the
public I don't think he's underestimated
by his peers certainly not by Wesley
himself and on draken has just turned in
good result after good result and I
don't think that anyone in this field is
counting him out he beat Fabiano caruana
to get here Robert he's definitely
earned his spot he has and he is playing
the Sicilian in game one so unlike
johnstov who chose E4 E5 symmetrical
Pawn structure instead we see an early
Knight C6 In the Sicilian E6 played by
andrekin and these types of openings it
gives away some of the control of the
dark squares and black if you have to
play the move D6 well there will be a
pawn that's back here but for now we see
look at these dark squares in Black's
position not the end of the world but
just something to note as we see this
game continue indeed what's really
interesting about this opening Robert is
it's a little bit of a hybrid so without
the move A6 we would have something more
like a taimana where you bring the
Knight out and in fact without the night
out and you play A6 you have something
more like a con
but we've actually seen this become more
popular lately kind of combining the two
and you're saying hey I'm gonna let you
make the decision of how you want to
play do you want to capture my knight on
C6 well that's what's happened in this
game so far for sure and we do see Pawn
tension in the center of the board the
E4 D5 pawns black really does not want
to take that pawn on e4 because then
you're saddled with this isolated Pawn
on C6 pawns there's another Pawn's best
friend they want to be an adjacent file
so when I look at these positions I
expect an attack because there's a
bishop on D3 and once that pawn goes up
to E5 we just had black doesn't want to
take the pawn and there it goes yep and
you know speaking of an attack that's
how quickly it can get going right Pawn
E5 Queen out to G4 this is a really well
known I guess you know thematic idea
Pawn on E5 kicks the Knight away from F6
lo and behold Queen G4 follows now if
you Castle in this position as black you
might be walking in to Bishop to H6
Robert this is a you know classic idea
immediately you know gaining a huge
Advantage for sure so that we will not
see because that would cost black in
exchange you'd have to play G6 to avoid
Checkmate then you take the Rook that is
a gain of material so we will not see
that move instead we saw G6 the position
means a bit closed but we're actually
about to have another game get underway
here because the third game about to
begin we will see Anish giri and taymor
rajabov and they will duke it out these
two are friends but today they are foes
indeed it's so hard to make that
distinction uh you know over the board
obviously many many of these chess
players hey it's a small world Robert
these guys are friends colleagues but
definitely competitors and when you
think about how much money is at stake
here 500 000 just for the live portion
from Toronto Robert I mean I'm not sure
how friendly I'm gonna be over the board
yeah I don't think that these two are
friends for today and the next but we
have that game on the right side of the
screen it's about to start the game on
the left side screen still very
interesting between Wesley so and on
draken so Anish giri tame overjob of the
first moves will start a niche with the
white pieces and well over job of
actually historically has been one of
the more fighting players and as we see
we're actually going to continue on the
uh so and on drinking game for now as
the other game gets underway but if we
we'll table that conversation on Geary
and rajabov and the moves are off
this is a very short table you know and
here we go uh you know I love to see all
the games getting underway uh we're able
to catch the beginning of them this is
awesome Geary starts with E4 as well and
you know already having a think there
it's like was he not expecting the move
E4 or was he maybe planning something
against that because he's gone with a
sicilian robber right and I actually
have experienced losing to a niche Geary
on the black side of D4 lines the
Catalan so he might have been surprised
by E4 move one and he choose the
Sicilian Line This is Rasa limo and
rajabov attempted his Sicilian in the
candidates he had a loss to five in a
carwana in the first half of the event
and he brings his Queen out to B6 now we
teach people don't bring your queen out
so early but here it has a direct plan
it's attacking the bishop 1v5 indeed and
you know just so many ways that this can
be dealt with Pawn to A4 Knight to A3 it
may be intending to bring it to C4 in
the future or Robert we could do the
absolutely crazy Bishop back to F1 now
that's actually a serious suggestion and
might surprise some people but the
bishop often goes back to this Square in
this opening leaving The Rook able to
you know shine on the e-file that's
right because the bishop would have been
on the Square where the Rook went after
a castling The Rook has already moved to
the middle on the queen on B6 we don't
like bring our Queens up because they
get attacked and then they have to move
so when this Knight on B1 eventually
lands on C4 that Queen will have to move
for a second time so Anish he's sitting
for a thing he did not expect this move
it's a bit of an obscure Choice by
rajaba and now he's actually ahead on
the clock so if a job spent time to move
one but maybe this is within his
preparation indeed and I think Queen B6
is definitely a move that number one if
you're rajabov you've definitely looked
at and prepared but also if you're on
each Geary in this situation I don't
think you're that concerned by it you
know that it's off the beaten path but
you also get this feeling looking at
Queen B6 like this isn't that dangerous
I just have to find the right way to go
and you know I think he'll be pretty
comfortable once he establishes his plan
is he gonna bring that Bishop back you
know and basically he's gonna start
attacking the queen and harassing it
that's right because it could take the
Knight on C6 as well but I don't think
he wants to do that but our fourth and
final match of the day is about to begin
as well that's the newcomer the second
least on the tournament in sam7 he
might's praying he doesn't need to pray
he's already been receiving the gifts
and he plays against nihal saranaman
this one these two players very young
have not actually played against one
another indeed yeah and you just look at
the the age the youngsters as you know
our panel has indicated playing against
each other right now and 18 years old 21
years old you can see there on the
screen the rapid rating so similar and
look at the most important statistic
they have not played at all Robert that
is what is drawing my attention right
now is that we're seeing a matchup
between two young superstars that
they've never done this before no they
have not and it's funny because they
have so many successes to their names
you would think that they were much
older but they are very strong despite
those early years and we see liftoff D4
played by Sam 7 who gets the white
pieces and we have a Queen's Gambit
decline with an early H6 Allah Magnus
Carlsen delaying the development and
just taking away the G5 Square yeah now
H6 is a really cool move to see and you
know just shows that these players and
many modern players Robert they take
inspiration from others especially of
course the world chess champion himself
H6 tried and that stops Bishop G5 which
is the main idea you don't want to deal
with that move and instead that lets
black Play Bishop to D6 because you
don't have to worry about dealing with a
pin from the bishop on G5 that's right
so the bishop could go on a more useful
diagonal rather than staring into its
own Knight and the queen comes into D3
we were just kind of chastising team
over Jabba for bringing his Queen up
very early in the game right but here
it's a bit different because the queen
on D3 supports the move E2 to E4 you
want to open up the position the Knight
on C6 not so strong here because you
would like a pawn and C5 as well putting
pressure on the center so I'm on that
Bishop on G2 that Catalan Bishop it
would love to have open diagonal a
hundred percent if that diagonal gets
open you really start to see the
difference between the bishop on G2 and
the bishop on C8 for black which is
locked in and not doing anything so love
the idea with Queen to D3 and it's
actually put Nihao in a think tank here
early on well speaking of player in the
thinking look at Wesley so's face and
look at that position on the right side
of the screen here there's a Pawn on G5
a rook on B4 Dimitri on draken locked in
and that Bishop on H6 for Wesley so also
in danger of being locked in yeah you
talk about being locked in how do you
let this happen this early on I mean
when he played Bishop to H6 it actually
made so much sense to me Robert because
look you're actually stopping Black from
castling seemingly permanently but
speaking of permanent I'm not sure how
that Bishop is getting out pawns on G5
and you know what's the most interesting
you're highlighting it The Rook from B4
stops white from playing the move Pawn
to H4 that's my first instinct Robert to
try to save my Bishop but we can't even
do it because the Rook on before can
capture it no I cannot and actually
black can play the move Rook H4 right
now the bishop is under attack code half
to slide into G7 and after Rook G8 black
loses the right to Castle but white will
lose a pawn the only safe square is F6
and after we just capture on F6 with
either piece
you just take twice and black is a pawn
ahead I'm on this looks really bad for
Wesley so and it's such an obscure
maneuver like you know when you were
learning chess as a kid Robert did they
teach you about the Rook A8 to B8 to B4
to H4 maneuver I think I skipped that
lesson well I think there's another guy
who might have skipped it as well and I
think that's Wesley so completely
unexpected and honestly Dimitri on
draken is getting off to the start that
a lot of people might have predicted
based on his run in this tournament thus
far and it just happened right we saw
Queen G4 it's where we left off G6 makes
sense Bishop H6 you cannot Castle but
with Rook B8 and Rook B4 after Queen G3
this move G5 was a shot in the dark so
already in this position it looks like
it was trouble for Wesleyan he brings
his Queen two moves in a row Queen F3
was his second queen move in a row he
just he's not in the right position for
his pieces and Rook H4 is kind of an
obvious move from Dimitri on draken yeah
are you surprised that he's not played
that move already yeah yeah I think in
this moment he's taking his time because
look Robert he probably feels that G5
has been a success anytime you see a
player play Queen G3 and it's shuffled
to F3 you know you've got him where you
want him you know plus uh you see
Wesley's body language here it's not
looking good he doesn't look happy so I
think andrekin's taking his time because
he knows I'm ahead here let's just you
know calm down find the best
continuation and go from there so not
looking to to mess things up when he's
got it in the palm of his hand and
Wesley if he had a free move he would
have put his Pawn on G3 to take away the
score that just indicates that Queen G3
was another mistake he should have went
Queen F3 because then G5 could be met by
this move Pawn to G3 taking away the
trapping square and white would actually
have an advantage so it's very
interesting to note that the queen
choosing a natural square but the wrong
one and now Wesley is going to pay but
Dimitri still has not moved it's
starting to become a little bit
worrisome for him his clock goes under
nine minutes plenty of time for a player
his cattleburg right but why don't we
let him continue to think while we see
Hikaru and John whoa what a position we
have there on the right side of the
screen yeah we're dropping into this
game at a great time because you know
these patchovs they start out a little
slow Robert and you know as as a fan a
chess fan uh people watching right now
they're probably thinking oh pet drive
you know I don't care about that game
let's show some of the others but have a
look at it now after Knight F7 first of
all we got a hanging Knight in the
position we've got a loose E file so
basically that Knight on E6 Bishop E7
I'm looking for tactics around those
pieces and of course the E5 Square
Robert White's pieces are ready to jump
in and we've got this sort of patented
Hikaru Nakamura think where he's like
you know I kind of feel like something's
there yeah he must be feeling that
because Black's King side is in shambles
and it just goes to show that in the
move ago if you took what was a hanging
Knight it would not have been a good
decision Pawn takes Knight looks free
but not all pieces should be captured
this Rook this queen and likely heading
towards a Checkmate because after King
to h8 I simply take this on E6 you're
running out of Defenders as my queen and
my Rook joined the party so that would
have resulted in just just to show how
this could have concluded check the King
goes to G file give another check the
king only has F7 and then once I move my
Rook away your king is being hunted only
squares and that's Checkmate wow and
best believe he didn't want that to be
how game one goes especially using the
Petrov I feel like you know when you
when you essay the Petrov this is not
the kind of position that you want to be
in so even psychologically he's probably
not comfortable here no not at all I
mean Knight D6 to F7 you're retreating
with rumors but that said right we have
enjoyed the look of White's potential
attack black bass is somewhat solid here
with these pawns it's hard to break
through the Knight eventually will be
under attack and if we trade too many
pieces you won't have enough pieces to
Checkmate me with yeah that's a good
point
um I think Knight to E5 looks like an
incredibly logical that's like the first
thing I would think of right jumping
into that great square but the Moon
Knight F7 is played directly against
that that it can capture it immediately
and you know if I'm capturing back with
just a piece then I think that black can
challenge the file bring the Rook from
A8 over to E8 and you know he's worse
but I don't think it's enough for Hikaru
to be satisfied and say look I've got
enough to win this game and it looks
very strange but at some point this King
might even slide up to F7 they're not
enough pieces for white to deliver that
Checkmate G5 is under Black's control so
we'll see how this one goes here but for
now it's looking quite precarious for
the king but a few accurate moves from
yanches of Duda and he may withstand the
pressure and be even able to level up
this position yeah indeed I think you
said it best it's a critical moment in
this game Robert and also we want to
focus on the time right yancha stuff
Duda has only five minutes you're saying
he only needs to play a couple more good
moves hey you're right but does he have
the time to find them that's the big
question but we are going to check in on
the game between Sam Sabian and nihal
Sarah nihal he's got the forehead cam
going on he is diving in to his computer
in front of him and right now it is
nihal's turn and there's a tactical
opportunity for Neil but that will
backfire I think a lot of people see a
night Fork they play a night fork and
Knight C2 in this game hits Queen hits
rook in the corner that would not be the
right decision because this Knight on A1
will get trapped it's not actually Queen
takes D6 right that looks like oh give
me a bishop it's hanging but you'll see
the evaluation bar shift in Black's
favor after that move instead the
retreating move Queen to D2 giving up
this piece in the corner The Rook there
and then taking on D6 the Knight is not
getting out of here it's currently just
one piece for the Rook but it's about to
be incredible that's incredible yeah and
if you just go back a couple moves
Robert was it Nihao that actually
underestimated this because I feel like
he might have thought Knight C2 Queen
takes D6 you calculate that line and
he's expecting to then you know excavate
his knight from A1 he might not have
seen this move Queen D2 that you just
proposed that that's tough move to spot
there's a hanging piece on the board and
you're like no I'll actually take that
later on my own terms right but that
goes the strength of Sam sebian he's
saying well looks can be deceiving it
looked like I was out of this tournament
but no no no I'm right back in here so
Sam Sabian he's putting up a big test to
Neil right now and so this bishop is
actually hanging and it goes back to E7
just as I was to ask him on should it
retreat but it doesn't feel good to
retreat in this position and this bishop
on G2 is very happy yeah you can just
see the difference in the pieces you
have the bishop on G2 and the bishop on
C8 Robert and just quick look at those
two and you can tell who is happier plus
when you have that Knight on B4 the
whole intention was to play Knight C2 so
if Sam came up with a you know
well-calculated variation where that
wasn't possible that's sort of like you
know he's won the battle but the war is
still ongoing for sure and it's going to
be a long-term Advantage with this
bishop on G2 compared to its counterpart
on C8 the little things add up in a
position like this but we do have a big
thing going on here with the chess.com
Global Championship it is the
quarterfinals four matches at once so
why don't we bring all four games on
screen for you to look at look at this
view Iman we have all eight players the
the forehead cam right I always like
that sometimes the five head cam if
they're making exceptionally good moves
but of these positions here I mean the
one between Wesley so and Dimitri on
Drake and that continues to catch my
attention because look at the eval bar
Wesley so looks like he's going down in
game one he does that that game has been
such a shock and it's incredible we have
this Rook on H5 in that game I mean
every game so far I feel like there's
been tactical opportunities so it's been
really really exciting to check these
games Robert and uh honestly I think the
uh the one you pointed out might be the
first one done for today I mean if we
just look at the position white is now
down a pawn yeah there is an attack
going this Rook that was on A8 went to
B8 B4 H4 h that's a journey but it's not
stop believing in this attack and I
already like to move Knight F3 check why
not go for more yeah I mean this could
pivot from you know oh I'm just gonna
win this bishop or maybe win a pawn to
actually I'm gonna Checkmate you because
you know if if Wesley goes all out to
try to save this Beast or save his Pawn
sorry that's not gonna work there could
be sacrifices on the king side here
Robert and this game could really end
with a bang yeah I'm looking at this
queen I'm trying to go to H3 I know that
diagonal doesn't work but I will play
the move E5 and the big point is this
bishop is loose on H6 so you can't just
go Queen E3 and take because after the
move Queen E3 you're not threatening
Queen takes F3 the bishop 186 is hang so
black and play E5 take my pawn and take
your Bishop thank you so much for the
material yeah no that's a really
convincing position he's actually gone
for something that I guess is a little
more tempered shall we say you and me
Robert we get to throw the pieces around
here and the analysis Booth but Bishop
D6 great move Look At That Knight on C3
it has nowhere to go be E5 D5 E4 all
covered Bishop is on E2 there's so much
domination going on if you look at the
black pawns they're covering every
square that white might want to put a
piece it's true and now the sacrifice on
G3 are thing to look at that's where the
bishop came in line with the queen but
let's uh leave Wesley so to his
struggles unfortunately for him in this
game we're going to take a look at Geary
and rajaba we have that board on the
right side of the screen right now and
I'm on that position remains a bit
closed but that could be bad news for
the Bishops when you have Bishops you
like an open board and that Bishop on G4
well that Bishop could get trapped if
you're not careful yeah and hang on a
second how the heck that Bishop get
there Robert that really caught me off
guard I mean I'm used to the bishop on
H4 and maybe I'm used to a bishop on G4
but not with a knight on F3 it's kind of
like you know I got somewhere and then I
sealed off the exit so I can't get back
so I am concerned about that we can just
immediately look at the move H5 Pawn to
H5 that trap the piece so obviously
that's what's going through these
players Minds right now and that's why
Knight D2 is played let's clear space
for this bishop to retreat and the eval
Bar says white is better and I'm sure
the players are looking at this saying
well Black's piece is a bit cramped in
there a Ford A5 at some point maybe a
knight will come to C4 things like that
but it's not that clear there's no exact
plan that the players are about to
execute so I feel like rajabov can't be
too unhappy with what's unfolding agreed
no this is this is what you know the
engine might look at and say clear
Advantage for white but the players are
definitely not feeling that way I'm sure
that Geary likes his position and to be
fair I like it as well but Black's got
just as much counter play options you
mentioned A5 for white well hang on if
black can orchestrate maybe an F5 or a
G5 expansion those pawns can be just as
dangerous on the king side that's right
and I think a move that rajaba should
consider at some point is Bishop F6 you
typically don't like giving up your fee
and Kettle peas but I always say this
when you have less space you want fewer
pieces because that way your other
pieces can breathe so Rook B8 is clearly
a way to stop the move A5 or at least
make it less tempting but I do like a
niche giri's position he is going to
continue to squeeze so this one a little
bit more close a little bit more just
strategic in nature yeah let's see if we
have anything more tactile as we bring
up all four games that are going on
maybe one of these will catch your eye a
little bit more yeah I mean we know
Robert gotta be honest the people love
their tactics they love their fighting
positions and uh that one might get more
exciting in the future we remember
hikaru's game started off as a Petrov
and then it got exciting that can happen
in so many of these positions right and
well speaking of Hikaru and Duda let's
go back there that was our game that
started first it kicked off the cgc
finals here in Toronto and as we look at
the position it nothing really looks
unexpected based on how the game is
developed but you must like White's
position here look at this bishop on d8
not really doing much this E5 square is
called a Transit Square it's a turnstile
it's whites for the taking you you grab
my Bishop well thank you very much in
comes my knight so Amman how can Judah
save this position the interesting thing
about this position Robert is
before the move Rook H7 I was almost
going to make a comment that I can't see
Black's pieces being better than they
are and in those positions you start to
feel like oh everything white does is
improving the position and there's
nothing I can do to match that and if
your opponent is consistently playing
you know bit better improving moves than
you then their position should be just
getting better over time and that's a
scary feeling as you know the time gets
lower and mistakes can happen so I
actually think Hikaru is cementing his
his edge here I think he's increasing it
and what we're seeing with that Rook on
H7 is that it might be misplaced right
you would love to get a queen out there
and deliver a Checkmate but there's a
knight in the way so Black's pieces
stepping on each other's toes meanwhile
the e-file is open please take me on E2
cesicaro the queen will take back and
watch out because this open file is all
white and that's bad news when there are
two open files white can use his Duda
cannot use his in return it means clear
Advantage for Karu indeed yeah this is a
what we call operational open file and
exactly what you're describing has
happened now suddenly you want to take
that rook and say oh no I was kidding
about the attack bring it back to the
middle of the board but it's not that
easy to reroute the pieces it takes time
and everything about hikaru's position
seems to be getting better and better I
think this might be a win right off the
bat Robert it looks like it and things
seem to be getting better for Dimitri on
draken as well we're highlighting how
Wesley so's Bishop looked trapped
earlier and things got from bad to worse
in that game so we're gonna you see it
here on screen there were sacrifices on
G3 you call that Amman and it's just a
matter of time between before Wesley so
has to resign capitulate and lose game
one yeah I mean in this position I think
it's more a formality of choice because
the Rook can take on H2 but so can the
bishop and in cases like this sometimes
it's the bishop that's the more
dangerous one because you take with the
bishop and then you want to just remove
it and guess what if you take on H2 and
remove that Bishop that's going to be a
Checkmate Robert right not just check
but check mate and we should point out
that in the current position black has
one rook and white has two so your
sacrifice idea right did come to
fruition and the way it happened was
with a rook leading the way wow because
he wants to go for H2 it's not about the
material here he wants to go for
checkmate the king safety is Paramount
and as we see Rook G1 just trying to get
Pieces away it doesn't even really carry
a threat to it and on draken he's been
doing this whole game when he has an
obvious move he still is sitting and
thinking trying to find The Knockout I
think that's such it just shows mature
class like that's when you spend your
time you don't wait till you have that
losing position and then try to invest
your time trying to you know find a
remedy it's not going to be there you
want to find the remedy when you know it
is there and that's where he's spending
his time I think that's a great decision
it's worked out from so far and guess
what Robert I think he's made the best
move in the position Bishop takes on H2
setting up Bishop to well it's a pickum
any Square for checkmate and the big
problem for White is you need to get
this Rook on H5 off the board so you may
think let me try to trade it bring my
Rook to G5 and then black plays a game
of keep away you play Rook G5 please
please please let me take you let's
trade let's do something like that and
The Rook simply slides away I think you
can just go up to H3 and say uh wait how
how are you gonna touch this exactly no
no no no no my Pawn covers G2 your queen
can't attack it yep and you know the
aftermath is that black has so much
material that's just sitting in reserve
Queen on C7 Bishop on C8 so there are a
lot of lines where you know white might
be able to survive this Checkmate but
you're gonna have to give up so much
material that the game's just unplayable
after that no and we may see a
resolution soon but other games heating
up as well so Dimitri on Drake and
looking to take his first game look at
Anish Gear with Team over job of the
eval bar swinging in rajamas favor so it
was a closed position things have opened
up and that seems to be bad news for
Anish gear on the board and also on the
clock he's down quite a bit of time and
you know what this position actually
looks pretty normal except guess what
that e-pawn it feels like it just got
plucked off the board like where did it
go because now the F Pawn for black has
as an easy path to F5 and there's a
scary idea of black playing Pawn nav 5
and then maybe Pawn to G5 Pawn to F4 and
slowly just kicking all those pieces
back to I don't know where H2 I mean
it's gonna get really cramped for white
so Anish just dropped his E Pawn here
and suddenly it's tame more of a job off
for choice and it feels like we're
playing Space Invaders right just pieces
going forward so let's just dial it back
a few moves to see where that E4 Pawn
went because that was his first move of
the game it's an important Pawn we left
off you know the Knight came back the
black Rook slid over and then at this
moment that's what happened wow B5 Pawn
was captured and that seems to be an
inexplicable Choice by Anish giri the
response was incredibly obvious when
Bishop takes E4 so he took a flank Pawn
for giving up a Central Pawn and not
just that amount he had to give up B2 as
well so I'm very surprised by the
sequence of moves indeed because I I
think it might have been more of a
emotional reaction like he played the
move A5 I don't think he saw B5 was
working as well as as it does and after
it was played he didn't want to let it
just sit there as like a you know haha I
got to play B5 so he snapped it off but
that was the wrong decision and now we
mention it rajaba he's got that extra
pun but the queen on C7 is still in a
pin so that's C Pawn right now is pinned
uh D4 is an aggressive move I don't
think that rajaba feels like he's
totally winning or anything of the sort
but we know we play with the black
pieces it's about equalizing then going
from there he's already more than
equalized and he needs to use the clock
as a weapon now so her job of trying to
make more of this position than just
that extra Pawn Hikaru Nakamura and Yan
chest of dude they start at the top of
the clock they were the first game to
get underway and it's getting exciting
there we know that Hikaru had a big
Advantage earlier in the game and look
at this Amman I see a rook Knight in
Bishop for a queen and three pawns that
is not the type of material imbalance
you see every day so as I look at this
here this position it seems to be one
where Hikaru is going to push for a win
but this gets confusing yeah and don't
forget the time like every decision that
yanchisoft Duda makes here is with 10
seconds on the clock Robert it's so hard
to handle all the possible squares the
queen can check from these pawns rushing
up the board when you've got that time
pressure that's right blunders happen
there's only a couple seconds of
increment Hikaru Nakamura he's in the
lead here he has many pawns to work with
but Duda he's keeping his pieces
together Compact and as long as he
doesn't allow Pawn promotion next few
moves maybe he'll be able to gain a
couple seconds on the clock and we'll
see moves like Queen G6 on one side
maybe Queen back to D3 then Queen to A6
it's just hard to keep track of all the
Pawns in the position so we what Hikaru
is looking to do is move those pawns up
but be careful Robert he doesn't want
them to get stuck on light squares the
dark squares are where Duda is going to
look to blockade those pawns it's a
really good point and look at the
corresponds on those dark squares
limiting the scope of the bishop he does
not want those pawns to be stuck in
their trucks he can play F5 five you can
start sending these pawns off the board
I think that's a good decision but
what's an even better decision is to
spend your time while you are ahead so
hikara knows he's a good position he
doesn't need to waste his opportunities
he gives a check on F5 so I thought the
other piece could go there he might
leave with the g-pawn and that's exactly
how you know everyone pay attention
that's how you advance those pawns when
you're advancing two pass pawns against
a bishop look at the color of the bishop
here it's a it's on a dark Square so you
want your pawns to advance on dark
Square so after G4 side by side the next
move would be G5 whoa when he played C4
giving away a pawn then D5 trading on
pieces but blacks are coming to life and
this King on F2 it's not going to get
checkmated but there could be a series
of checks that allows black to stay in
the game indeed and I think the
simplification is kind of what Duda
wants the more pawns on the board the
more targets for that Queen to hit and
there goes the knights D4 this Pawn may
eventually go to A5 to be protected by
the bishop and for now dude he's keeping
Pace in the clock still at about 10
seconds very impressive display of speed
yeah and some point hikar's gonna have
to make that decision when is it time to
play Pawn to G4 as soon as that happens
like the floodgates open Black's gonna
Target these puns with Knight back to E6
looking to get into all these you know
checking squares so that king and queen
have to be careful Robert we're all on
the lookout for that deadly night fork
for sure and now the bishop switches
diagonals and there goes the a pawn so
their Pawns in the both sides of the
board here but white does not want is to
allow those pawns to get stuck in place
Knight C6 can come back to stop the a
pawn but that loses sight of the f and g
Pawn so the Knight has to make the
decision it is a short range piece not
an easy choice for yonchista yeah the
bishop is making its intention clear
it's blockading but the bishop is now
committed to the queen side the Knight
on D4 as you mentioned has to pick a
side as soon as you go Knight to C6 and
drop back and hit the queen while the
queen is so mobile it can go from side
to side and the g-pawn will suddenly run
up the board and there's Knight C6 going
after the pawn A6 whichever Queen B7 and
Duda doesn't care because his Knight and
Bishop cover the A7 Square so so a month
I would be very nervous out of this
position he has no time he needs to make
these choices and this King seems to be
able to Dart away to G4 yeah that's why
you advance your pawns on dark squares
Robert you can use the light squares for
your king and he's got this amazing
shelter that you're building right and
here goes the king and there goes the
evaluation bar it is completely winning
now for Hikaru Nakamura and he I think
he's on the verge of winning I think
Judah might resign in just a few seconds
in fact this moment could be nearing the
last because the g-pawn the a pawn how
do you stop them all there's too many
simply the G Pawn the a pawn the queen
supports G7 and A7 and Duda says no more
resigns in game one and Hikaru Nakamura
finishes with his King in the center of
the board triumphantly wow and what a
victory in game one for akara Nakamura
the winning does not stop for the Fisher
random world champion he steals game one
and as we see here Nakamura takes a lead
in it's an eight game match so today
will just be the first four of the eight
but ikaro Nakamura he's all smiles as
you see in that picture yeah and you can
see the score there just to keep
everyone updated Nakamura winning game
one of course taking that early lead
against Duda I mean it's got to feel
good to start an event like this Robert
for sure and I'm looking at the chat
here in the game between Wesley so and
Dimitri on draken as we head right back
into the action there was a draw offered
by Wesley declined by andrichen and what
in the world how is this game still
going what is the material count it
looks like white with two Rooks black
still with one and how many extra pawns
four for black so four pawns for a rook
here mod I didn't realize this was math
class uh Robert I I don't know what the
heck is going on here how did that not
end I thought there was meat on the
board first of all that must have been
an incredible defensive task by Wesley
so but that couldn't have happened
without a mistake we know that on draken
had such an edge but he is still
declining the draw as you mentioned he's
not willing to admit that this game is a
draw yet you better be careful because
if you keep declining the draw you might
lose it you bring your king to B8
already Rook B4 check opening the
Queen's diagonal results in a win for
white so Dimitri has to accept the draw
he does in fact do that but he's spoiled
and wow huge opportunity a huge
opportunity and you feel like those are
the moments that sometimes Define a
match when you look back and you know
maybe this match gets decided by a
single game you think back to this game
and that's the one in question yeah a
win with the black pieces would have got
him out to hotstar but look at Wesley so
he can hardly believe it I think he's
just trying to contain all of his
emotions right now because he was on the
verge of defeat that whole game through
yeah I was gonna say there might be a
wry smile behind that hand Robert but uh
Wesley is definitely breathing a sigh of
relief in that game although he had the
white pieces he got off to a terrible
start and on draken has got to be
kicking himself for missing that
opportunity and at the end of the day
scoreboard says it all half half doesn't
matter how it happened the draw was
secured by Wesley so he is tied with
Dimitri on draken and now Anish giri and
Timo rajabov they still are slugging it
out in game one and Iman I feel like
every time we tune into that matchup
between those friends the position is
completely different
exactly yeah you know earlier we tuned
in and it was like where is the pawn
right and then you know we're obviously
want to jump into that game here because
I think with all the games starting to
wrap up this one looks like it might be
the next one Robert
yeah and a nice gear right here we see
you know he's on camera he's uh playing
this he's very intense and the game
ended in a draw so I think the players
they're just looking wait a second is
that the repetition I think it is it was
a three-time repetition but despite that
pawn down Anish actually had the avenge
according to the evaluation bar but
that's neither here nor there because
the game finished with a split Point wow
yeah that's such a and you know that is
definitely a result that I can tell you
Robert I did not expect uh you know
looking at that position earlier and how
pawns seem to be dropping and things uh
changing every time we looked at it that
is a very surprising result but it's
interesting to see the results coming in
all of a sudden it's like everyone sort
of had this uh agreement it's like oh
yeah guys we're all gonna wrap up right
now yeah it's this time and a flurry
these games are ending but this one
seems like it might go on for a while
because nihal sarin down under a minute
on the clock Sam seven at almost three
minutes and with the bishop pair now we
can see everybody can see the eval bar
is at the middle completely even but the
eval bar does not tell the whole story
who can attack the other player's pawns
whose King will venture the center This
is the End Game the king can use the
weapon indeed and I think the eval bar
especially in end games like this it's
important to remember that it it tells
the story if things happen you know the
way they should but things don't always
happen that way Robert we got time
ticking down less than a minute for
nihal sarin here the bishop pair for Sam
Sevin I think Sam's got a great chance
to make use of these Bishops and you
know look to score a potentially a full
point from a position that would be so
frustrating for nihal to spoil and we
see nihal on screen there his head is
always right at the computer trying to
figure out all the complications and now
Knight C2 great move threatening a fork
of Pawn so if you're not careful you
lose them and if you play them with E3
you shut in your Bishop you don't want
to do that so the Knight prefers pawns
on one side of the board the Bishops
love both sides because they're long
long-range pieces so the fact that there
are a pawns and b-pawns on the board
should favor Sam's chances that's right
and you know I'll make this point again
I always love to point this out for
anyone watching when you're playing
against the bishop pair you'll have one
Bishop whatever color that Bishop is
look to trade Bishops of the same color
so if you're in this position with the
black pieces your knee house aren't
you've got the dark Square Bishop look
at the position try to trade for that
dark Square Bishop as you've highlighted
if he was able to do that it might flip
around and suddenly Nihao might have the
better chances to win in that end game
Robert that's true and already that the
king F1 black can start forcing White's
pawns forward and this is a good thing
when the end game I want to get a queen
right but the pawns are in front of one
another so you can't just push to the
other side black has those pawns so if
you can keep harassing those pawns maybe
you can even pick one off yeah that's a
great point you would love to have all
those pawns back and then commit them
later when you want to on your terms but
the Knight might be able to harass those
pawns so far forward that things just
become like a stale deadlock and that's
probably why we see that eval bar so
close to the middle right and we love
Bishops as long range pieces we keep
talking about that but the bishop on G2
is not participating all the way on the
queen side so for nihal he went Bishop
E7 and in fact the eval bar is sliding a
little bit up in white server I think we
can kind of ignore that for the moment
unless there's some huge blunder but I
believe the reason why is that now white
doesn't have to keep pushing those pawns
forward they're safe where they are and
now the king can join E3 King E2 King D3
and then watch out because the king's
not gonna stop it wants to go to A6 and
I was about to talk about this move
Bishop to F6 this is a human move a
practical move we I just talked about
trading those Bishops but he's done so
by conceding maybe the maximum right
he's doubling those pawns the H Pawn
will be isolated and on its own over
there so you've got this decision if
you're Sam do you take that Bishop
knowing that that's what black
ultimately wants and then is it weighed
by the fact that those pawns get doubled
he decides not to do you like that
decision Robert no I think with both
players in time trouble but particularly
seven seconds I think you take on F6 and
keep this Pawn F7 that's a light Square
you have a light Square Bishop so I
think you can trade then bring your king
out and then all of a sudden black needs
to be careful but for now it seems like
Sam he's taking his time he's being very
deliberate right his time Advantage is
about to dissipate indeed and I think if
he doesn't take on F6 there's not much
progress to be made I think eventually
he's gonna decide Bishop takes F6 is the
way certainly you can't lose that
position surely Robert no way so Bishop
takes F6 is a good way to play on zero
risk there Sam now under 15 seconds is
getting low on the clock for him we know
how nehal is the top rated player in
bullet on chess.com and Sam he might
just make the draw because he's running
out of time yeah I agree with you it's a
tough decision to make with four seconds
I think it's it's exactly as as you just
called it the draw has been agreed and
he is quickly out of his chair Robert it
was just not the right time to
potentially make a decision that he
wasn't ready for and he'll relax he took
a breath for the first time all game he
was very stressed there he was down on
the clock positioned slightly worse but
he managed to secure the half point so
we do have an even match up between Sam
Sevin and nihal Saron the two youngest
competitors in the field they're playing
that old school game with an ending
indeed and you know they definitely took
their time in in that position I think
that Sam in a later stage of this match
would definitely have taken on F6 Robert
I just feel like game one you know get
the Jitters out you definitely don't
want to you know blow things in an end
game where you know it's objectively a
draw so I think this was a decision made
because it's game one I think that's
right and I think we saw something
similar in some of the other games it's
not too much risk taking we did see some
decisive games in fact well I guess in
the end there was only one it felt like
we would get three or four even but
Hikaru Nakamura he obtained the upper
hand early he did not let himself
relinquish that Advantage but I'm on the
other games we saw three draws yeah and
I think we just have to speak about you
know who who's the luckiest here and
that has got to be Wesley so Wesley
escaping with that half Point result
that's got to feel Robert like a full
point to him NACA obviously scored the
real full point he's gonna be feeling
great starting off his event and you
know giri rajabov a draw where I thought
there was something to play for and
maybe also in sevi and sarin but I think
that those draws kind of came because
you know what it's game one let's not
take too much risk yeah some natural
results there but the draw between
Wesley Stone Dimitri on Dragon this is
really where we left off them on it's
completely winning for black not just
because the evaluation Bar says so the
engine's roaring in Dimitri on Dragon's
favor I can hear it yeah the engine is
talking but that's Checkmate yeah King's
gonna Checkmate how in the world did
Wesley so survive this it's incredible
like first of all chess is a you know
it's a two-way game so you cannot
survive this position without indeed a
mistake from your opponent but that's
nothing to take away from Wesley he kept
finding the most tenacious defense and
after Rook G1 Bishop takes H2 like if I
was a betting man I'd say it's over it
looks over the King goes out to D7 and
here after Bishop E3 there's a discover
check and this is what happened he was
A5 on the other side of the board a move
that gives away the entire Advantage
instead Queen to E5 bringing the queen
towards the center and over towards the
king that will help lead to defeat I
can't really blame it's a hard move to
play but A5 was a step in the wrong
direction and after Knight E4 bring a
piece not just to the defense but maybe
to the attack the advantage is going out
the window and it actually petered out
into the draw that we saw completely
logical given that mistake yeah
incredible and you know I'm even looking
at that eval bar as you're playing the
moves wait a second and I'm thinking
wait a minute wasn't there an
opportunity missed the other way he just
wasn't even thinking about it he was so
happy to even be playing this game he
didn't realize there could have been a
win on the board oh my goodness I
thought it was live I thought there's a
repetition was force yeah but Queen A7
check leads to Checkmate this King
cannot go forward because the Knight it
cannot step back because of the Rook
that leaves Bishop B7 that's Checkmate
that was checkmen too isn't that basic
Robert I mean look we're we're not
supposed to be too harsh on the players
here but you have to when Queen A7 is
there Robert that's a simple Checkmate
in two moves oh my gosh nerves got the
best of West that he was just about to
lose the game he could have flipped the
script completely but this is where we
saw the uh still winning if he played
Rook takes D5 check and then Queen A7 so
that Checkmate idea was there it just
didn't come to mind can't really blame
him because he spent the whole game
defending but for Wesley so he'll need
to prove better in the next couple games
because Dimitri on Drake and won't let
Avengers like that slip no I think both
of these players you know have the game
one Jitters so to speak because
opportunities missed from both sides now
that I see the full game along with the
chat I think we can all agree at some
point both players deserve to win
what an amazing hour of games we just
had it's just the first game of the
matches so it's just exceptional stuff
and brave means private browsing and so
much more by default Brave blocks ads
and trackers on every page and video you
visit even on YouTube no ads means up to
three times faster page loads faster
streaming and faster playback it means
35 longer battery life while saving on
mobile data and internet bandwidth for
Android iOS and desktop get the best
browser for gamers streamers and
creators switch in 60 seconds at
brave.com chess we're gonna take a quick
break when we come back we'll play the
game twos in all four matches at the
chess.com Global Championship twitch
subscribers we have some new exclusive
content for you from Toronto during the
break do not miss it
foreign
[Music]
thank you
try to write a little more allegedly
this time yeah yeah don't worry I got
you do you though
take two I was born in Vancouver but as
fond as I am oh God my voice is already
cracking okay I'm gonna do this again
and the thirst for Bros
do you agree with that statement I don't
know Sports can you name a single
Canadian team
Canucks
Vancouver baby my wife you're in the
right in the right place
it's really hard to wear a blazer and be
professional and stuff you know what I
agree with xqc
he's like I meant to call Andrea she was
so annoying like the most annoying but
it was because I was roasting no it was
because she's annoying oh it's getting
hot again Alex could you fan the
director please I can't do it I need you
to Fan me can you go I can't do it
anymore it's too hard I'm just gonna
keep bothering you stop you're gonna
break something sister it's already a
little broken in there let's go all
right
[Music]
my name is Ethan Curry
uh you know we all have nicknames
Chicago is naturally where I'm born and
raised so that's how I got the name I
guess they call me the muscle I'm the
one with the passion I'm always looking
for a good fight you know evidently
it'll make a difference man that's
Checkmate coming up they don't matter
what we're trying to do is to let them
know hey we're playing down here in
Houston Texas and if you come down here
help step in trust me we're going to
beat you you better bring your game
we in Toronto for the cgc is going down
I hope y'all hype because I'm high we
here at the cgc of James Cancer the
third and uh we're about to go try some
poutine here in Canada
[Music]
let's try it let's try it hold up
it's amazing it's amazing I love it
was absolutely amazing first time trying
it definitely recommend it three minute
all right let's do it okay A little
London system
all right you'll move there it is
they actually played no you played good
though played much better than I than I
thought right great game brother thanks
Ethan thank you man at least you are
here at the CDC watching the film
content's gonna be amazing the team is
amazing we'll see you guys later
foreign
welcome back to Toronto that's the cgc
championship trophy which will be
awarded to our champion this Monday
that's certainly pretty nice but also
rewarding is the prize pool which starts
with a first prize of two hundred
thousand dollars
wow look at that 200 000 Champion 100
000 to the runner-up 50 Grand to third
and fourth and fifth through eighth all
get 25
000 in cash it's the biggest first place
prize of the year in chess it is a great
prize fund indeed and well I'm
Grandmaster Robert Hess again with
Grandmaster Mont Hamilton Iman that was
a fun first set of games it certainly
was Robert I think we got a little bit
of everything we witnessed firsthand
that the players are nervous we saw that
the human element but we also saw some
great chats some Fighting Chess and we
got a decisive result in Hikaru Nakamura
taking out yanchisoft Duda in game
number one shockingly only one decisive
game based on how they were developing
but hikar Nakamura up top for a reason
he gets a win over John the other three
matches between Wesley Stone and Drake
and Geary and rajabov sam7 were drawn so
exciting games for sure the players you
know they were nervous as you said
absolutely Robert I I think we saw that
in a few of the matchups even the gear
Theory and rajabov match which we didn't
talk about as much I think Geary
for sure in game two of Hikaru Nakamura
and Yan chist of Duda is going to get
underway shortly and this we see here
the insights between the players only 40
games in Rapid for Yan chistav Duda but
the accuracy is there for the Polish
fighter absolutely yeah the accuracy is
is such an interesting statistic because
that is what I think of when I think of
yancha stuff due to even that game that
he just played Robert I don't feel like
it was that inaccurate that just looked
like a slow grind from Nakamura so you
see those Wild Games those end games
from the players you know are we gonna
see more of those two things because
that last game although it started you
know a little slow Robert it did get
extremely exciting and no surprise there
that car knock more thrives in Wild
games that position started calm and
then it got open and a card Nakamura was
able to maximize so he is jumped out to
one nil lead but we have yonchist of
doodle with the white pieces so he gets
white and game what do you think he's
gonna do yeah the thing is this is such
a long match and you have to keep
reminding everybody watching because the
eight game format Robert is not too
common these players might be more used
to four games where if you lose a game
the onus is on you to almost bounce back
immediately but I think we're in a
different situation right now I don't
think that John stuff Duda needs to you
know fight back in game number two
immediately go all out for a win that's
not the case at all in fact I think
stability just getting a good game out
maybe a solid opening Advantage is what
he needs to do and he started with D4
okay and Hikaru knock more plays E6
rather than his vintage King's Indians
he has a lead why should he take any
risk in the opening either and it's
becoming a Catalan Queens game but
accepted type of position the pawn on C4
is gone the bishop on G2 is very happy
but that's slicing across the position
but sometimes players try to cling onto
this Pawn on C4 so I'm on in the early
stage here we see the Contours of the
position the light square is under
control from the car's pawns but the
center under dude is control indeed and
I I think it in this situation we've
we've got Nakamura with the black pieces
playing what is a solid opening but also
one with a lot of poison you mentioned
you can try to hang on to that pawn and
you know although it's theoretically
based it's still pretty scary when you
realize hang on I'm actually not getting
that pawn back and a lot of times that's
what happens in this opening you don't
get it back in fact you play for the
imbalance you play for the compensation
and you spend the majority of the game
potentially down upon it's not for
everyone and the compensation is the
center because D takes C4 took a pawn
away from the center white actually has
two pawns to one that sounds like
White's up a pawn but only at that part
of the board black has four on two from
the a to the C files and the B4 Square
not under blacks control because there's
opponent A4 so white has given up
control some important squares but it is
quite likely if Duda wants it he can
make moves like Queen C2 bring the
Knight to D2 and scoop this Pawn right
back up that's right in all likelihood
that pawn will be recaptured and what we
have is this structure that blacks
develop B7 and C6 pawns against the
bishop on G2 one of the best pawn
structures that you can have against
that Bishop so Naka going for a very
solid opening here but if you're Duda I
feel like you've got the imbalance you
want you've got the center for yourself
to control I think this is the
imbalanced game where I give a slight
Edge to the white pieces this is the
game that he wants in game two and I
just saw Chad telling Judah he has to
move and I was just about to say Hikaru
at exactly the amount of time he started
with yeah and Duda has spent a minute
and a half and Counting trying to figure
out this position so he's caught by
surprise by something that Hikaru has
done but his position does look good
it's very natural indeed very natural
but the moves are not coming out very
naturally for for Duda in this case so
he's spending his time and you know if
we think back to that last game yes
Hikaru had that Advantage the whole game
but the time also played an important
role it was not clear to me that those
three pieces versus a queen we're gonna
lose at the time the time was definitely
a factor Knight C3 so Duda says I don't
even want that pawn back he's trying to
protect the E4 Pawn push but that B4
Square we're highlighting is under
Black's control why not develop and take
away the E4 Pawn push because we'll
remove the guard and it just doesn't
really feel like that natural Square I
was thinking Knight A3 3 Knight B to D2
like don't we want to take that pawn
back on C4 Knight C3 feels funny but at
the same time maybe he's just not caring
about that pawn he's saying look Pawn E4
and potentially Pawn to D5 we could see
a really early Central break well he may
not literally care about that pawn but
he may find himself regretting this
decision Wesley so and Dimitri on draken
are about to get their second game
underway and they had the most hectic
game of all Topsy Turvy one and if we
look into the insights between these two
players no surprise to me here Dimitri
on draken prefers the end games down the
bottom of the screen but Wesley so one
of the most accurate players in chess
history and it's it's so interesting to
look at these statistics because you
look at the Wild games and you say Okay
Dimitri and Drake you know it has more
Wild games and then you look at the end
games and he's got more of those as well
it's like wait a minute the guy just
plays the whole package and when you
think about it that's almost what
happened in the first game it was
insanely wild but it was lit liquidating
near the end so he didn't complete that
attack will we see another crazy one
like that I have to say no Robert I
think these players are going to reel it
in in game number two because that was
just too crazy to start things off and
no when you think of clash of styles
these two have similar Styles they
prefer quieter positions not tactical
melees and yet went to
end game aficionados go at it they get
the wildest game of the event thus far
and we see that oh Dimitri on draken he
goes for his little setup here the
bishop on C1 not very happy it's kind of
like a French offense for for white and
I feel offended by the look of this
bishop on C1 but in all seriousness
Amman this kind of opening it might be a
strategic play from on Dragon saying
Wesley is in more practice than him he
plays much more over the boy classical
chess let's avoid Theory altogether yeah
avoiding it all together and you know
almost looks like a London where you
just kind of forgot to bring that Bishop
out to F4 but the move C3 definitely
indicates his plan for the rest of the
opening that Bishop is no longer going
to go in the B2 Square which looked
likely a couple moves ago now it's going
to get out to F4 or to G5 the white
Bishop certainly looks like it's going
to D3 one of the best squares but you
know we've actually got an opportunity
for black to take that option away with
Bishop to F5 so I'm looking at that move
right now Robert as a clear candidate
and this is a transport position we've
gone from Kali system into caracon this
exact position can stem from the caracon
where white captures on D5 and black C
Pawn captures back on the Square so this
is familiar territory for players and
Wesley so not really a Carroll Khan
player so I think this is a good
strategy employed by dimitriandrakin
indeed that's why you'll see some
players that always start with a
specific move they might try something
else but it's against what they know
their opponent is bringing to the table
and transpositions in chess are how you
can trick and get your opponent out of
what they want to do and in to what you
want to do well a slow start to this
game with Dimitri on drinking on the
clock and while he thinks the matchup
between Anish giri and Timor rajabov is
about to start these two friends drew it
was not a friendly game one the result
was split but here as we look into game
two the job of not very active in Rapid
chess on chess.com but look at that
accuracy among completely knotted up
that's pretty accurate yep right there
as you can see the the obviously the
total games to me that is what I'm
focusing on here Robert I see that you
know Tamar rajabov just simply not as
active but it feels like whenever he is
active he's performing well he certainly
is and he beat yondapon machine to get
here while Anish giri he might have had
the match of the entire event the
opponent not over 2700 but when he
cleaned swept roundek said wani in the
second round that was a sight to behold
so in each giri the number one player
from Holland he is locked in in this
matchup I think it was a jittery start
both players made some mistakes but as
the job of gets the white pieces here in
game two I'm on I feel like Anish he's
gonna have to find his food footing real
fast because rajaba does not let people
go twice he doesn't and the thing about
Timor rajabov that's maybe
underappreciated is he really
capitalizes on his chances you know he's
not necessarily fighting super super
hard for the result every single game
he'll have some games just like every
chess player where yeah you know you're
happy to make a draw with the black
pieces that's normal but when you give
him that opportunity wait does he ever
pounce on it and take it away so Geary
does have to be careful not to
overextend and we're getting a really
imbalanced opening Robert right off the
Jump yes because white has the bishop
pair top level players love themselves a
good Bishop pair but is this bishop pair
that good that's the big question only
white has a dark Square Bishop sure it
can go out to G5 you think let me pin
that Knight but notice the pin was just
blocked on this other diagonal here so
black already threatens the move Knight
takes D4 getting rid of the piece in
between the bishop and queen the queen
usually loses that Showdown indeed and I
think that's why Pawn takes D5 was
played because if you bring the queen
back to C2 which was just played before
capturing well black might get ambitious
and take on C4 we should just talked
about that in the other game the Hikaru
game you can take that pawn on C4 and
just hang on for dear life I think he
was ready to do that there so Pawn takes
in the center and now white has played
Bishop G5 Robert before playing E3 so
that both both Bishops can develop
harmoniously and I'm gonna steal one
from the Iman Hamilton Playbook here you
mentioned when one side is a bishop pair
the other side has a couple Knights why
don't we trade these light Square
Bishops that is what anishkiri wants
because if these bishops come off the
board look at C4 look at B3 the light
squares are vulnerable so I wouldn't
even that shocked to say Adventure like
a bishop B5 type of maneuver that said
if you make it that obvious after Bishop
B5 the g-pawn could have gone up and the
bishop would have escaped exactly so
damn it that's just chess right there
you just grabbed it one side has a plan
the other one can play against it so you
can't make it that obvious with what you
want to do C5 was played E3 three
obviously Bishop to B5 a little bit
harder to achieve now white wants to
just develop nice and easy Bishop D3
Bishop E2 kingside castle and you know
the Bishops they're I always say they're
like that long-term investment just
holding it is sometimes worth a lot yes
are you just pulling a GameStop on me
here wow good reference including this
show but a rook coming to see it we see
the play for black with the castle but
let's leave these players to it it's
still a locked up position and we have
our fourth and final matchup about to
begin their game two we have nihal sarin
versus sam7 we know they have not played
each other but they have played plenty
online and this should come as no
surprise Neil Saron fans 77 of his games
are end games and look at that accuracy
that's actually probably the scariest
combination of two statistics that you
could have to be that accurate and to go
to the end game most of them it just
means that you know if Nihao wants to
get an end game he can do it and if we
remember game one that's exactly what
happened he had the black pieces I think
he was happy with that draw to start
things off now he's got the white pieces
and he'll look to make a statement yeah
he is phenomenal when the pieces are off
the board in fact in the Olympia where
he led his team to a metal finished
India 2 team which really performed
admirably he played some great end games
throughout that one so we see early
Bishop D2 so unlike in that game between
rajabov and giri if black ever takes on
C3 the bishop can take back so you don't
have to compromise your Pawn structure
indeed you know what Robert I actually I
think this bishop d2 move is resurging
lately it's a move that if I saw one of
my chess students would would play or
you know a young kid I'd say hey you
know what you actually want to develop
that Bishop to F4 or G5 outside the
pawns and then develop your other Bishop
then both Bishops are happy but we see
Bishop D2 and this is a great
illustration Knight to B5 that's the
idea not only do you want to just unpin
but you actually want to trade dark
Square Bishops that helps your structure
out a lot and a fascinating decision
because now the Bishops are staring at
show the obvious choice is just to trade
and then push your opponent C6 because
white is attacking this Pawn this is an
open C file for the rook and so actually
makes me question the move but this is a
structural decision rather than a
tactical one so if we see the Bishops
trade on D2 just to put this on the
board for everybody that C6 forces the
Knight back to C3 and say well your
Bishop B7 not exactly the happiest
camper exactly this is you know maybe
not the best move in the position but
it's a strategic decision he wants to
trade those Bishops look at the
remaining pieces on the board obviously
the bishop on D3 the scope that it has
in the center is way better than its
counterpart on B7 so you understand the
decision also because this is a rapid
game rob you don't need to play the
absolute best move in every single
position you want to get a position that
you're comfortable with that you know
where the pieces go and you know what
your plan is that's worth a lot rapid
and we heard stamp 7 talk to Nemo and he
said well it's rapid I might play for
tricks tricks are for kids these two are
barely outside of being kids themselves
neots aren't still a teenager so tricks
abound Knight A6 defending the C7 Pawn
but it may look wait isn't this a huge
blunder like what if I take on before
distracting this Knight away and Knight
takes C7 that is a fork of these Rooks
and you see the evaluation go all the
way down because this Rook on C1 the end
of the file is going to be loose after
the simple trade and Rook C8 that's a
pin and a win for black yeah that's a
great combination and you don't see it
coming Knight takes C7 looks so secure
but Knight A6 believe me when he's
playing that move he's got this all
worked at yes he does he's not just
stumbling into a lucky sequence even if
he's the lucky loser and back in this
tournament so all four matches are
underway all eight players are in game
two you see some looking a little more
stressed than others and as we look from
board to board here my eyes are on the
top left where we started it this round
Hikaru Nakamura and yanchist of Duda
because the pawn on C4 still exists that
is a pawn that's sacrificed in the
Catalan in the Queen's Gambit accepted
all these variations but normally you
want to win that pawn back and guess
what we talked about that move Knight to
C3 I'm going to highlight it again that
night move I think it's come back to
bite him he then moved it to A2 and if
you wanted to move the Knight out of the
way to capture the pawn on C4 you didn't
need to put it there in the first place
so maybe Knight D2 or Knight A3 was just
a better option because I see Knight C3
Robert as a waste of time now the
knights on A2 not a great Square the
only Square can get back into the action
is C3 but then you're forgetting that C4
Pawn right you're saying I'm just giving
up on that one but if we do get Pawn to
E5 Knight to E4 things like that we can
see how white can take advantage of some
weak Square so let me ask you something
this is a rapid tournament I sometimes
feel like the Catalan is a great weapon
in classical chess of course so many
luminaries game like Vladimir krumnik
have used at the highest level but
sometimes I feel like in quicker time
goes I just want to grab the material
totally agree and that is the
interesting difference between that long
form classical chess and then the
shorter time controls like rapid chest
there are variations there are openings
Robert that you can't even use in
classical but then you shorten the time
you try to wrap it suddenly it's a try
you shorten it to Blitz and suddenly
it's the best opening in blitz so that
really does happen for sure and maybe B5
will be played in a car will cling onto
that pawn we'll see how this one
develops but Wesley so and Dimitri on
draken they are locked in a very heated
battle where look at that black queen on
the right side of your screen here there
is a queen on A2 and it looks like it
will in fact see the light of day it's
not getting trapped down there yeah and
Queen on A2 is such a like you're saying
with some confidence here so you're
convincing me Robert but I'm looking at
that Queen and I'm saying okay where's
that play today you were talking about
where's that day is it is it coming soon
I hope so if you're uh Wesley so fan
because that Queen on A2 he already had
one piece trapped in this event he does
not want to see his Queen lost on A2 and
so how will black extricate that queen
I'm already looking at moves like Bishop
takes Knight on F3 right because when
the queen takes back then your queen can
slide to D2 and evacuate via H6 that's
not the end of the story black is up a
pawn white has good control over the
board and lots of play but at least
there's an immediate way out that I see
right yeah that makes total sense and
you know while you've got that side of
the board you can also play on the exact
same side of board as your queen you can
play moves like A5 to try to pry things
open and maybe activate your A8 Rook so
he's gone with your move I love the
decision because G takes F3 is so
undesirable those doubled pawns isolated
in front of the king it's a weakness
plus there's no guarantee you're
trapping that Queen so you know doubling
the pawns could just be for nothing
and and when you think of trap Queens
you need to figure out how to trap it if
Rook ever went to A1 ignoring the queen
being under attack the queen can always
slide back to B2 so there's no immediate
way to trap it I think the queen is
going to come back out via D2 and I said
I like extra material and faster time
control so I do like the look of this
for Wesley so after a shaky game one but
we do have action unfolding all across
the boards here so look at this game
between rajabov and Geary it's still a
kind of early stages of that one but a
big decision for rajab of Amman the
bishop on G5 is now under attack will it
capture the Knight of six or will it
retreat I gotta say my my instinct is to
retreat that Bishop uh you know Bishop
takes F6 is a fine move often the
decision that that gets made but I love
keeping the Bishops here Robert I think
Bishop H4 maintained the tension and
there's that extra element that yes
we're playing rapid chess and just
keeping pieces on the board you know
give your opponent the opportunity to
make a mistake and I think there's more
pressure in the position keeping that
pin and most importantly keeping the
bishop pair right if you're going to
give up that Bishop pair you need a
follow-up so Bishop takes Knight of
course the queen will take back and yeah
your knight can jump into E5 but you're
creating a bunch of one move threats and
that would be my concern about taking on
F6 and rajaba does Play Bishop to H4 he
says this bishop is the only dark square
one on the board look at these squares
maybe later in the game this bishop will
come in handy agreed totally I think
that's the right call uh Bishop H4 makes
sense but you know white also has to
make sure that things don't get too
spicy in the middle of the board before
your Castle right everything looks great
in White's position here for vajabov but
that King on E1 might get caught and
it's so easy to underestimate you know
that the engine will always be the the
first one to say uh no you can't get
away with that because your King's in
the middle but sometimes as humans we
just appreciate the rest of the position
looks so great Bishop pair but that King
on E1 it needs to get castled ASAP I
agree and black can play and the light
squares were indicating earlier C4
Knight B3 these type of moves so now
he's giri on the clock he's down on time
he will need to start playing a little
bit quicker but action is heating up in
other boards as well we have the matchup
between nihal sarin and Sam Sevin Nihao
with the white pieces we saw him jump
around with Knight to B5 I'm on and now
that Knight is back on E2 so the Knight
continues to go hopping yeah B5 it
starts on C3 then B5 and back to C3 then
E2 so C3 is sort of like the it's like
the basketball pivot foot and then he's
just deciding where to go from there so
obviously this Knight on E2 it's not
going to just stop there Robert it looks
like G3 and potentially F5 is a
destination and on top of that you can
even go to the F4 Square because those
doubled pawns are at the you know cost
of the bishop pair and I don't think
black wants to do that this early I
agree with you but I also state that it
feels like black won the opening battle
this Knight just jumped around a bunch
and because black steals the dark Square
Bishops there was a stare down in pieces
on B4 and D2 now this bishop on D6 has
more scope just like we were talking
about in some of the other positions the
bishop on D2 is staring into its own
Pawn so it doesn't feel like a very
valuable piece no agreed totally the
bishop on D2 now all of a sudden you
want it on the other side of that pawn
but you can't have everything in chess
you can't have it on D2 when you want it
there and then out on F4 or G5 when you
want it there agree with you that that
Knight on A6 while it may have looked
silly and you know off to the side when
it was played now it's journeying back
Knight to C7 Knight to E6 where it's
controlling the F4 and G5 squares which
are extremely important and black might
use that to play Rook C8 and and spear
had a C5 move I I'd love the way that
this is going for Sam Sevin and I got
the same question as you Robert that
Bishop on D2 uh where is it going the
answer is nowhere most likely and black
will strike when he is ready with that
move C5 hanging Pawn structures are very
complicated so Sam does not want to
commit himself to that so I think in the
early stages here savian should be very
happy played a good game one here in
game two looks like he has no issues out
of the opening and Knight G3 played this
is what I like to say a pawn three
squares away from a knight dominates
tonight Sam didn't even let me finish my
thought he plays G6 taking away F5
taking away H5 E4 out of white control
as well just complete domination of some
of these minor pieces so this one B4
some expansion the queen side it will
get a little bit more interesting with
the next bunch of moves but Hikaru
Nakamura Yan chest of doona they started
this round here and Amman that's C4 Pawn
still exists but look at the pawn mass
in the center D4 E4 and F4 for yanches
of Duda wow yeah I mean this this type
of Pawn formation here is really scary
and the Knight on G6 is also placed in a
way that it seems to be walking in to
everything Pawn on F5 even Pawn to H4 to
H5 that Knight is going to get kicked
around Robert and if you're looking at
the way the pieces are starting to get
placed
I'm seeing a lot of opportunity for
yanchisoft Duda to bring the pieces to
the king side and I'm not sure Hikaru
can match that defensively right and
sometimes you defend against an attack
by being a turtle getting in your shell
and making sure that the attack isn't
too vicious and he does put the move F5
on the king side the evaluation bar not
sold on that move I was gonna say
sometimes you just send in defend excuse
me in the center with the move C5 try to
explode the middle of the board maybe
play Bishop B7 to trade off the light
score pieces but F5 is a car's choice
and this is a big moment of mine
ampissant is available for one turn
exactly will do to take that or will he
leave it well in this position I think
if you look what happens after Pawn
takes on F6 it looks like the Knight
Will recapture and that D5 square is
just so juicy for the black pieces plus
The Rook slides over to f8 for black and
as good as that you know F Pawn looks
maybe F5 is coming suddenly F5 does more
harm than good for White's position so I
actually think he's not going to take on
passal but that actually tells me that I
think F5 was a great practical move by
Hikaru and that's just trademark he's so
good at finding those defensive moves
maybe the engine is saying Hey That's
Not Right But if you can't take on pass
on as an attacker Robert that's
extremely annoying that you don't have
F5 anymore you don't have F5 but the G
file maybe at some point can open up he
starts to Rook D2 kind of an ambiguous
move and where is that Rook going do I
really need to slide my second Rook to
D1 he is preventing C5 he's saying this
is one of the big ideas in the position
for black first of all white can just
press for with D5 but if the D file
opens give me the Rooks on the file
that's going to be bad news for black
and sometimes this Rook slides up to D2
and the idea is that you actually want
the Rook on A1 to slide past the D file
maybe to F1 at the moment or potentially
King H2 and Rook G1 oh and the reason
why I think this is better than just
playing King H2 Rook G1 immediately is
you don't relinquish the D file at all
so so you highlighted the need to have
D5 available in reaction to C5 well he's
got that with Rook D2 and then King H2
brings The Rook over so everybody's
working that's an exceptional point and
this Rook may find its way to G2 later
Bishop F3 Queen G3 Rook G1 Rook G2 and
that King on G8 not the safest piece in
this position Hikaru is well ahead in
the clock due to only has two minutes
and 38 and counting down seconds and
Judas moves for now are pretty obvious
the problem when you have obvious moves
you may make the wrong one and that
allows hikar just the time he needs to
strike with a move like C5 at the right
moment spoiled for Choice sometimes the
position it looks like you have so many
good options and Robert you probably
know this as well but you're looking at
them and you're like okay well this
looks good and well this looks good and
this look and if you have too many good
options sometimes you burn a lot of time
on the clock which is extremely extreme
extremely bad habit honestly or you
don't end up making the right choice
because you're just spoiled right well
it looks like in this game lots of
choices to be made not a very clear
position and the one between Wesley so
and Dimitri on draken they still are
fighting but that Queen has found the D2
Square in a different way and that's bad
news for Dimitri on Drake and he lost
the pawn on A2 and now we see here that
the queen escapes White's Pawn structure
on the king side is kind of in shambles
with F2 and F3 this compromised
structure not very good this looks like
a huge Advantage for Wesley huge
Advantage even though that eval bar
isn't you know I feel like it doesn't
represent how good this is for black I'm
mentioned earlier Robert and I think you
were echoing it that those double pawns
if you take them without any guarantee
to trap that Queen that's a long-term
weakness and while he's paying for it
right now because look that Queen is
clearly not trapped it's getting out
from D2 and honestly if you don't trade
Robert I'm even concerned maybe that
black turns us into an attack by getting
the queen back to F4 or H6 after sliding
the bishop out oh that could be very
dangerous for the exposed King so the
problem with double pawns are open files
good for Rooks but bad for kings and
actually the C3 Pawn is loose black is
ahead by a pawn so it looks like oh and
the move Queen B3 was like keeping the
Queens on the board and here's a huge
tactical shot yeah unbelievable I mean
the fact that we were just highlighting
how you could turn this into an attack
Robert this is the perfect example I
think he may have overlooked Bishop
takes on H2 and we're just talking about
the H6 Square well hello King takes H2
Queen all the way to H6 and look at that
Journey what was it Queen d8 day five
day two to D2 to age sex and winning a
piece on H4 Robert that's insane only
way to gather the pin is up to G3 and G5
the bishop once again second game Row in
this match a bishop getting trapped on
the dark squares on the king side so he
misses it Wesley with Rook to C8 he
still has a big Advantage he could take
back on C6 with his rook and the King
will never be safe but there are three
other matches with real battles on the
board right now that one was in our top
right and I love this scene here with
all four boards going on yeah how about
we go on over to the game between
rajabov and Geary we haven't looked at
in a while and I see some expansion on
the king side for both players and that
probably should be good news for the
side with the safer King so I will pull
this game up right here exactly and yeah
rajable you see rajaba's forehead cam
full display yeah I mean you know I was
thinking Robert now that we got you know
chess.com here we got the cameras we're
gonna you know we're done with the
forehead cam but somehow these top guys
they always find a way to show the
forehead they do in this position I mean
The Rook seems to be thriving the most
after H takes G5 and yet the evaluation
bar saying it's in Black's favor so if
we do a quick material count after a
capture on G5 it will be even opposite
color Bishops when you have opposite
colored Bishops Josh and games but
aggressive middle or early stage games
because you can attack I see an open H
file I see an attack but the engine says
Nah whatever and I don't agree you know
that's just where looking at the engine
can just paint the wrong picture that's
why we have guys like you and me here
Robert to make sure people know what's
going on this is real danger for Anish
giri look at that Queen it can Shuffle
over E2 H5 look how quickly it could be
Checkmate in one on the board Robert I
see that as as Anish I'm honestly pretty
scared yeah but the bad news for White
is you have some bad pawns C3 in line
with this Rook so if you don't Checkmate
the black king you'll probably drop your
Pawn so it's one of those situations
where do you go all in do you go for
that King and if you don't is it gonna
be too late because if black plays F6 I
know we're never supposed to play that
move Ben if you're watching we're sorry
but F6 not just kickson out of there
right how many safe scores that Knight
to go to I I wasn't keeping track uh and
I apparently I don't need to because the
answer is zero and that is probably
going to be the reaction then to Queen
E2 because Queen E2 looks so natural but
after Queen E2 F6 Robert and that line
might get absolutely wild Queen E2 F6
Queen H5 looking for mate well all of a
sudden after Pawn takes that Knight
there will be no mate in sight so I I
could see this potentially even
happening on the board because to be
honest this is a mess I don't know who's
who's who and we put a few moves up and
you see the evaluations that's only
slightly better for black because
instead of giving the check this is an
important attacking a moment here you
don't just give the checks hope for
checkmate you could take back on E5
bring another piece into the attack and
the king is not finding shelter it
cannot run away it still is an advantage
for black but put in a practical setting
in the arena here in Toronto this is
danger all over the place and that's
scary foreign absolutely I mean not many
players would have the confidence to
walk into that but you know what the
reason I was saying Robert that we might
see this on the board is not because
either player necessarily wants to be
there it's they might have to be I think
that there's almost no choice after F6
where does that night go you highlighted
well you got to just keep the attack
going so more fuel to the fire there as
you know we see the player cams dealing
with an attack like this Robert it
doesn't matter how strong you are we all
get a little scared we do but F6 is on
the board now it's a big decision for
team over job of he is playing from
Belgrade Serbia will he play Queen H5 go
all in hope to cash in on the Checkmate
attack or will he Retreat his Knight to
G4 the attack may continue a little bit
more slowly with the Knight hopping over
to H6 as the threat so big moment for a
job he's actually down a couple minutes
on the clock that's good news for a
niche who's defending his King because
if rajav doesn't have the time to figure
it out right well then he will survive
the day exactly I mean I want to see
that happen I want to see that attack go
through but we we have to check the
other games Robert because we can't stay
fantasizing about possible checkmates
when there are other exciting games
happening right no we have this game
between nihal sarin and Sam Sevin and
there is an alpha zero style Pawn push
H5 then H4 kicking this Knight away or
not first is the move C6 by seven wait a
second there's a bishop hanging on D2
over here a Knight hanging on G3 the
Knight is now going to capture on e4
protecting the bishop on D2 while
threatening Knight F6 check with a fork
so look at this sequence if Knight E4 I
think Sam and say let's let's be calm
let's become you're gonna take my Pawn I
will take yours removing one of the big
threats night hanging Rook hanging
Bishop loose on D2 and the engine says
that black is better and that's an
incredible find because it does show the
patience that you have to have in this
position don't go for them most
important material necessarily with that
Rook the highest value go for the one
that's impacting the position the most
that pawn on E5 I mean white would
happily be down the exchange Robert for
that comfy position remember this is
also rapid chess we have time ticking
down nihal is also at what three and a
half minutes and ticking so he wants
those easy decisions he wants to get the
moves flowing he doesn't want to have to
deal with the position where you know
it's just double edged and you know
extremely loose but the problem is what
is he think about because Knight takes
E4 seems to be the only move he made it
but he spent way too much time right any
other move would have lost a full piece
he is worse here but he's not losing the
material although with the Knight being
on e4 and about to be captured D2 is
loose next it feels like Sam Sevin I
picked him to win this match the chat
did not you did not but it seems like he
has the upper hand in game two he may
take a lead but let's go back to the
game that started it all off here it's
Hikaru Nakamura against Yan chistoph
Duda that matchup is a lead for a car
after a first round win and we see on
the screen here that the attack for Duda
with the open G file it looks like it's
just getting underway
yeah this this is the type of attack
though that you have to be a little
careful not to you know maybe overvalue
it because the Knight on f8 is such a
great defender Robert it covers that G6
Bond basically forever white needs so
much Firepower to make a legitimate
threat here we might see something I
know I'm getting ahead of myself but
something like a sacrifice on F5 even
with the queen oh he missed it just as
you said it yes that was exactly what I
was talking about Knight takes and queen
takes off five if Pawn takes a five Rook
takes G7 with Checkmate over here so a
missed tactic from yanchester due to
just as a mom was calling it out instead
Bishop takes Pawn rookchy at night back
to E4 trying to go onto the F6 Square
where this king is never going to find
shelter with all of White's pieces
heading its way wow opportunity missed
but we have to stick with the action
here 15 seconds for the white pieces to
somehow for Duda to make something of
this attack Robert and Hikaru Nakamura
is a tenacious defender in fact maybe
the best in his history he just does not
lose games even when it seems like it's
completely lost so right now E6 is
hanging how do you defend that pawn you
can bring your queen over to E8
defending E6 and bring another Defender
to G6 but there's a pass Pawn on the
other side of the board which can be
served as decoy and he might go Queen B7
that hits the Knight on e4 it's like an
active defense typical Hikaru finds a
move like that but Queen C6 that looks
like a good response be careful if this
gets traded into an end game this might
actually be a Hikaru flip oh my goodness
where's the material account extra Pawn
for white so still good for due to Rook
G1 to A1 watch out this A5 Pawn is loose
so I think Judo should start going for
it he can trade pieces as well play Rook
A1 he's not in danger of losing this
game but he's five seconds and with
knights always a tricky situation always
tricky The Rook goes to d8 I'm wondering
what the threat is The Rook on G4 is
looking misplaced now that attack isn't
happening anymore oh my gosh now Rook D2
and maybe it's attacked for black but
Knight F6 and Rook GA you have to be
very careful if your Hikaru Nakamura
your king is in grave danger wow and
here comes will the night go in it's
time for you to move two seconds King G1
looks like a fantastic move and are we
gonna see a repetition no he plays B3
and that was pinned there and that was a
trade being offered I would trade and
then start trying to bring my knight
into the game I just don't see a square
he goes Knight F6 oh my gosh it's even
him on yeah and The Rook on G4 is such a
problem here the Knight on E3 blocks the
communication for the bishop and the
pawn and B6 captures and B3 will defend
this Knight so you want a pile of
pressure on a pimpy then suddenly Hikaru
May sees the upper hand Rook C1 is there
Rook C7 there might be a Checkmate
threat here too and there might be a
repetition although it looks close to me
I think this might even be a repetition
with the Knight and the Rook G5 he
Carlos King is running for the hills oh
my gosh there's no chicken G7 no check
the Knight covers it and he car won't
have the upper hand King's escaping yeah
this is this is exactly what black wants
in this end game the king coming to the
middle of the board
I don't see anything here for White and
the King will keep on running King to D5
it is safe the E5 Pawn is now loose oh
my gosh Hikaru is up a pawn and he's
trying to win this game yeah there's
Knight anywhere you want of course the
F4 Pawn can be taken probably takes on
F4 Knight G2 check in the E5 pawn and E5
just Falls will there be enough checks I
think that A5 dropping does not give him
enough and there was a winning move
there was a winning movement and it was
H5 check to drag the king up to H5 and
give this check on B5 that is a hard
move to see in time trouble but we're
still in this game right now the Knight
on A5 desperately wants to get back into
the action but it just can't reach where
it wants to go and here the Knight
finally is coming back towards the
center of the board
we just saw Wesley so behind the players
Wesley so won his game he's still there
behind Hikaru just watching the action
unfold but Hikaru he has the advantage
as an extra Pawn Duda is now putting up
a good fight but the emotions you were
almost winning for Duda now you have to
defend to the end of the game yeah and
the end of the game might not be close
by because Nakamura with one extra Pawn
is gonna push and push and push and we
are a move 82 and this game is still
gonna go on for a while unless the white
king gets checkmated watch out here
comes rookie to check King pushed to the
first rank yep rookie two definitely
looks like a great place to start maybe
Knight F3 first oh gosh protecting and
attacking E5 will be covered he wants to
bring the H Pawn for me Rook G3 check
and don't go to H2 get mated immediately
yep he's got to give that up rook F3 of
course we won't see a repetition here
but the players sometimes use this to
gain time in these positions and E4
protecting The Rook over here Rook F6 I
mean they're blocked with Knight F5
potentially wow I think you might want
to do that just not avoid some trades
Rook A4 uh oh oh here come the pieces
King F3 93 check and mate yep oh and
then it's made it's made too far way too
far away and Rook G1 E3 check and if
King deter's Rook D1 winning the Knight
this is over they promote over it that
pawn is going all the way Rook D1 keep
it simple take the Knight
and Hikaru Nakamura he's got that head
nod and the oh my goodness the
headphones come off and it's a victory
the guy cannot be defeated even in
completely hopeless looking positions
Hikaru Nakamura surges to a two-nothing
lead in his match against the Magnus
beater in yon chistoph Duda that is just
incredible the way that he turned that
position from defense into attack was
incredible such a big win for Hikaru
he's starting out this tournament as
well as anyone wants to with two wins
Robert such such an impressive game and
we still have two games going on these
matches look at these boards Iman on the
left-hand side screen there's a king on
E2 and a king on H6 in the right hand
side screen things a little look a
little bit more cozy despite the
adventure black so let's go to rajabov
against giri because 11 seconds for
Timor job of both Kings in danger being
checkmated indeed I'm you know it's uh
basically strike while the iron is hot
here there's a Rook hanging in this
position Robert there's checks on the
board but if you grab that Rook suddenly
you sort of hand it over to the other
guy to go and start his attack and these
guys say you know what I'm not sure what
the evaluation is let's call it even
yeah because taking the Rook would have
led to me draw Anish giri runs away and
he might have escaped with one as he
leaves the room because I mean that game
was just on the verge of defeat for
either player but a draw in game one
then also a draw in game two it seems
like these players they just can't break
apart from one another indeed it
actually looks like the games they've
had there is the opportunity for one of
them to take the advantage to run away
with it but neither one of them is
willing to take that plunge into real
murky calculation territory no they want
to keep it simple and when things get
really complicated and they're kind of
unsure they're happy to make that
repetition and stay well within the
match and of course it's tied up at one
to one and a player who does not want to
see a second draw in a row is Sam Sevin
he's the newcomer to the field he a
second chance here and F5 he doesn't
want to give Neil any chances because E3
is hanging with check and once E3 Falls
it feels like the whole position
collapses I want to trade material I
don't want my king to be in danger I'm
up with pieces let's go Rook C1 yeah and
you know what Robert if the time
situation was reversed it can be tough
to play with that extra material when
you're low on time but the opposite is
the case he's got three minutes and
change to put all the pressure on Nihao
he's picking off pawns he's playing
accurately he has the time to make sure
that he's playing the right move here so
if nihal survives us that would be
incredible you mean 3.8 seconds isn't a
lot of time to survive a position when
you're down in exchange that is shocking
news to me that was coming to my mind
Robert yeah I was thinking exactly that
well nihal actually is a bit fortunate
to be here because in the Opening match
of the round of 64 against Ralph
momentov it went to Armageddon and he
barely got his final moves off
delivering a Checkmate and so he is
happy to be at this stage but he's not
happy to be in this position because
look at this Amman no attack for white
black has a rook compared to a knight
for White and the Kings on G3 that's not
helping matters no there is a setup that
well better believe Sam is not gonna let
this happen but there's a setup that
white might want Pawn on H4 and Knight
going to F4 Queen D6 check pretty much
playing exactly against that but wow
what a move Knight to E5 offering The
Rook here and I mean don't we just go
back to uh D6 here I think you can
definitely go back there and make sure
your king is safe so what Neil's hoping
for is by trading down which sounds bad
when you're down material is there fewer
Defenders and this King on G8 is also
wide open I think that this 97 check
thread will be seen by by Sam so that is
a fork that you have to watch out for uh
but Queen D6 check the Knight has to go
back to E5 and you're lucky you don't
lose the night on the spot that's right
yeah Rook to C5 in that moment would
allow Queen to E8 check that's probably
what's really keeping him in the game
here but Nihao you know resourceful as
ever if he can get Sam's time down to
something more manageable like they both
are in time pressure I think he's got
chances so Sam's got to you know
conclude this game with the two minutes
he's got and we see the 95 if F4 comes
in at night can be stationed there for a
while this king is not very safe so it
just seems like a position where Sam now
done under two minutes he could spend
some time but he doesn't want to spend
too much agree and because you're
highlighting F4 it's such a sturdy move
I'm looking at G5 Robert G5 stops that
move you've still got the knight in a
pin and if you can't play F4 to you know
solidify the Knight there hang on I'm
threatening to win your night in a
couple moves that's true it's a really
good move the King on G3 out in the open
and if you play F4 then well good luck
to that King so I like the look of G5
Sam might like it as well but it does
expose his King even more but there are
clear drawbacks yeah indeed it's a you
know give and take you got to give
something to get something and in this
position he's spending his time exactly
how I would I think you do take your
time here because you don't just look
for the next move Robert you look for a
plan you look for a tricky move where
you anticipate a reply and you've got to
reply to that move because the guys got
seven seconds you don't want to give him
a chance to think move by move you want
to all of a sudden put him under
pressure and here we go F4 then G5
because if F takes there might be Rook
C5 and there's no Queen E8 check so very
nicely done by seven and look at this
move King at you please take me on F4
that shuts down the diagonal then I can
go Queen D4 instead that looks like such
a good move the F4 Pawn Falls with check
now there's Rook C1 although he survives
for just a brief moment with Knight G1 I
think Queen D4 as your Highline covers
the checks Robert that is a great finish
and that's game over and Sam sevian
takes the early lead against nihal sarin
so he said he was excited to be here his
chest is excited fighting and now he has
a one point lead over the teenage
Superstar from India yeah I mean the uh
the box score there says the results you
know as we're seeing them a point in
game two for Sam Sevin I mean really
impressive what we've seen from him so
far he's come into the tournament and it
feels to me Robert like he's playing as
if he's got nothing to lose right he's
got that you know second chance at this
tournament he's making it count and he's
not just anybody they didn't just pluck
him off the street and like let's get a
player to face off against nihal sir no
he is nearly 2700 So a lead for seven a
lead for Wesley so he played a good game
against Dimitri on draken all tied up in
gear rajaba but Nakamura once again
winning that one was a bit more
surprising indeed yeah that that game
was such a back and forth and honestly I
think Nakamura just kind of thrives in
those situations where it's that back
and forth you know he went from defense
to attack he was handling the pressure
from Duda and it looked like Duda was
gonna maybe even up that match but as
soon as it got into a time pressure I
think Canty eluded it alluded to it the
best early on when he said you know what
there's nothing scarier than Hikaru
Nakamura when the time gets low it's
true because he is the bullet chess
champion and has been numerous times the
guy is just a wizard and when he doesn't
actually lose the game the chance that
he does lose are not very high you
better knock him out before giving him a
second chance and while we didn't catch
the end of the game between Wesley so
and Dimitri on draken we're going to
bring that up and analyze it for you
because there were some great tactics
that Amman you had spotted during our
analysis yeah the the tactics there
looked really exciting and I love the
way that it was handled by Wesley early
on it looked like he got a great opening
advantage and just that over commitment
to trapping the queen which it was never
gonna happen Robert but you know white
was playing as if it was a guarantee
yeah right here right he castled
kingside just giving up this Pawn A2
exactly because there were tactics as
well this Knight is pinned and this Pawn
is pinned so it was a tricky looking
position Dimitri couldn't handle it but
we got to this point pretty quickly and
then after missing Bishop takes A2 the
first time right the second time it was
not to be missed once the queen was
under attack bam Bishop takes H2 check
once the king took Queen F4 and the
difference here is while the dark sweat
Bishop survived the light square one
didn't that's right and you know he
actually got to do it in an even better
situation he got the Rook to attack his
Queen so he basically got what we were
looking at with an extra Rook C8 for
himself so not too bad at all I I think
just great tactics early on and you know
you just look at the position it's so
easy to convert especially for someone
as strong as Wesley so the Knight
against the bishop it just runs wild on
the light squares yeah look at the
Knight going from C6 over the king side
towards the action then the H5 Pawn goes
up to H4 this bishop on G3 not very
happy the King on H3 even less happy and
look at this Knight takes D4 giving away
peace and queen of five check how many
times was his Bishop the victim of a
tactic yeah and you know it almost felt
like previously the the bishop was
actually the victim of the tactic but
then it wasn't actually captured so it
was like the problem it's like finally
you're paying for your sins yeah and
then it could not stay on the board
anymore after Queen takes F4 some trades
happen but check this out Rook H3 Queen
G5 check and after Rook C2 he tries to
defend with Queen G3 because this is a
pin on the H4 Pawn so style points to
Dimitri on Dragon he's a comedian he
gotta give it to him Queen G3 is a great
resource but even that great resource
it's just not enough to save the
position look at that beautiful Pawn
structure for black all connected and
White's pawns at some point they were B4
D4 the app file and the H file so you
just have the worst possible pawns all
disconnected from one another Well a
very nice win there for Wesley so and
Sam seven also had a great win so you
know as we see three players win in the
second round how did you see that round
and fold you know Robert I think in the
second round we saw the players sort of
fall into their form a little bit more
Sam Savion definitely displaying from
those first two games that he feels a
little more comfortable game one he
wasn't ready to take that jump right at
the end of the game and you know commit
to that decision game two he was all
about commitments and he committed to a
great great win obviously Hikaru keeping
it rolling we know he's that like you
know counter puncher he's getting
attacked all of a sudden he turns it in
to win so he car knock him up just more
of the same well the players may take
their lunch get a quick break we're
going to do much of the same and when we
return we'll have more live chess plus
the high and low lights from Canty and
Nemo's copter tour above Niagara Falls
twitch subscribers hang tight for some
more exclusive content from Toronto will
be right back
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
check out chess.com's newest mobile
release for Android and iOS now with
game review
game review is a fast fun and
instructive guided review of your games
see your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy check out the eval graph for an
instant overview and scroll down to see
how many great moves best moves blunders
and yes brilliancies you have played
learn from chess.com's coach who gives
move explanations opening statistics and
shows you the best lines of play use
retry mistakes to get another shot at
finding missed opportunities
game review is available today on both
Android and iOS
download our app and try it yourself
[Music]
I'm really excited to go on this road
trip I'm excited to drive to Niagara to
play chess on a helicopter yeah we're
playing just little helicopter I know
you already know what it is Chad cgc
we're here it's about to go down y'all's
turn up let's go
[Music]
I'm excited for this
now 3.5
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
I was born in Vancouver but as wonderful
as Andrea and Vancouver are it's pretty
tough not to fall in love with the city
of Toronto
natural beauty abounds inside Toronto
and pretty close by
the largest city in Canada the people
here have been playing chess and clubs
in universities and in public parks
what are you doing
for well over a century
and now this wonderful place plays hosts
for the very first chess.com Global
championship finals
facing elimination for weeks eight of
the world's best players have survived
to continue their quest for the
queen-size share of the one million
dollar prize pool
oh and it's just made Sensational this
is the most shocking day that we have
ever had
friends you you're in the right place
it's time for the cgc finals Toronto
Canada officially has it all
welcome back
to beautiful Toronto so many things to
do and see here including of course
playing chess
we are inside the hotel one we are
getting ready for the second half of the
opening here for our quarterfinals
so welcome back everybody we set inside
here we're playing chess we're not
playing chess as we speak we've been
watching others play chess I'm Danny
wrench now alongside Grand Master Robert
Hess feed a master James Canty and AKA
nems nems code Nemo joins us on the end
here and we've got so much to get into
so shout out to Twitch tap by the way
who've been actively involved all day
we've been following I got involved a
little bit it's been a ton of fun so
keep it up
we got a lot more live chests to come
you may even spot a wild Hikaru Nakamura
behind me uh but uh right now we're
going to dive in first we're talking
about Hikaru Nakamura against yond
Kristof dude in a moment but for those
joining here's how we got here where
we're at at the halfway point here on
day one for the cgc quarterfinals
Hikaru as we said the guy up 2-0 is uh
is just doing hikaranakamura things over
yonsha stuff Duda Wesley so rebounded
from missing mate in two in game one to
win the second game he's got a one and a
half lead Anish Geary and Tamar rajaba
are all knotted up with two draws and
then Sam sevian the Cinderella story he
wins a huge game over nihal sarin what
is going to happen there uh we can't
wait to unpack it Robert let's uh let's
get some thoughts here for our first two
hours of live chess I want to start with
you you had the call with him on
Hamilton your biggest Takeaway on what
we saw there in the first set of games
yeah we definitely saw some nerves from
the players there are some swings
topsy-turvy matchups some players with
winning advantages then almost losing
those games so it's day one the first
couple games they're just getting set
here but I think the chess has been
quite shaky at the outset
Nemo your thoughts uh you're going to be
interviewing these players your thoughts
on the games you've seen maybe the
biggest moments so far I mean I was in
twitch chat actually when
um we we saw Wesley so miss meeting too
and obviously that's just one of the the
things that can happen in professional
chess no matter how good you are no
matter you know what's happening
somebody can miss mating too for sure so
I think there's a lot riding on these
games obviously the prize pool is huge a
lot of things are happening in each and
every game and it's been so fun to watch
so far yep it has said a lot of nerves
on the line a lot of there's a lot of
money up there and then Sam you know Sam
I Am won't all the green eggs and ham
that man came and won the game right so
that's it's looking like I really had
searing for winning but now seeing Sam
bounce back like this after like losing
so we don't know what's gonna happen
it's lots of games left I'll suggest so
it's exciting to see I'm with you I mean
I think you guys hated everyone the
nerves are very real not every day you
see Miss mating too and then on Drake
and was winning by the way we should
call that out too that game was all over
the place I don't know what my biggest
takeaway was besides I would say that in
the end we saw Hikaru Nakamura doing her
car with things we called it we were all
standing around the monitor out there
like here goes hicaro he's going to turn
around and win this game and sure enough
he did it so all right it was a lot of
fun we got so much more chess ahead but
in addition to the chess we've also been
talking quite a bit about how beautiful
Toronto and the surrounding area is uh
we uh we we had some fun this weekend
Canty and Nemo they took a special trip
just across the border to Niagara Falls
and of course uh they they squeezed in
some stuff all in the helicopter and uh
well let's take a look
I know you already know what it is Chad
cgc we're here it's about to go down
y'all turn up let's go
I'm excited for this here it is y'all
see it
but it's for real oh my God it's kind of
cool this is excellent
wow that is so gorgeous yeah you're
right that water don't look friendly
yeah they trying to get in there bro wow
look at the view here I am way off the
ground right now look at that it's just
so peaceful right here yeah
I mean it's so good it doesn't even look
like water all right come on now
yeah
all right let's get it let's go
okay
who won yeah we watch The Falls yeah
[Music]
yeah sure wow that is so gorgeous oh man
wow are we over Niagara Falls we're on a
helicopter what are you doing
shout out to chess.com
all right we're Landing wow that was
incredible that was super cool that was
incredible got the same favorites me and
Nemo sauce well I don't know one of the
fan favorite right I think you know okay
it's fine yeah fan favorites yeah yeah
let's go with that
okay well we a lot to unpack there and
James we're gonna get to that blunder in
a second but first about that experience
Nemo your first time in a helicopter
first time playing chess in a helicopter
how was it I mean it was so incredible
because I don't I have never even come
close to a helicopter before so I didn't
realize like
you know the size of a helicopter is
pretty small but they were able to get
all the equipment in us obviously and
then all the helicopter was like glass
and I guess I just never really thought
about like oh how am I gonna look out of
this helicopter but all of it was like
glass and I was like wow this is so
beautiful once we start flying
everything was just completely
incredible and obviously playing chess
being able to say I play chess in a
helicopter
that sounds pretty cool yeah I think
we're the first to do that in fact Danny
think about this Robert I mean is chess
in the helicopter have you played chess
in the apricot exactly don't answer that
you know it's it's chess in a helicopter
it's amazing right it was Blissful just
up there you know your stomach moving
around a little bit but you playing some
chests at least trying to and then
having a great time it was great to see
The Falls too what about you ever play
chess in a helicopter no I'm calculation
over everything so I calculate the risk
of flying in the helicopter so James you
should probably give me that necklace
yeah the uh the the helicopter looks fun
maybe one day we'll try but James let's
dig into the the scene there let's dig
into the blender that we saw as we bring
up the video what was going through your
head here in this moment when you uh
when you slid that Queen to to a bad
Square coming up here oh man that was
ugly take us through so I remember I was
I was looking at you know I was looking
outside everything was all nice and
pretty and then I'm playing I'm kind of
just moving I want to trade some pieces
off I'm like oh this is a good Fringe
things are fine I don't really play this
like this then I move slow slid The Rook
over to d8 and it wasn't great it wasn't
great it was not great work the d8 and
it was not great right so
um then she doubled up on me there and
said oh you got a little blunder there
with a little smile yeah yeah cute and
stuff and then uh
I hurt definitely hurt Nemo you spotted
it pretty quickly there the queen D2
nice little battery yeah I mean honestly
I was gearing up to take control of that
open file to start with so honestly I
think candy kind of just like I wasn't
thinking oh yeah I'm gonna win this
bishop because it's pinned you know so
he kind of like walked into it himself
and I was just gonna play it anyways I
was like oh actually you know what I'm
gonna win this piece now we give panty
the excuse that he was distracted by the
beautiful Niagara Falls for the movie
that felt like I was watching the scene
from some kind of action movie yes right
yeah I wanted to see the full thing yeah
yeah I I would Replay that game we can
dive into deep analysis of that letter
maybe a video a video coming soon but
we'll threw the board out the window
okay uh well the uh again like would you
give are we giving him the benefit of
the Dow there was a lot of distracting
things there so we're not gonna hold the
blunder against him here no I will yeah
you know okay all good James we know
each other a long time thank you had a
long time
Nemo so you weren't you were too
distracted you said Niagara the first
time you've seen Niagara actually it was
probably my seventh time oh really okay
yes yeah I misunderstood that with the
first time no helicopter his first time
yeah yeah well second time so you know
many times since a long time first time
in the helicopter seventh time see
Niagara right
okay would you do it again oh yeah
absolutely I just wouldn't play that
game again
all right well he's gonna do it again
but that's that's going to do it for us
for now we will be back post game here
of course to break things down in the
gameplay Hall but now it is time to
bring in for the first time from the
Caster Booth we have Grand Master Daniel
naroditski an international Master
content creating sensation Gotham chess
over there with the call you guys ready
we are absolutely ready thank you so
much Danny Levy Knight we've gotten
kicked out but we've moved to an even
better place the commentator Booth here
alongside my good friend International
Master Levy Rosman Levy how excited are
you for the second half of day one I'm
so pumped those were some incredible
games in the first and second round the
morning rounds if you will of day one of
this quarterfinal and we just had to
listen to people talk for 10 minutes
about playing chess in a helicopter so
not only are we excited for the games
we're also incredibly envious so I want
to put that behind me and I want to
focus on the chess that was incredible
props to candy and Nemo as we push
toward game three of Nakamura Duda let's
take a closer look at the Polish Phenom
Yang stuff Duda he has a comeback that
he needs to pull off but Levy he
definitely has the Acumen he has the
pedigree to get that done of smooth path
toward the cgc finals what jumps out to
you about uh the Polish 24 year old
super Grand Master yeah I feel like I've
been hearing accomplishments of
youngster for like 10 years but that's
crazy easy because he's only 24 years of
age he has probably the highest rapid
rating of any player at least on
chess.com in particular with his success
but he is in a worst case scenario he
could not have had a two-nothing deficit
in a worse way because in the first game
he was outplayed in his pet opening and
in the second game he was completely
winning so well completely winning might
be a tiny bit of a stretch we've seen
mate in two already not not exactly seen
by the players so this is a worse
nightmare for him but the good news is
he has a little bit of time to bounce
back but his time is quickly running out
yeah he has he has a lot of time to
bounce back but he has to start now I
mean if you lose one more game you think
about it you're down 3-0 against ikara
Nakamura that's crisis time that's a big
problem as we watch the Players get
started putting their headphones on yank
shistov he'll have the black pieces in
game three and I'm very curious to see
what strategy Hikaru adopts is he going
to go for the kill or is he going to
play a solid game because at this point
you know a draw only benefits one player
and it's a car Nakamura here we go oh I
mean in the first game E4 worked why
would you not repeat it iuc this time
already youngstoff making a different
second move so we have a Berlin okay now
a big question yeah because uh Hikaru
can you see Hikaru looking around it's
not that he doesn't know what to play he
plays an ante Berlin he says you're not
taking my pawn and of course he could
have made that Berlin draw but listen
Hikaru feels confident he says I've got
the white pieces he plays the Berlin
with black so he's a specialist with
both colors why not give it a shot and
we have this very fashionable D5 line
essay by Young stuff do the center
already open and Levy the players
continuing to Blitz out their moves yeah
so my recommendation for people watching
at home is not to play this fast they
can do it you most likely may not be
able to play as accurately as quickly
but they know everything you see Hikaru
with above 15 minutes and obviously an
itch near his ear there you go uh it
looks around smiles and the Knight has
been centralized and we're gonna have uh
betrayed wow I'm still processing my
visual processing is is way too slow for
this the Queens are off the board to
check on G4 they're still blitzing out
their moves interesting because he
allowed F2 to F3 there which was a very
natural move to kick out the bishop but
I guess he doesn't want to do that it
seemed like it improved this position
because the Knight has no way back yeah
there was F3 I guess the drawbacks that
you allow to check on d8 with Tempo and
you're absolutely right I think the main
reason is that he wants the F3 Square
there you go and there we have it and of
course black could take on F3 yeah black
could also take an F2 and he does so
fast what's going on love if you've ever
seen this how do they know 17 moves of
theory and something that's like almost
never been played and they continue and
it's not even like a Berlin it is an end
game but it's not the traditional Berlin
end game Knight to H4 by Hikaru Nakamura
threatening this move Knight G6 using
the pin against the F7 pawn and can do
to defend that G6 Square because if he
moves his King instead you drop the F7
Pawn anyway yeah Knight G6 if it was
White's movable it would be winning
basically because Knight G6 I mean maybe
maybe not winning maybe like King hides
on H7 and white gets a devastating
attack but what is the move here for
black is it something crazy like can if
you play G5 can white Switch the plan
Knight F5 I guess so I'm I mean we're
gonna have to see what yancha stuff
comes up with here but before we do that
we are going to switch to the Wesley on
Dragon game which is about to begin we
can see those players on camera now
Dimitri and Drake and Levy much like
young schistuff a very frustrating start
to the cgc but he has just been an
online sensation in the last couple of
years Levy his pedigree his reputation
really speaks for itself at this point
yeah and that last fun fact right there
tells you exactly what you have to do he
prefers Bishop just get them off the
board on a serious note he defeated got
akomski World Championship contender in
his Heyday and his prime would also be
caruan and he beat Corona in a minimum
number of games he's the second seed
from his group and those first two games
were Haymaker field games they were
throwing punches Maiden 2 was missed and
in the second game a very smooth effort
by Wesley so so Dimitri he has to make
it count here with the black pieces
repeats the Sicilian but this time
chooses a rare line the early Queen B6
variation Levy I have faced this a
couple of times but it is so so much
more rare than the Tamanna and the night
ORF and all the main things yeah folks
you have to understand we're shocked I
mean I get it we're chest nerds we're
shocked a queen moved on move forward
and it does look very natural the queen
is misplaced there White's Bishop on C1
is just gonna go to E3 and attack it in
one move and that is going to be what
happens here uh unless the queen just
drops back voluntarily so very
provocative opening here from and Drake
and he really likes to mix it up yeah he
doesn't I think the idea of this line
yes you waste the tempo after Bishop E3
but you've sent the Knight back from D4
and D4
is a pretty juicy Square for whitesnites
the logic is that yeah you invest the
tempo moving your queen tight twice but
on the other hand you force whitesnite
onto an inferior position and Wesley
already taking his time man I feel like
I can breathe for the first time in this
coverage I feel like somebody's actually
thinking yeah this is uh Wesley of
course did not expect this all the top
players they know how to beat what are
called the sideline Sicilian variations
that you play with the black pieces make
no mistake you will never see this
opening in a classical game at top level
and by classical I mean 90 minute 120
minute whatever it might be I don't even
know the last time an over 2700 rated
player played this with black in a long
game yeah because white is better no
white is definitely better that's not
under dispute but Dimitri trying to get
a fresh position and it's clear that he
is trying to come back from this one
point deficit he wants to equalize this
match right here and right now Wesley
approaching this from a classical
perspective this is the third ranked
setup I wonder why it's called that way
you know very chess players are known
for their originality Bishop comes out
to E3 and D3 and it's pretty clear to me
at this point that Wesley is going to a
castle kingside although castling Queen
side Levy is also possible in such
positions but not really up Wesley's
alley well can I just say this he can
always play Queen to F3 so the third
ranked attack what about H4 and Rook H3
oh well yeah we'll get there A4 Rook A3
maybe the king I think the king will
come as well yeah just the full Squad
along the third grade no I agree short
Castle looks good then F2 to F4 right
very common idea as well
and Knight F6 by Dimitri and Drake and
continuing his development we'll keep a
close eye as this opening unfolds but
the third game is about to begin and
that is the match between anishkiri and
Timur rajabov I mentioned in the pregame
show Levy the Timur ajaba frequently
overlooked he's 35 years old but he
doesn't seem to be on the decline to the
contrary a third place finish at the
candidates super impressive yeah one of
the things about Timor rajab over the
last few years is he has made a lot of
draws Right In classical chess short
draws sometimes non-combative draws but
that does lead to having the lowest loss
percentage of any player in the field at
6.5 he doesn't lose games I wish I could
have that fun fact about myself and he
just beat yanipomshi in three games so
when we have these kind of situations
always interesting to see what happens
in the matchups and this is a matchup of
friends game three about to be on their
way indeed and Geary will have the white
pieces one E4 by a niche that's what I
like to see and another Sicilian but
this time Anish playing The Rose solimo
which is incredibly fashionable on this
C3 variation has been featured top and
bottom bottom and high level chest low
level chest everybody's playing it now
and I think they're repeating the same
line from game one yeah and that Queen
on B6 just for anybody at home it's not
the same Queen on B6 that you saw in the
game that we just looked at this is a
very closed position you'll get both
sides eight pawns nothing traded in the
center Anish walking it down the center
of the board with the move order that
rajaba is playing with black he's
inviting the rosalimo and Anish giri is
showing up to the russellimo party he
most certainly is and he is you know
taking the bull by its horns pushing the
pawn up to E5 and now Bishop B5 to C4
forcing black to make a decision either
move the Knight back to C7 and the queen
is feeling mighty uncomfortable if a
knight appears on C4 or he's saying you
can play E6 but then you're creating a
massive weakness on D6 and then White
Knight is going to be salivating at the
prospect of planting itself on D6 I
really like this move Bishop C4 and I
think this is an improvement by Anish
Gary over his play in the first game you
know one idea I just really love in all
these positions is Black's King side
Knight has abandoned post H4 H5 what are
we waiting for who is stopping you from
just launching an attack well I'll tell
you Timur ajabo who has a 6.5 lose rate
the Knight has retreated and a neat he
Retreats again that's so
oh that's so counter-intuitive right
like for an audience member watching you
know why did the bishop just make two
retreating moves yeah but Knight C4 is
such a huge threat that Knight on C7
blocking the Queen's escape and forcing
the queen onto the path of a very nasty
discovered attack so we'll see how Timur
deals with that threat but we have our
fourth game about to get underway Sam
Sabian and nihal sir and the two young
phenoms about to Duke it out in game
three now Saran Levy we all predicted
them basically that nihal was going to
win but he has a one point comeback to
make but if there's somebody who can
make it it's 18 year old nihal Serene
isn't it yeah it absolutely is look at
the people that he's beaten if you don't
know Ralph Mama of one of the best
players of
azerbaijanik okay yeah the whole
multiple time world champion probably
inspired Decades of Chester and he just
beat the world championship Challenger
the world number two the only player
above 2800 not named Magnus Carlson In
classical chess dingley Ren
yeah I mean he's he's an anti-tilter he
never tilts I've played him so much
online I've never seen nihal lose a game
and just kind of collapse he's so
objective but can't he bring that
objectivity to the table in game three
okay we have a one D4 by Sam Simeon
which is an opening that he's
incorporated into his repertoire pretty
recently now a big choice for nehal he
can play the ragazon levy he can play a
traditional Queen's Gambit declined
let's see what he chooses last game of
course was an IM so Indian this this is
such an intriguing matchup for so many
reasons like the fact that they have
never played a chess game against each
other even though they don't always play
on a online they might have played on on
some random Blitz Games and I'm sure
they have because they're both rated
over 3 000 but Knight bd7 chosen by
nehal this is a very cagey Queens Gambit
decline very passive but has a little
bit of Venom here and there interesting
approach because he could have just
played a main line and killed the game
off as we say but he's choosing to keep
more pieces on the board keep some
tension yeah Knight bd7 is quite an
ambitious line actually and one of the
the ideas of course is to delay the
development of the dark scored bishop
and another idea is that D takes C4 is
now very much on the table because let's
make a random move by white G3 after d
takes C4 the knight from D7 can swing
over to B6 and it can be surprisingly
hard for white to win this Pawn backhand
I'm not entirely sure that Sam sebian is
in the mood to Gambit away upon you know
when he's a point up in the match my
guess is that he wants to play a little
bit more solidly and so I think we're
going to see uh the development of the
dark Square Bishop maybe even C takes D5
yeah C takes D5 kills all the fun
clarifies the pawn structure right away
it's kind of weird probably to the
uninitiated to see so much tension among
Pawns in the center of the board and
neither side capturing but also another
way to kill the fun here is just to play
E2 to E3 I'm not sure there's a stronger
way to kill the fun defending the pawn
with the bishop and then looking to
develop it and Castle it must be weird
for Savion because he's up one and a
half to half
does he take the risk does he play the
more aggressive way there's a reason
he's already below 14 minutes unlike
some other guys who played 20 moves of
Theory in 10 seconds now and see takes
D5 and Bishop F4 is on the board and
that's exactly what he was thinking
about you nailed it live it's not that
he is seeing this for the first time he
was just choosing the approach do I want
to play more so do I want to Gambit the
C4 Pawn there's our answer no I do not
want to Gambit it and this is what's
called the Carlsbad structure where the
asymmetry is contained in the fact that
white has an epon and black has a c Pawn
otherwise the structure is symmetrical
we're probably going to see E3 Bishop D3
black is going to develop his no not the
bishop to D7 the bishop to E7 and I
think we're going to see pretty normal
development or not Knight F6 to H5 what
an interesting move by nehal as he hunts
for Sam sebien's dark scored Bishop Levy
yeah don't make multiple moves in the
opening with pieces that you've already
developed unless you're these guys right
so nehal has voluntarily moved his
Knight out to H5 to clarify what's going
on with White's dark squared Bishop now
white will finish off with the light
squared bishop and then shortcut Castle
can black play F7 to F5 at some moment
and use the knight's offside position to
then go back and control White Center
yeah I think that's a really interesting
idea clamping down on the C4 square and
Sam is gonna have to find a role for his
light squared Bishop but let's take a
look at our beautiful four game view
we're gonna update you on all four games
at the same time top left is that
lightning fast Berlin game between
Hikaru and Yannick schistoff where you
can see Hikaru is still down upon Levy I
mean this is just a feast for the eyes
isn't it yeah it's a complex battle I'm
trying to count the pawns he's still
trying to get his Pawn back but he's
better he's down a pawn but he's better
and I think it's because Black's pieces
are scattered all over the board and
it's very difficult for black to conjure
up some connectivity between them which
is why he's down four minutes let's go
to that game let's take a closer look at
that end game I think everybody's
curious has Hikaru nakamura's game has
his opening experiment resulted in
success so we have hikar with the white
pieces down upon in a Berlin the first
day
out but Bishop takes H6 collects the
pawn back and he takes F5 is pre-moved
attacking the 996 whoa wait oh we just
showed us the 30 second game we show up
and seven moves are busted out okay we
need to rewind yeah we need to rewind so
so let's go two moves before Bishop
takes H6 first Hikaru plays Knight F5 do
you think Jan shistov missed the move
Bishop takes H6 of course the idea is
that this re-forks the black bishop and
then white is the one up a pawn instead
he took on F5 but Levy I mean fast
forwarding to the current position black
is worse here clearly worse and it's not
just a draw because there are still
Rooks on the board yeah but the scary
thing here is that the only reason this
is apparently plus one according to the
machine is to trade the Rooks by black
and if you just pull that up on the
board if we trade the Rooks right uh yes
and Rook f8 Rook f8 King f8 and so on uh
White can sneak in and get those pawns
but the computer is claiming this is a
draw does this look like a draw to the
human eye absolutely not and crazy you
know why it doesn't look like a drug
because you could say okay well down
upon opposite color Bishop end game I
heard that's a draw anyway but if we
extend this line after Bishop a6baba
here's one pass Pawn right white can
make another one I think using his King
side two on one and that's a term known
as trousers uh in in Russian chess
terminology when you've got past pawns
uh kind of like pant legs on either side
of the board and that is the worst enemy
uh on the defending side and opposite
card Bishop end games how are you going
to stop both of these pawns at the same
time and white has another Pawn that he
could use in case black finds a way to
eliminate both of White's passers this
is a very hard position to evaluate
maybe it's a draw because of Black's
passer but Levy you know this is this is
not easy to Value then Jan has six
minutes on the clock already this is
anything but a guaranteed draw and if
you don't know as a human being going
into this that you are going to save the
Half Point you just never do this
because you just cleared everything off
the board the computer might say it's a
draw and then you get there and the
computer changes its mind because it
finds a resource it doesn't have the
depth from 20 ply out so very tough spot
for Duda who might just be down three
nothing in about 10 minutes dude and
here's the thing if he doesn't take on
F1 if he makes a neutral move such as
king G6 to move the king away from the
seventh rank well then he car says thank
you very much you don't want me you
don't want to change the Rooks all right
fine I'll get my Rook to D7 I'll Attack
your Pawn on C7 and you could say well
but then Black Goes Rook F2 check and
takes on G2 this is not a fair Pawn
capturing race Levy because White's
gonna take everything on the queen side
and then play B5 and A6 Black's pass
Pawn is still going to be you know
putting it's putting its clothes on in
the morning and White's gonna have two
queens so this is out of the question I
think John schizoph might be 4 forced to
try this Rook end game whether it is
drawn or or losing this might be his
best chance that's such a horrible
Prospect and again I said this when we
first started the show JKD has lost
these two games in legitimately the
worst way imaginable because he got
everything he wanted on the board and he
still lost what do you do when that
happens well you try the Berlin and it
turns out Hikaru was prepared until the
20th move there and I have a feeling
Hikaru is using prep from the candidates
it's a very common theme for the
audience at home when players prepare
for massive events like the candidates
of the world championship they have a
year to use those ideas I have a feeling
we're seeing that right here Hikaru
using an idea he didn't get to use in
Madrid where you were doing some amazing
commentary by the way and he's using it
here and Duda does not look happy he
does not he looks frustrated he looks
like somebody who's about to go down 3-0
I agree this is a major major prep we
will keep an eye on janshu stuff dude as
defensive attempts uh which seem to
dwindle by every second that he spends
but let's go go back to another very
interesting match Wesley so against
Dimitri on draken and we remind you that
Dimitri is currently down a point he has
the black pieces in game three he
decided on a very sharp Sicilian a rare
Sicilian with that early Queen B6 move
yeah and what do we have here Levy holy
smokes is this position messy yeah so
Wesley actually didn't I was wrong yeah
he castled long he's he's looking for a
for a scrap let me tell you right now
Dimitri and Drake and is very much also
looking for a scrap and apparently is
better but that that eval bar again very
deceptive because it only depends on one
move by black right now otherwise Wesley
is better this is this is a this is
Wesley just offered a draw oh this is so
interesting Wesley accompanies the move
Rook C7 with a dropper there's something
here that he really doesn't like and I
think I can tell you what that is I
think what what Wesley is afraid of is
actually the move Rook F to C8 you're
like thank you for the night now you
play Queen C6 thank you for the bishop
there's this devastating check on C2 and
although that doesn't look dangerous
after King A1 A3 look at whites King
look at the B2 square and look at that a
file which is about to open if you say
no problem I'll play Bishop D4 and
defend the B Pawn after AP Bishop B2
this is like the shades of the first
game where Dimitri just sacked all of
his pieces and was that close to mating
Wesley so and then Wesley so is that
close to mating Dimitri but at the end
of this line whites Chang is in
Checkmate it's very much indeed
Checkmate which will likely not be
overlooked and it's crazy because Wesley
is a move away from playing Rook take G7
getting a devastating attack of his own
what Wesley just did there with the move
on the live board Rook to C7 is he
wasted time you waste time day to day in
life it's not a big deal sometimes you
waste time on the chess board sometimes
also not a big deal in this case the
time wasting is that his Rook cannot
actually take the Knight because of the
counter attack that you just showed this
is this could be a very fatal error and
uh well Dimitri now gets a draw off or
accompanied with Rook C7 I think he's
going to sense weakness yeah that's what
worries me about that draw for right
when a high rated player with the white
pieces offers you a draw that probably
means there's something they're afraid
of so I think that you're absolutely
right the chances of Dimitri spotting
Rook fc8 have just gone up by a lot and
what makes matters even worse is that he
could start with the move A3 he could
say let me exploit the placement of my
pieces and try to open up the a file and
then if white plays B3 Rook fc8 looks
even stronger so interested to see what
he's about to do this is really
suspenseful that he's smiling like the
Joker he's down one and a half and a
half it's been a completely insane what
is he smiling at yeah what like is he
incredulous that oh Wesley just offered
me a draw haha yeah what is he he he's
got like a like a joker experiment
you offered me a job yeah I see it
he's he's laughing what and and he
agreed okay he took it Wesley patting
the chair there because he's like oh my
God Wesley is breathing a massive sigh
of relief right now rook fc8 and queen
C6 I don't see a defense to that move
the engine originally was giving an
advantage to White Wesley but when we
actually played those moves on the board
you saw the evil bar dropping
precipitously after Queen C2 holy smokes
is that a big decision put this line on
the uh I know right now we're we're
looking at uh Wesley Wesley's probably
analyzing the games like why can I not
get a better position against the
Sicilian yeah twice now twice now when
Drake has been better with black that's
not supposed to happen by move like 18
and again I think this decision to
Castle Queen said that may have been the
culprit for Wesley but the game is over
the draw has been agreed to and that
means Wesley maintains his one point
lead with one game to play today Levy I
you know as commentators we're supposed
to cheer on the players we want long
games but just objectively I think
Dimitri might have wanted to spend a
little bit longer he had 10 minutes on
the clock and there must be reason
Wesley offered a draw yeah well look at
that he Leslie's not leaving no he's
like job's not done you know he's okay
now it's done
he's probably gonna go continue to
analyze the position uh but not in the
room itself look at this he's spectating
Hikaru we know they have a great
camaraderie he was helping Hikaru a lot
in the Fisher random World Championship
Hikaru gazing around like
speaking of which Speaking of which all
the pieces are gone so Duda cold-blooded
trades everything and goes this is a dry
you ain't beating me that's exactly what
he's saying Duda looks pretty confident
he has uh maintained time on his clock
well not a lot but three minutes but if
he can get the position into a fortress
three minutes is gonna be more than
enough okay so he has B6 and C5 on the
board what the heck is going on in the
queen side so Levy I'm gonna make a
statement you tell me if you agree with
it I think from an objective perspective
white wants to have past pawns that are
as far away from each other as possible
so and that's actually hard to achieve
because if white takes on C5 then black
can actually take on A5 and white has
opacity but how does white maintain his
past Apon maybe it's by moving the
bishop back but then the problem is that
black eliminates remember that third
Pawn that white had on C3 without that
third Pawn black can give away his well
he can't give away his King but he can
try to give away uh his Bishop
strategically uh for one of White's
pawns and maybe get a wrong color Apon
or wrong color H spawn actually yes this
end game actually could be
decided by something super fascinating
as we look we were just looking at our
at our laptops here um that black Bishop
on A7 standing in front of that pawn is
not going to leave this could just be a
fortress defensive draw because in chess
when you are talking about a and H pawns
which is what Duda will have the
promotion Square in the corner of the
board has to match the color of your
bishop and if you notice hecaro's got a
light squared Bishop that h8 corner is a
dark Square which means that would be a
draw bishop and h-bond regardless of the
other material uh for uh for black would
be a draw and I think that is what Duda
recognize he could sacrifice his Bishop
he doesn't have to actually defend his
Bishop he could just leave it there to
die for the pawn and it's going to be a
draw I think it is as well I think
there's a high probability of that let's
see if Duda can put together that
apparently apparently A6 is winning whoa
oh my God immediately he played A6
because the bishop because the bishop
will die now because it doesn't have the
open diagonal that's absolutely crazy
that Bishop on A7 is jammed it's stuck
and now white can Focus all of his
energies on promoting that other problem
we need to go back to this game because
this is huge Levy what an idea by Hikaru
and here's the thing this is why he
played Bishop Bishop B5 if he had played
Bishop D3 and he'd done the same thing
black could have reopened the bishop
with a timely B6 B5 yes he put the
bishop there for a reason he didn't any
money
moment and now he's just pushing his
kingside pawns he doesn't even rush to
recapture C3 this is so ridiculous he
found the only trick in the position he
literally it's over it's over and let me
just show a really quick sample line you
could say well black stops the king Side
Pawn yep that's not where the action is
happening
your king can't contain both fronts at
the same time White's going to use the
pass Pawn to distract the black king and
then get his King to be
AST yes oh my God
he resigns
he saw that line immediately and this is
unbelievable he is
this is devastating for youngsters
Hikaru Nakamura is up 3-0 that was a
ridiculous game ridiculous preparation
and Bishop B5 and A6 you can see dude
again taking his headphones off they're
indiscus Levy what a start to the match
yeah this is just sickening I mean it's
incredible because folks you have to
understand we were watching the second
game and there's a big monitor here and
people started realizing When the tide
of the second game was turning when dude
it was better it's not over against
Hikaru until legitimately the result of
the screen pops up
no it's it literally isn't and as Danny
said in the pre-game show we were just
calling for that comeback oh my goodness
what have we seen there but what are we
seeing in front of us here with two
games remaining Samsung on the right and
anishikiri and Timur a job of on your
left Levy I'm gonna toss the ball to you
you choose where we go next I like the
Geary game I think it's super complex
but choice is yours yeah that Queen
straight there is a very interesting one
we we could pop into giri Raja let's do
it I didn't really give you a choice I
was just pushing you in that direction
from the start I was manipulating you I
see I was manipulated indeed okay so
what do we have here well maybe you'll
disagree with this observation I think
Anish giri is up upon yes one not trying
to make any controversial statements my
first day of commentary yeah yeah yeah
yeah people have been canceled for less
than you six pawns versus five and uh am
I missing something he's just he's just
up a punch he has an extra Pawn he has
an extra pawn and the most important
thing is that there's no compensation
you can say well what about the Rooks
well what are the Rooks are really doing
they're looking at the bishop on E3 and
the bishop on E3 is well protected by
the F2 Pawn so I think white could make
a casual move such as Rook 81 here
although Bishop f8 comes surprisingly
close to trapping the queen yeah the
queen can very much get trap B5 maybe B3
one of its only escapes and even then it
can there's attacks of the black Pawn on
A7 to A6 Knight comes to A5 so Queen's a
little bit of a No Man's Land There
Queen D6 might be the best move just off
for the trading but where did the queen
come from I think it I think it came
from D6 yeah he played Queen C5 and if
he plays Queen D6 then Timur will repeat
moves now maybe there's a better move in
this position yep maybe you could chase
the black queen with a move like Rook D5
which apparently actually that's
apparently this does look like an
incredibly good move yep if Queen A4
then I think after B3 the queen is
trapped and it's black screen here that
gets trapped rather than White's Queen
interesting yeah that is that is super
interesting the best move after Rook D5
I guess is rook d8 and then white sacks
the queen but the Rook will take the
queen no matter where it goes beautiful
yes black has to play Queen d8 and then
at the end of the line Levy there goes
another pawn and this should be a pretty
straightforward technical win for a
niche surprise he didn't do that he had
a chance to do that and instead he went
Queen back to C5 well I think he's gonna
reconsider and probably go back to D6
because Bishop f8 is very scary
yeah it is I mean the queen just doesn't
have a lot of squares and you know Rook
81 doesn't even really create a threat
the D7 square is controlled by Black's
Bishop so I'm honestly kind of shocked
that he didn't that he didn't find Rook
D5 we're sitting here in our comfortable
chairs yeah it's easier from the side as
the expression goes but you know the
energy Gary is 2770. I think you're
right I think he is going to go back to
D6 this is a very important moment in
this early stage of the match because
it's been two draws and Geary has to
punch the ticket home he sometimes gets
great positions and doesn't bring it
home he was just up two minutes he's now
down 30 seconds that's not good he's got
to make the right decision yeah and Tim
Moore's is wildly resilient I mean we
don't really talk about Timor in the
same breath as Defenders like Hikaru
Nakamura like like Magnus Carlson of
course but I've seen Timor pull off some
really pull out some really really bad
positions and we do actually see Rook 81
on the board so giri misses the
opportunity to basically put the game
away with Rook D5 instead he doubles his
Rooks and Bishop f8 is really asking to
be played dislodging the queen forcing
it onto an awkward spot and Levy I'll
point out one other idea the Bishop from
F5 can jump on down to G4 pinning the
Knight threatening to ruin White's King
side structure black is not out of ideas
here no absolutely not you're not out of
colors I like that red we got blue we
got green we have these colors we need a
regular yellow orange or whatever it
might be no black and there you go you
might as well just go play the match
seriously uh by the way uh best I tried
didn't qualify okay I didn't try it
didn't qualify as a so same result
apparently Queen to D6 is once again the
best move so
be just really need that Queen trait or
else it's very tough to make progress
again very easy to sit here and go oh
ninjas have fun it's plus one very
simple it's very different to be playing
there your time is ticking you're like
why am I not winning I should be winning
why am I not winning yeah black has no
targets and to make matters worse after
Queen D6 Queen A5 guess what move isn't
possible any longer Rook D5 this move is
no longer effective because the A2 Pawn
is not protected the Rokon A1 was
actually doing something it was sleeping
on A1 but it was also guarding a pawn
that becomes important in this line so
Anish giri now down to four minutes I
think he's experiencing the exact kind
of frustration you just outlined Levy
he's saying this should be winning I'm
up upon my pieces are on perfect squares
why can't I find that that you know that
final move just out of curiosity can we
put a move like Bishop E2 on the board
very natural is there some Rook takes E3
ideas lurking with Bishop to H6 and
trying to get some weird counter play on
white so you're attacking E3 that's a
pretty serious threat I'd say okay I go
Rook D3 yeah I I didn't exactly have a
follow up there but I guess you could
just go back Bishop F5 for example and
White's probably going to have to
re-sacrifice The Exchange and of course
White's kingside pawns are still
very much damaged no he absolutely Rook
takes E3 is an idea maybe this isn't
even an idea that is scaring a niche as
we speak three and a half minutes left
we keep talking he keeps thinking this
time pressure is going to be pretty
serious yeah when an Unstoppable Force
meets an immovable object he's going to
run out of time at this rate and we've
been here he had a seven there in the
first slot of the numbers and now he's
got a three and in about 20 seconds he's
gonna have a two that's where I like how
we're just it's commentary of time it's
just 65 seconds or so there's gonna be
one in front of his time but yes again
I'm full of controversial statements
today okay we'll leave Anish Guri to
think about this position not for too
long we hope let's check into our last
remaining game and that is of course Sam
sebian who has the white pieces against
nihal Serene he probably won't spend too
long in this game this seems incredibly
balanced and nodded up Levy am I not
seeing anything is either side really
pushing here to me it seems like this is
almost certainly going to be a draw it
it is very likely headed in that
direction it was kind of two forces that
came together here that nehal played a
provocative variation in Sam Savion said
you're not going to have any fun you're
down to game in the match you're going
to have to prove it with the white
pieces I'm not going to take any risk
actually if anybody is playing for
anything here I would argue with Sam
because the queen of the Knight have
together Unstoppable Powers yeah the
only way that I could see this game
getting interesting is if white let's
say plays 94 and manages to go Queen C3
and attack the F6 on the problem is that
any time you go Knight E4 let's let's
take a random move by black was Queen C6
for example if white puts the 994 the
moment he does that blacks Bishop swings
over to D5 yep and it pressures the
Knight and then if given the opportunity
black is obviously going to exchange the
Knight has to drop back to C3 I actually
think we're going to see a repetition of
this kind very shortly yeah again
there's only a few ways that white can
pose any problems and it's not at this
level of the game and probably not with
this much time on the clock but if you
remove the minutes area and they just
had 25 seconds versus 35 seconds yeah
queen and the Knight are vicious
combination because there's no way for
black to attack white but the Knight
definitely can attack the black king
yeah and it also doesn't help that white
has you know this damage on the king
side which always gives black these
ideas for Perpetual check we won in
Queen D6 if the Knight moves away and
there are no Targets on the queen side
either pawns on A3 B2 A7 B6 and H5 by by
nihal is is a perfectly serviceable move
just grabbing some space controlling
some squares and one way or the other
we're going to see your repetition here
I'm fairly confident that this game is
going to end peacefully and Sam is going
to maintain a one point lead with with
one game remaining a really really
successful start I would say Levy it
does a dream scenario for him to win his
first game uh with that with the black
pieces I mean not even with the white
pieces right the spectacular stuff so I
don't think nihal has a trailed in this
cgc by the way so nope this is a new
spot for him as well and we'll see how
he adapts we will indeed he'll have the
white pieces in game four but it's clear
that our most interesting remaining game
is indeed Geary against Roger publicity
finishes made a movement he has and it
is Queen D6 and the sad thing is we have
highlighted is that after Queen A5 the
pawn on A2 is hanging another sad thing
is that he's got 90 seconds on his clock
Timor has built up a three minute time
Advantage this is going to be a barn
burner fasten your seat belts folks
although Queen C8 not Queen A5 has been
played yo what is what is the idea there
because I was going to say White's next
move could be Queen G3 so what does
Queen C8 stopping exactly
that's a good question yeah I wonder why
I didn't play Queen A5 maybe he's trying
to involve the queen through F5 uh in
some lines although Queen F5 of course
runs into Bishop D3 a lot of times
and now when he's down to almost a
minute on his clock I wonder if he
should just play H3 and accept the
ruined structure to clarify the position
no he goes Bishop E2 Levy your idea oh
your idea takes in Bishop H6 looks
really darn good here yeah I think
anisha's idea after that is just to play
King H1 and so he won't he won't get
forked but then apparently rajaba has
sufficient counter play yeah if we go
through this line really quickly and
then we'll dial it back and watched him
make his moves after Bishop H6 King H1
black plays Bishop takes E3 let's say
The Rook moves black can keep harassing
The Rook with Bishop F5 blackened even
dropped the dark squared Bishop back and
say hey your light squared Bishop is
weak my Rook is on a good spot this just
looks like the kind of position you want
in your opponent's time pressure yeah
it's like a vintage King's Indian
defense with a bishop on G7 there's so
many of these motifs to sacrifice one of
the Rooks on the e-file grandpoint guess
who's one of the best Kings Indian
players of all time I forgot the name I
think it starts with the Daniel
narrative design
Kasparov you know and then rajaba and
then right he might very well play Rook
takes E3 at this point and he's
definitely thinking about it Timur has
now spent over a minute let's go back to
the live board and let's watch to see if
indeed The azeri Grandmaster snaps off
that Bishop on E3 what helps him Levy is
that there aren't too many enticing
Alternatives I guess you can attack the
queen but you nailed it the queen has
this nice Square on G3 and if Anish
plays that and then he plays H3 he
consolidates his extra Pawn so the ship
is about to sail and rajaba lets it sail
H5 is such an obscure move I guess he
wants HP Bishop takes H3 could he be
wanting to sack this bishop but then
takes Queen H3 Knight G5 just wins on
the spot that's a great point and the
bishop on E2 guards the G4 Square huh so
confused a couple of moves ago the best
move for white was to play H3 wait yeah
why not H3 there it's like there's a
there's there's movements forbidden for
reasons that we don't know it's like
it's been banned he goes King H1 I mean
H3 is still very much in the cards and
guess what Levy Rook takes E3 has lost a
lot of its luster yes because Bishop H6
no longer threatens Bishop takes E3
check it gives white a critical Tempo
that he could use for a move like Knight
D4 yeah Knight E5 Knight yeah Knight D4
because again there's the king is safe
now I'm so perplexed like sometimes the
best players in the world play moves and
I go oh yes of course how can I vote Yes
yes and now I'm just like what's going
on why is nobody acknowledging the move
H2 to H3 removing the light squared
Bishop from its post that was even the
best move before a niche played Bishop
E2 that was a tough move to play because
the king would have be open well now
it's it's it's strange for sure but the
only thing I could suggest is that with
the move H5 I think timora's signal that
he's really not sure how to further
improve his position for whatever reason
he rejected Rick takes E3 and I think
Anish is saying hey I'm gonna milk your
clock down I'm gonna toss the ball right
back to you because clearly you don't
know what what to do with that ball and
the strategy is kind of working now Tim
Moore is the one down under two minutes
the clock is beginning to equalize we
are headed down the path to a Time
scramble Yep this is gonna be crazy
because all of the pieces are virtually
still on the board this is gonna be
amazing just by the way I saw a result
pop up nihal sarin and Sam Savion yes
they have in fact agreed to a draw on
neither side choosing to play in the
sandbox with Knight vs horsey I mean uh
Knight versus Bishop they did not both
have Knights on the board so yeah
relatively peaceful game there it all
comes down to this you can't ask for
anything better each guy has a minute on
the clock with a full Board of pieces
this is a bullet game there's a flat out
bullet game teamwork continues to ponder
his next move the issue is that if you
just blindly Chase White Queen if you
play Rook 8 to E6 the queen can slide up
to D7 it can slide back down to G3 in a
way you want to keep this queen on D6
that might be the most vulnerable score
on the whole board but it's a catch-22
if you attack the queen you force it
onto a safer Square now two more is down
to a minute here we go oh yeah this is
uh going down from a minute now this is
like going down a giant water slide here
here we go you know uh all of the
distractions that you gotta deal with
and maybe you're high up you're able to
fly through the water jump in the pool
A6 after all of them he has moved a
random Bond because you know why because
he doesn't know what to do
A3 this is hilarious this is this is the
last remaining game of game three folks
as Levy just pointed out sevion and
nihal have drawn their game Sam Sabian
keeps his one point lead but can Anish
and Timur will one of them jump out to a
one point lead 30 seconds and now for
two more this is crazy they're on a
standoff yeah they're in a stalemate
yeah they're still okay retreating back
to E7 they're passing the Hot Potato
back and forth is he trying to go Rook
D7 I think that's exactly what we did
okay Queen C5 there we go preemptively
oh Bishop H6 is actually a move here
because the Rooks are trained at this E2
Bishop yes so is rookie three because
Bishop H6 after that doesn't hit the
King on G1 but it hits the queen on C5
so our old friend yeah our old friend
and Timur is investing virtually his
remaining time he can play a move like
Queen C7 if he wants to pass the move
Rook C7 on the board that's a tough move
to play I would play Queen beat that's
not the direction are they gonna repeat
moves are they both gonna be like hey
we've got too little time to handle this
circuit fail Queen C5 repeating oh come
on no way Gary's up a full Pawn at least
go Queen B6 Queen D6 put your queen on
another Square come on Anish it's not
it's not it's it's not that time yeah no
no no no no it goes for it but Levy
there's Rook to E5 and the queen is
almost out of squares no Bishop F5 by
Tim Moore a 5x more
gosh I don't know H3 Maybe by white
again okay Queen G3 Queen has made a lot
of moves Rook to E4 threatening to push
that H Pawn further forward maybe even
to H3 and induce serious weaknesses okay
brings them all the Rook G4 there oh
there was Queen D6 only moves kick the
bishop up H3 finally playing H3 it's
begging to be played it's been beginning
to be played for 10 minutes
oh H4 oh my gosh I'm so glad I'm not
playing oh my God if Knight takes H4
Bishop takes E2 and I think Bishop E5 in
the end this attaches the queen from the
Knight so he goes Queen D6 and there's a
stack on H3 we talked about this what
just take it and block with a knight
Queen H2 oh Bishop B5 slicing off
he missed Queen D7 that's it oh my God
he missed Queen D7 cutting off him over
95 hits Queen F7 root nine and 94 or
Bishop D3 trapping The Rook either move
wins
still winning but Bishop F4 reignites
the counter play for black oh my
goodness Queen Chief still winning oh
Bishop still up a piece just Queen G4
trade the Queens breathe don't forget to
breathe
okay rookie seven okay that's very good
but Timor I think cannot avoid the queen
trait well he's trying yeah King G1 a
king you want such a nervous move he's
just trying to gain time yeah like B4
like what I mean there's no there's no
gameplay here right now no I like before
though he's trying to go A4 and B5 and
then get the D4 score for himself I
would play A4 right now and B5 Queen D4
exactly B5 chase the Knight away two
more desperately trying to whip up that
last counter play but he has nothing
nothing on the king side yeah 95 Queen
D4 anyway probably
this is crazy still not over
yeah there it is heading in that
direction oh just taste snap take that
night get that off the board
Bishop F1 has stopped various checks on
the first rank nice classy move there
for Anish yes now the now there's
various ideas of unpinning your queen
and playing Rook to E4 but how Queen G4
I would play right now yep very nice and
Rook coming to D6 another pair of Rooks
is going to be traded
and with every material that disappears
this game six yeah six but Bishop D3 no
no I'm telling he's playing nervous
moves he's like if it feels like a niche
has timor's time you know what I mean
he's got 20 seconds actually he can take
a little time but he he doesn't want
this coming down to like a last chance
for teamwork G4 oh Rook D4 is a clutch
move classy clutch you name the
adjective forcing blackstroke off the
board and now it's over that's it
teamwork okay stage four Rook H4 that's
it he's gonna resign he's gonna
resigns the castle and gets the first
win in his match with Timur rajabov that
was an incredible finale you called it
it was nervous chess for a while but
Gary just outlasting to more Bishop
takes H3 let's give I need some credit
for how he reacted to that sacrifice and
as a result he is up by a point we have
our first lead of the match yeah that
was such an odd game because it was just
a pawn down for a while but seemingly a
mutual stalemate Anish giri breaking
through against his good friend in a
very tense game three
wow I mean I'm still I'm still
processing this match I'm still
processing just how many nervous moves
were made we had like a 30 move time
scramble Levy yeah I mean we joined this
game the time scroll really started
around move 27 and imperceptibly this
game lasted 61 moves more than half of
the game they played two separate games
they played a game where they just sort
of moved their pieces around and a niche
was up one and then they played an
entirely new game where they just had
less than one minute and were pushing
pawns so that they didn't lose on time
and then it's more sacrifice the bishop
incredible what an incredible game
anushkari jumps ahead by a point let's
take a look at uh the scores after game
three all of the games have concluded
starting with Hikaru who jumps out to a
3-0 lead we might revisit that game in
just a second Daniel scary we just
talked about him Levy Wesley he's up by
a point keeps his lead very
anticlimactic really interesting matches
all around yeah I think obviously the
only game of the round that was a bit
slow was Savion uh sarin but uh Wesley
so Dimitri on draken were a bit all over
the place uh and then agreeing to a
Droid of nowhere uh hear your job of
obviously just spectacular and I believe
we're going to look at the Nakamura
versus do the game if I'm not mistaken
Hikaru has been firing on all cylinders
winning games in every way imaginable
yep which is horrible news not just for
Duda but for everybody else in this
tournament no you're exactly right every
like game narrative right come back when
when because of opening preparation win
through good middle game play tactical
positional he's just winning every type
of game archetype and the confidence is
unbelievable I mean he is just riding
the wave of success and he is riding it
all the way to tournament after
tournament Victory we need to talk about
his the game that he just played this
was some incredible opening preparation
in a Berlin Levy can you talk us through
what your immediate thoughts were after
we saw this opening getting blitzed out
yeah let me just quickly even back up to
to this moment the move D3 in and of
itself he's up two nil in the match and
he still doesn't play an end game he can
kill the game right here essentially and
he says no I'm gonna play the antsy
Berlin inviting this bishop to C5 not
letting do to uh clarify the center and
then Duda fires off this move now Hikaru
likes this move right dude is not black
yes exactly with black and well
evidently with white with every color
you don't slow play with D6 or anything
like that or Bishop takes C6
um the white chooses not to play and
Dinah I mean they played how many moves
in a row did they play without even
thinking 17 17 I have an answer for you
they went exactly 17 moves before one
side started to think yeah and uh two
queens were traded about white lost the
pawn but we know what white got for that
pawn white God activity on the queen
side white God activity on the king side
and white got a clarification of the
center of the board so black couldn't do
anything so yeah white rob the bank
essentially for a pawn right rob the
bank for a pawn and Duda making a
mistake a little bit later allowing this
tactic Bishop takes H6 that was a
mistake we confirmed it he had to either
move the king or move his Bishop but
allowing this move losing not just a
pawn but transitioning forcibly into an
opposite card Bishop end game where
white dominates all of the files white
threatens Rook D7 and after all of the
Rooks were exchanged the bishop picks up
the the A6 pawn and the final brilliant
idea by Hikaru put the bishop on B5 and
only B5 lock up Black's A7 bishop and
casually walk your king over to B7 using
the passer on the king side as a way to
distract Black's King what a smooth game
Levy yeah just an unbelievable game and
just to break this down one more time at
that level of Chess between Hikaru Duda
everybody else in the event and so on it
comes down to the smallest of nuances
and Hikaru found it again the only
resource in the position both guys knew
what was going on both guys knew all the
resources Hikaru just knew that one
wrinkle of pinning that dark squared
Bishop in the corner he's up three
nothing what are you gonna do what are
you gonna do that's the question Duda is
asking himself what an hour it has been
Levy this has been incredible
Brave means private browsing and so much
more by default Brave blocks ads and
trackers on every page and video you
visit even on YouTube no ads means up to
three times faster page loads faster
streaming and faster playback it means
35 longer battery life while saving on
mobile data and internet bandwidth for
Android iOS and desktop get the best
browser for gamers streamers and
creators switch in 60 seconds at
brave.com chess we are going to go on a
quick break when we return we will play
the final games in all four matches here
on the opening day of the quarterfinals
at the cgc get hyped because we will
have plenty of fresh subscriber content
during the break so if you subscribe do
not go anywhere we will be right back
foreign
[Music]
meets every Wednesday we call it the
Maddie great place for just like a
hangout I love the atmosphere casual you
can like grab a beer have some fries
Crush some noobs and chests and right
now they're running a blitz tournament
but it's a great place to hang out every
Wednesday they host it right here at the
Madison and as you can see behind me
we're in full session here it's a great
place a lot of people have dropped into
this very location including Grandmaster
Hikaru Nakamura as recently as I believe
it was last week or a week before and
then guys like me also come once in a
while so it's a fun place to hang out
foreign
[Music]
I usually like to take it one match at a
time so I win that one I go on to the
next welcome to Toronto welcome to the
cgc are you excited for this week I'm
definitely very excited it feels really
good to be here all right so
I've been a replacement in the field do
you think that works to your advantage
or disinvested I think this is both
because he was probably preparing he
wasn't preparing against me and I wasn't
preparing against him so we both just
have like one two days to see what we
can do how is preparing for a rapid
tournament like cgc different from
preparing for large over-the-board
events so when I'm preparing for an over
divorce event I'm trying to pose my
opponent problems that they couldn't
solve in a long game while in a rapid
tour I can play some tricky lines which
figure out how to play against it
it's really awesome so on chess.com you
can click on insights and it will tell
you a bunch of details about your games
and one of the interesting things that
we actually found out about you is that
you play most accurately on Wednesdays
by far did you know this I definitely
didn't know that okay well apparently
you play by far the best on Wednesdays
thank you for joining us
baby
okay all right
yes I was born in Vancouver that is okay
doing great
yes I was born in Vancouver
but as fond as I am of that place it's
pretty tough not to fall in love with
the city of Toronto you're not allowed
to say that Andrea is that where the
chess bras are from no they're found
they're mine they're not even from there
[Music]
let's go
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
welcome back to beautiful downtown
Toronto this is just day one of our stay
in this wonderful City coming up we have
our fourth and final games of the day
first up will be Yanks just off Duda who
finds himself down to hikaranakamura
three nil as we head into our final
games of the day let's take a look at
insights for the entire field this is a
beautiful graphic Levy I want to involve
you on this Just A Feast for the eyes as
we see the overall accuracy and the
experience level the average game style
what catches your eye here I think it's
the fact that everybody plays around the
same level of accuracy but when you
compare the styles of Nakamura and Duda
smooth for Duda by the way the only
player who has smooth games when it runs
into intensity and time gets low
hikaru's style will win and that is why
they have played three games and Hikaru
has won every single one of them it's
been an unbelievable display by Hikaru
Nakamura and an intense game style not a
surprise there uh as Hikaru leads 3-0
well welcome back everybody to the
chess.com Global championship finals
here alongside International Master Levy
Rosman the one and only Levy what a
amazing previous round it's been this is
going to be an epic final game of day
one yeah I think every match has had its
moment in the spotlight but I think one
player who has had the entire day in the
spotlight is Hikaru Nakamura he's just
coming off of becoming a world chess
champion in official random his first
world championship ever he's been ranked
world number one in Rapid and Blitz sure
but let's add an official title to that
everybody was wondering is he going to
come in is he going to have any
adrenaline dump but uh no he's he's
approaching it no Reykjavik to Toronto
very smooth transition let's look at all
of the other scores of course icaro
leads 3-0 as we were discussing but
Wesley leads by a point against Dimitri
on draken Anish gear Elites Timor rajaba
2-1 as well and yet another 2-1 score
with Sam sevian up a point against nihal
Serene just uh close matches all of them
except of course the topmost one Levy
yeah Nakamura has been spectacular
Wesley so getting an early lead I feel
like that score in that match could be
anything in so in drinking could have
been three nil could have been two and a
half but it's two one for Wesley after
that draw Geary with a big win and
Savion with an early lead in his match
so uh some underdogs some people who we
predicted some people who didn't predict
but that's why we're here that is indeed
why we're here and part of the reason
we're here is to look at Hikaru Nakamura
as he gets settled there in his
comfortable chair puts his headphones on
I mean we can talk about Hikaru Nakamura
forever I mean his biography at only age
34 that's pretty young by most people's
standards I mean he has achieved he's
climbed the mountain and climbed it many
times Levy what an incredible player
what just a recent string of
performances this has been yeah
absolutely listen when you talk about a
field of players you look at
hikarnakamura is Magnus there right
those are the top two that you are
looking for and now that he's the world
champion of Fisher random as well he has
played all his games today in the
afternoon by the way so that fun fact is
uh it's a bit shocking he's still
winning every single game he's playing
but he's had a great run thus far and he
doesn't seem to be stopping anytime soon
he is in Peak form he is just it's
unbelievable Jan shistoff well he has a
psychological battle to fight right now
yes he has a 3-0 lead to overcome but he
just seemed broken in that last game I
think Levy you called it during the
break can he get it together
yeah am I see what you're saying yes E3
so we're getting garba's face
the car was like really really Riley oh
my goodness Carl looks disgusted at the
opening and he doesn't I don't think he
thinks it's a mouse slip does he no I
mean if it was a mouse that we'd see it
reflected on duda's face one
what
wait
what is going on did he just
is he playing a bomb cloud
I'm speechless I'm usually not
speechless I always know what to say
I don't know what I'm supposed to say
right now what am I supposed what are we
supposed to say right now we don't see
the chat Cham is being nuts ready yeah
absolutely not oh my goodness I'm so
used to having a chat on the screen
somewhere when I'm live casting I knew
something was up when he played E3 I
could sense it because if you want to
play an offbeat opening go on B3 you go
one Knight F3 if you go on E3 at this
level that means you're up to something
yeah but this is so shocking I mean did
Duda go on the break and buy a plane
ticket home already I mean this is right
but we Donnie and I were discussing this
he lost the first two games he was down
two nil in a worse way possible Right In
game one out played fair game two gets
everything he wants is unable to win
game three it's nothing he can do that's
it and so we were talking with with
Dania like he's His Own Worst Enemy
right now will he be able to pull it
together at least to score some points
oh there's our answer there's our answer
like the pawn Cloud he played the bond
cloud and the game isn't over he hasn't
followed It Up by resigning or
blundering his Queen he's actually
trying to get out of the situation of
course Hikaru is the worst person to
play the bunk loading I mean this
position is we can commentate the
position obviously the position is lost
objectively with the king I have two I
mean you have just moved your king from
E2 to F2 you have lots castling rights
your Bishop is terrible I could pick
apart the reasons why black is winning
out of the opening but I think most
people can kind of arrive at that
themselves this is crazy yeah sabotaging
your own development moving the king
multiple times and yet the position is
still only minus 1.8 now of course yeah
it's probably more like money 1.2
because white is like completely
succumbing to defeat and black is like
did he just play the bomb Cloud I have
to destroy him right also as you said
Hikaru got to 3 000 online rating I
think playing the bond cloud is that
right 2500 2600 he's better than
everybody in the world and he played the
bomb Cloud damn it so he did he did
reach 3000 or so with a bomb Cloud Speed
Run we will see how Hikaru nurtures his
Advantage he will not live this down if
he loses but we have another game to get
to we promise we will bring you more
Hikaru Duda coverage but Wesley so and
Dimitri on draken are about to start
their game let's have another look at
Wesley so's biography aged 29 Wesley so
needs no introduction one of the most
solid super GMS around he rarely loses
he's just a rock Levy I still can't
believe that I know it's so hard to talk
about anything else I'm sorry production
I I I I am absolutely shocked yeah
Wesley had a crazy run here he almost
lost to Jeffrey Zhang he was three moves
away from losing to to Jeffrey Zhong in
the round of 16 but uh he's got an early
lead here against the draken we'll see
what happens in game four yeah yeah this
matches so many twists and Trends right
I mean I was I stopped watching you know
round one because I was sure Dimitri was
going to win then Wesley missed made in
two but somehow Wesley stabilized in
that second game and then in the last
game Wesley with the worst position
almost getting mated when offering a
drawn Dimitri takes it so Dimitri he
pins his hopes on having the white
pieces here let's see what he can create
and he starts off with a pretty off-beat
English three is it I don't know I don't
like to see the Z3 I'm closing my eyes
no I I don't think we're gonna get that
Dimitri playing a very specific move
order uh looking to avoid a couple of
theoretical bumps Road bumps if you will
that's why I could play you put a piece
on E2 it's not the king this is so
unique this is such a weird line because
Camp black just goes c65 here like yeah
that's sort of the the typical way the
black meets this Wesley drops his Bishop
back to E7 I think that he is gonna go
c65 maybe Dimitri will try to beat him
to the punch
and played D4 in this position it's very
standard and since you've blocked your
light squared Bishop You'll Play G3 and
then bring the bishop out the other way
and he does so Knight takes certainly
right not fun yeah Pawn takes usually
black plays D5 and you can get like a
bad iqb and then quite why did you put
your knight on easy to block your Bishop
so what's he thinking is he gonna click
okay it takes as possible but this is so
much more natural but after D5 Levy I
mean is this really anything impressive
with your Bishop block 10 black has
super healthy position what am I what am
I missing here about Dimitri's opening
strategy ah he forgot to play King to E2
that's what it was yes how could I have
forgotten that was anything but I guess
he'll take on D5 and then finish his
development somehow and do his best but
yeah very odd opening listen he doesn't
have that many games remaining he's down
a point yep Wesley can basically well I
thought he could draw on demand of the
white pieces if he really wants to I
think he can he can play one D4 so
Dimitri has to make this game County he
can't just give up a quick draw uh that
would be that would be a disappointing
result so he's taking his time here
trying to figure out how to did I say
that in a Canadian accent did I just say
out no I I I I I was not I'm I'm still
shocked that we have I know I can barely
like him verbalize my thoughts but
Dimitri on Drake and he's got to make a
decision here he trades on D5 yeah I
mean this is obviously not that
impressive but plenty of pieces still on
the board exactly the game is not over
it's equal but plenty of life left in
this position yeah there's already
imbalance in the pawn structure black
has three three white has four two
almost like a battleship situation and
that will lead to various imbalances in
the middle and end game white has
opportunities of attacking on the king
side maybe bishop D3 some various things
over there on H7 so there's life left
for sure there most certainly is maybe
the move C5 can be considered to chase
the Knight away from D4 we'll keep an
eye on this game as they exit the
opening and under the middle game but
another game is about to enter its
opening stages and that is Anish giri
against Timor rajab of let's look at
Geary's player card he leads Timor by a
point he's 28 years old he is just a
walking meme he's an incredibly strong
Grand Master great guy I mean what what
categories does a niche not fill yet
generally walking meme has a negative
connotation I thought but positive in a
positive way positive positive walking
meme yes
that have been made by a niche and uh
folks make no mistake around 64 32 16
just demolished folks he really has he's
up in this match I know and the whole
draw meme Gary wins games you don't get
to 2770 by drawing but let's see if
teamworkromov can make up this one point
deficit much like Dimitri and Drake in
same situations got the white pieces he
has to make it count yep and already a
big choice on move three nimso Indian
will we see a rogozin there's a million
ways this could unfold wow he has
invited okay A3 Amish variation and a
niche cracks a smile and that generally
means they've probably had some
discussions about this variation at some
point probably some Fireside Chats now
A3 Levy has become incredibly popular
all of a sudden I mean everybody seems
to be playing uh you know God forsaken
line that just like a year ago was
considered one of the more inferior
responses to the nimso Indian yeah
that's because in many of these
positions what Knight F3 that's also
rare that is extremely rare I was gonna
I was just gonna draw an arrow yeah go
ahead that generally whites play is
associated with expansion in this form
and then the bishop and then this and
then so on and so forth but Knights who
have three folks again we're chestnuts
so this is a very normal move but the F
Pawn was supposed to go there so he's
just taking him totally out of
theoretical Waters here he is and he's
making Gary thinking the reason that
this line has been considered dubious is
is obvious just visual even if you're
not a nimzo player just look at White's
go inside constructure you're accepting
long-term damage black has an easy plan
connected with attacking a C3 the Bishop
from C8 can develop to A6 the Knight can
come to A5 so you're basically harassing
White's Queen side pawns if you're black
here and so Levy that's why you
highlighted that white needs to generate
play on the king side but maybe Geary
wants to play this in a more creative
fashion maybe get the bishop out to F4
maybe play a little bit more on the dark
squares in the center we'll see we'll
see as fascinating that the move Knight
to F3 has been played I think we're
probably we've left 99.9 percent of
known Theory at this point we definitely
have it now Timur is taking his time
I've seen people go G4 I don't know how
desperate he is I mean maybe anshu stuff
Duda will make a move for him here I
mean you do have King D2 so if you don't
let the Polish Grand Master near your
computer yeah I I was going to say G4 is
a very interesting move I'm sure the
computer is going to hate it and I'd
like moving other people's pieces we
both were thinking the same thing and
the the idea by the way is that after
Knight takes G4 some serious attacking
possibility on this G file absolutely
there are and I think that's what he's
contemplating and we are going to
contemplate the start of our final game
between nihal sarin and Samuel sevion
the battle of the young phenoms it's
been an awesome match between Savion and
nihal we haven't managed to cover it
quite as intensively but it's been some
high quality chess and that's not a
surprise when you have the likes of sam7
he is such a solid player as my first
coach would say he has like an adult
style he's 2700 weird to talk about it
that way he plays like he's been playing
chess for 50 years but he's got the
Tactical prowess of a teenager yeah and
once again I'll bring this back to the
fun fact of the day that he plays his
best chess on Wednesdays well just so
happens that right is it it's Wednesday
in Toronto still it made it's not
Wednesday in a lot of the world but it's
still Wednesday in Toronto 94 and he's
up two to one and I I felt heartbroken
choosing a winner in this match because
if he was going up against and so many
other people I may have chosen him to
win but so hard to go against nihal
sarin I know he's making us eat our
words yeah I don't remember the last
time nihal has lost a match I mean even
the last time he has faced a deficit you
pointed out the pregame show he crushed
dingley around that wasn't even close he
made dingley around look like a fool so
nihal son he's not used to facing a
one-point deficit and he also has the
white pieces so all three players who
face that one point deficit have a
chance to come back right now in this
game and a London system by any Hall
which he plays religiously online I mean
this is basically all he plays against
me in our Blitz matches and he's not he
doesn't play the London to make draws he
plays the London for a win that is
possible Eric Rosen can confirm that yes
he defeated dingler and I believe with
the London in the second game of their
match and of course he didn't win
because he played the London he won uh
despite playing the last number so yes
thank you for putting it that way but uh
Queen B6 is an interesting move order
Savion is not developing the knight in
the traditional way or developing the
bishop and now we have a prospect here
of a queen trade neither side is
actually going to take here because both
sides want to avoid opening up the
accompanying Rook on the a file I
believe actually uh dingly Ren played in
a very similar way with black against
nihal sarin he had a good position then
he proceeded to lose later in the game
so yeah and that's one of the things
that makes nehal so so tricky I mean he
takes these equal positions and he finds
chances in the unlikeliest of places so
Sam playing this in a very traditional
manner he plays the movie six I think a
lot of people might raise their eyebrows
because that does Block in the light
Squad Bishop Levy it's a closed position
it's a quiet position and it's a
position where as I like to say
sometimes on my stream not every piece
needs to be climbing Mount Everest at
the same time it's okay for your Bishop
to be on D7 but I know niho likes these
positions I I don't exactly remember
that game but I think this is exactly
how that game went really yeah and I
think which would make sense and and
then Bishop D7 and then Rook F to C8 and
then a regrouping like this and then an
attack on the queen side and he
stabilizes I think that's exactly how
that game went and you know what what's
super interesting is that strategy where
you play something that a previous
opponent played but because nihal won
that game maybe seven is hoping that he
didn't analyze the opening as carefully
uh but as you indicated ding did have at
one point I think even a slightly better
position so let's see what nihal can
bring to the table here the position so
very locked up the Queens still facing
each other you nailed it Levy neither
side wants to open up the a file for the
other side we have kind of a a standoff
type of position here this is so funny
this makes me think that savion's
preparation for this match was oh let me
see what dingler ended that's where it
ended he just went back and went well
only hot likes to play the London so
what happens if he plays London I'm
gonna play exactly how dingler look at
this he's not a bad strategy hey you're
following the world championship
challenge yeah I mean but this is so
funny I mean Savion was a last minute
replacement and he knew what his
opponent would bring to the table so
he's just said oh this his previous
opponent did a really nice job so I'm
just going to play the exact same way
why would I reinvent the wheel and here
we are all his prep on the board yeah
and Rook fc1 Newhall copying that move
the position still completely closed and
I think the first big decision
eventually one side will have to do
something on the queen side seat takes
D4 Queen takes B3 black can also played
the move C4 that's very common in the
London one thing you see really
frequently and this perhaps is the most
typical plan you play C4 white drops the
queen back then you drop your own Queen
back and you try to quickly run your
Pawn down the board B5 B4 but the
drawback of doing it here is that white
can very quickly Counter Strike in the
center with E4 and if your Pawn chain
gets broken up then you just are left
with the worst sides of your position of
a weak C four Pawn passive Bishop so
that's not in the spirit of this line
and that is the reason why if we go back
to live position Sam Sevin continues his
waiting strategy and ding I think also
played the move Bishop E8 yeah exactly
we're following that game I believe move
for move this is so funny and white has
run out of improving moves before black
so find proof here for white I believe
in that game something like Knight E5
happened but I to be honest with you at
this point I don't remember otherwise I
would be playing in the event myself but
something has to give white has to make
some move white just is literally
completely out of option and by the way
that's the idea of Bishop E8 I think
it's prophylaxis against 95 which no
longer comes with a threat and you can
see nihawk plays Queen C2 A5 stopping
anything else and expanding on the queen
side pushing the pawn pushing the pawn
to A4 I I love the way Sam has handled
all of the openings in this match and
the ball is is squarely in the Hall's
Court he's gonna have to produce
something because he can't let this game
go to waste and Savion with more time on
the clock as well things are looking
pretty good here Levy uh for Force M7
but let's check out all four boards at
the same time yes yes sorry I don't know
please go ahead he's gonna say like help
yourself hilarious example of going back
and forth with the queen yeah this is an
amazing view bird's eye view of all yeah
I love this and the cameras look at that
I know I could just stare at that for
the entire coverage yeah do we have to
commentate no can we just like wear our
heads sets but chill in the lounge so
you don't have to have us on the screen
Levy we have to go to the Hikaru game I
think the chat is going to go crazy we
have to update people on what's going on
there yes let's go yeah the the instant
recap of that game is that youngster of
Duda has lost three games in just the
absolute worst bouquet of ways and great
wow I love that term and uh he played
the bomb cloud in this game you know if
he doesn't like if he wins this game
with white because Hikaru makes a
mistake in overpressing
listen that's why when Magnus played the
bomb Cloud hikara responded with King E7
so the face that Hikaru was making I
think he was trying to decide do I want
to go King E7 here and avoid the
potential embarrassment that's gonna
accompany losing but you know what I
think swedey Carl let's say Hikaru loses
this game guess what people might laugh
but he's still gonna be up 3-1 he's
still going to be crushing it so Hikaru
cares about winning the match I don't
think he cares about impressing the
crowd and I actually really really
appreciate the fact that Hikaru
responded objectively he didn't throw a
fit he didn't play King E7 he just said
yeah you want to play King E2 and get a
lost position out of the opening I'm
gonna go up 4-0 is he going to go up for
zero dude actually hasn't done a
terrible job of coming back
but love you oh yeah the thing about the
bong cloud is you can make 20 good moves
after you move your king and then you're
still going to lose that's uh only
Hikaru can win so many games well some
some checkmating ideas potentially in
the future if there was something on F2
let me just show this really quickly
Queen takes F3 Bishop before almost mate
almost made but the King has the F2
Square it's very much not made yeah very
big aggressively not mate you just
blunder your queen so how is the car
going to crack open the position as long
as the center remains closed the
weaknesses in White's position can sort
of be squirreled away and hidden AC car
we're gonna try to strike at the other
side of the board what what appeals to
you here
yeah I mean it's
it's a great question if you look at the
well by the way one idea is Knight E4
not Queen F3 but just playing Knight E4
here with black and I don't think the
Knight is touchable because it's made if
you take it and queen F2 ideas maybe
okay let's let's Analyze This Knight
before I take it you take it yep King H2
I was thinking Queen F2 but I guess
there's some Bishop G2 stuff but okay
yeah Queen F2 Bishop G2 hides and then
the Knight guards G3 otherwise that
would be made the computer line is
released computer line is ridiculous
Queen F6 to D6 human said yeah yeah he
takes E4 is on but this makes sense once
it's played yes yes and you know what's
crazy Levy that pawn on A6 is so
significant here because without that
pawn white would be able to play Knight
B5 just I love hikar speeds are always
just in the right spot at the right time
yep so for example D5 you're playing 95
and Knight F3 we don't check yeah that's
it let's not talk about this line
anymore
um I love Knight E4 I think that could
be what he cars calculating and he
played 1944 okay I can't think of this
again he can play literally any move and
maintain an advantage between -1.5 and
-2 which is the equivalent of two full
pawns and that probably has to do with
the fact that white made three King
moves I don't know why why would you
think that let me stop making these
conjectures these wild guesses you know
listen it's my job they brought me in as
the uh you know to be the the Charles
Barkley of the show you know I'm gonna
say some crazy stuff and that A5 you
know Bishop A7 but I will make you laugh
it's minus two now by the way so uh yeah
Folks at home don't move your king three
times in the first ten moves of the game
16 moves of the game I'm real I'm really
sorry it was a little bit longer than
that yep but uh yeah again we have a
situation where dude is going to run out
of improving moves just like nihal sarin
did in his game the difference being
nehal sarin played a London and dude
and his car is not gonna run out of
improving Moves In fact with every
improving move White's position is going
to get closer and closer to collapse you
could say well I'm looking at this
position I don't see how White's
position is going to collapse black is
going to plan a bishop on D3 and then at
that point already sacrifices on D4 are
going to become a thing everything is a
thing because white is a king on G2 a
bishop on F1 all of White's pieces are
discombobulated so the moment black
sacrifices anything in the center I
think it's going to lead to Victory add
on top of that the fact that Duda now
has five minutes to Hikaru seven yeah if
young stuff pulls it off this might
be the most shocking game of the whole
match the shot at this game of the year
yeah no he Cara just doesn't lose these
positions
oh can I show a cool line sure
um I love this so it's like our
Playground now it is totally our
playground but I actually forgot which
line I was gonna show I was okay it was
ed4 or D5 there was some line where
black sacks on F3 I made it work but I
already forgot how to do it because
White's position is so bad it was
something like Knight C1 it was this
okay but here here black and wind in a
much simpler way just Knight takes D4
just as a sample of a line where black
sacks on D4 Queen D4 just look at this
we don't even have to handle it Rook H1
Queen F2 mate these are ridiculous lines
that we never talk about in high level
games that's why I want to show these
yes it's very painful very disturbing
position and I got some orange juice
here I was thinking to drink it gets
some vitamin C this position makes me
sick
oh gosh yeah I think Young shishtov has
had enough I I think he probably thought
he had good chances in this match and
then game one happened and then game two
happened
and then he was just broken I mean that
game three you know what got to him the
fact that let me play Berlin let me play
the most solid opening in existence
nikaru still just destroys him out of
the opening yep yep that that is just so
tilting okay let's get out of here let's
go back to our four game view let's I I
can't look at just this position anymore
I need it diluted by some more normal
positions Levy we've got a couple of end
games top right we have on Drake and so
in an end game what catches your eye
here I like that and Drake and just hit
him with a fork little Knight C7 action
but I I am concerned about the fact that
that position is probably going to just
disintegrate mutually let's put it this
way it's the last game of the day you
know especially if the match is close
nobody really wants to take a crazy
amount of risk tomorrow will be a
completely different story if you have
to win in game eight you're gonna play
some wild openings but Wesley giving
what is Wesley thinking about by the way
yeah what is he thinking about let's go
to that game let's let's see how the
position's gonna disintegrate I'm not
totally convinced that this is just
gonna be a dead draw uh but let's take a
look at uh the details of this position
the night is on C7 oven okay so the Rook
is attacked I'll tell you what he's
thinking about he's thinking between
rook ac8 and Bishop D5 to B3 counter
attacking White's Rook aha oh and he's
just played Bishop there you go but okay
I take the Rook you take the Rook I take
the bishop but isn't black gonna be
slightly better when all is said and
done and all the all the checks are
balanced Knight takes a eight Bishop
takes D1 this hasn't happened yet I'm
just sampling this King takes D1 now
there's no discoveries obviously it's an
end game so Bishop takes E3 blah blah
blah blah
couldn't you make a case that black is
slightly better because of White's pawns
or do you think it's not significant I
learned from my favorite YouTube
channels that Bishops are better than
Knights In the End Game having said that
yes Pawn structure is very important it
could just be another Savion nehal
situation where it's a night Bishop but
instead of Queens it's Rooks I the
Knight is going to go to C5 make no
mistake and it will stand there for the
rest of them you're right Bishop is
going to go to C4 White's going to get a
rook to D1
these targets are unattackable they're
just optically awkward but a lot of
people kind of forget that weaknesses
don't exist on their own they have to be
attackable for them to actually be weak
and often in end games you know these
isolated pawns can be safely defended by
the king we're going down this exact
line now Levy black could throw in
Knight C5 check he does doesn't really
change the tenor of the game I think
we're gonna have a draw yeah the Knight
is great but as you said there's
weaknesses and then there's weaknesses
that can actually be attacked so if a
weakness exists but it cannot be
attacked is it a weakness Schrodinger's
a weakness well it's like the forest
question right if a tree falls in the
forest and nobody hears it does it
actually make a sound there's a bunch of
those yeah I know does it make a sound I
I don't know if there's like a
scientific answer to that question I
think it's like a rhetorical I I see
yeah but I feel like you that's why I
discussed frequently physics I see I see
I do get to these discussions frequently
to my to my great detriment but King C2
on the board he's thinking
he's thinking there's a night hanging
was there a drop but there has been no
draw for yet what is he thinking about I
mean you could play Rook C8 if you
wanted a toy with the Knight why would
you gift you know what's hilarious oh
and on Drake and just offered a draw but
he just offered it maybe Wesley was just
waiting for that draw for to come well
what a what a Chad seriously we got
multiple Chads in the room right now we
do bong Cloud we got it waiting for your
oh he waited for his opponent to offer a
draw and then he declined it look they
said now I'm gonna take it yeah wow what
a psychological play there Wesley I'm
not totally surprised you know why
because black is not risking at all and
we have seen Levy you can co-sign this
we've seen people like Levy and Magnus
squeeze smaller advantages than this did
you say Levy and Magnus
did I just say Levy in Memphis I meant
to say Wesleyan oh aren't you flattered
I confused you with Wesley I thought
that was such an effortless line I just
said like you just like threw it in
there I was like supposed to read the
compliment I mean I'm sure you've
squeezed advantages like this before as
well yes I've squeezed advantages out of
positions back to my opponent so before
we jump to another game can we even
visualize a reality where black somehow
wins this game maybe he sets his Pawns
in motion what do you think about that
uh actually yeah very legitimately yeah
Rook D6 b5a4
Rook d65 A4 and then maybe put a knight
on B3 so that on B3 and again black is
not risking we can't say that enough
right yep Levy could make 30 moves say
hey I didn't didn't work out let's make
the draw so it totally makes sense that
you should Levy again oh my God what's
wrong with it are you complimenting me I
mean listen man I'm flattered I could
absolutely make 30 more moves I could
also make 30 more moves for both sides I
actually think I confused your name
earlier okay Wesley Wesley we'll see if
Wesley can Wesley can squeeze out this
Advantage but let's go to another game
let's take a look at uh the Anish giri
game we haven't checked in in a while we
have a a londony type of position
although we remind you this did not come
from a London this came from a uh a
samish a samish nimso Indian and a queen
trade is in the cards or is it in the
cards right exactly there was uh it
looks like a London but the bishop on F4
somehow perished yeah where did it go
very interesting because what is a niche
bobbing to I I heard producers or
somebody involved in the show outside
talking about if we can get the
information of the playlists public
and we can like see what they're
listening to I don't know if we have
that information I would be very curious
yeah yeah I'd be curious if somebody
could actually guess okay the queen
trade has happened and Timur follows it
up I didn't say Levy actually named the
player correctly Rook 8-2 preparing to
double Rooks on E1 so from a purely
visual perspective uh Levy it would seem
like white is better because the A6 bond
is a weakness but there's a big
extenuating factor black has the B file
and black has the potential to
infiltrate P2 yes I think it might have
might balance each it's uh each other
out yeah and if you trade A6 Pawn for C3
Pawn black wins the game basically so
exactly Yeah well black just gets to
pass Pawn
um I just noticed that there's no way
you can throw my name into these two
players uh kind of when you're bringing
them up because there is no l anywhere
else exactly that's I think what I was
why I was doing is Wesley and Levy
actually sound pretty similar yeah here
there's a lack of the letter L so I
think you're safe and in this game by
the way look at the time last game it
was a niche uh suffering this game
almost three times the time Advantage
for black yeah nine minutes to three and
a half the time was not moving there for
a second speaking of a tree fall in the
forest we can have a whole conversation
about time being a social construct but
it seems like it has a began moving once
again it has indeed now do we think
black is going to go I I'm pretty sure
black is going to go Rook FBA can we
forecast what we think is going to
happen so let's say Rook FB displayed
white response probably with rook fa1
and let's say I play the simple move
Rook B2 the obvious move
here the problem is that black has no
threats and white could try to solve the
problem of his back Rank by Shifting the
king over to E1 and at the end of the
day not only is the A6 spawn a weakness
uh Levy but there's also F3 E4
possibilities much like there are in the
London yeah there's like some weird way
black could get the A6 Pawn to A4 and
get a bishop to C2 that would be a
really bad situation oh oh but you're
not in time yeah exactly you had one
more Tempo okay why is that position
still okay
it's like hardly better I guess it's
because of Rook C2 maybe there's a
various oh and doubling the Rooks and
you called it the C3 Pawn is a big
weakness yeah that is that a pawn is
disposable somehow and you just use it
to decoy the opponent into playing
passively okay so even if black sacks
the a pawn are many scenarios the
activity compensates for it and so Anish
Guri probably calculating those types of
lines he's got plenty of time to do it
what's your prediction you think there's
gonna be a draw or you think something
crazy is going to happen probably I
don't know I don't feel like there's
enough I mean if anything you give white
a couple moves F3 and E4 is on the way
that that looks really unpleasant
because if black loses the defense of
the Pawn on C4 and the pawn on D5
collapses let me just kind of show what
I'm talking about here this is very bad
white could very easily go on to win the
game literally white gets two moves
right now white is probably just better
immediately yeah so this game comes down
to one move at a time you lose the D5
and C4 pods white has connected passers
in the center that's that's dynamite in
these types of end games so anisha's
good reason to be thinking right now and
we'll keep an eye on this end game as it
unfolds but let's go back to our
beautiful four game view I just I think
we can't look at that view enough
it's it's gorgeous but Levy correct me
if I'm wrong but we have to get back to
nakamura's game sure we're not going to
get another bomb Cloud this tournament
so I think we need to go straight listen
into hikaru's attempt to dismantle it
don't tempt me with a good time
I think he is dismantling it what do you
think the Knight is on F4 it's just it's
just a positional squeeze and dude is at
30 seconds and you know whatever you
know the worst part of this is but the
worst part of all this is what is it
Duda has to play another game not today
at least one at least one game I'm just
saying like he has to at least show up
tomorrow and play I think he's gonna
play a bomb cloud with black well okay I
won't answer yet I'll make a confession
to you as the last minor pieces are
traded and the problem Levy before I
talk about it is that white couldn't go
rookie one just so everybody's on the
same page because here black simply
takes and starts gobbling up all of the
pawns this is a lost queen end game yep
Duda has to give up control over the
e-file and I think Hikaru is gonna go
Rook to E3 and just start collecting all
of these weaknesses but when Danny
mentioned that in the OR Amman mentioned
that in the event of a 4-0 score one of
the good things about the format is that
the players still have to play the next
game I was kind of laughing to myself
and saying oh that's a hypothetical it's
obviously not going to happen
this is about to happen yeah rookie two
wait rookie two just ends it doesn't it
yeah rookie two and rookie two Rook have
two G5 goodbye go home that's the dinner
time look at this I think yeah I I I I
don't know what to say I mean there
there's ways of going out when you're
down three nothing and
this is uh yeah this is a stunning yeah
self-sabotage whoa took on C3 he didn't
even let me play rookie two he took on
C3 still completely winning he's gonna
go Rook C2 on the next move
everything wins all right everything
wins geez I mean this was Rook C2 trade
the Rooks and go C3 c2c1 yep yeah we're
not even spending any time he's just
saying my king is perfectly safe it's
over
what a
what a day
wow I can't believe we saw a bomb Cloud
I don't like that you know we're not
supposed to we're supposed to commentate
the games as commentators not judge the
games
I don't love that decision by on shistob
I mean I don't love it either I don't
love it either I mean I feel like you
need to fight yeah yeah it's sort of
it's strange on the one hand you could
do whatever you want and I'm not a huge
guy about like respecting the game or
yeah no neither am I however you but
like you're it's the cgc it's the
highest prize fund individual win yeah
victory for the entire year it feels
weird to be here fly out and play a bond
cloud and I'm totally laissez Affair
like you know do whatever you want you
know screw around in the last round
sometimes when it doesn't matter it does
matter here you're absolutely right 200k
price fun I'm shocked at this decision
by Young tristoff And I think Hikaru
dismantled it very professionally the
result of the game was never been
questioned I don't think Hikaru wants to
win like that and he leads he leads 4-0
I don't think Hikaru wants to win the
game no he does not I think wants to win
the game in the and display signs of his
uh chess style that are really really
good yeah but not like that no he he
most certainly doesn't but he did win it
like that yep and he's up 4-0
um we have three more games that are
remaining they're all in the end game
let's go to their sarin savian game
because it's been a while since we've
gone to that game and the end game seems
very very unbalanced Levy oh my weird
position how did we get this from a
London yeah this is a London gone wild
uh Sam is advancing those Queen side
pawns which by the way is the entire
meta strategy of his setup to rotate the
effort over to where it's standing now
on the C file remember that's the afro
oh that is the afro that's the effort so
this whole strategy is absolutely
fascinating and he took it from dingly
ran and he's made it better dude Tim
Savion is on his way to being up two
games here this is I really regret not
picking him I I really kind of wanted to
but I do but it was just the pressure
it's knee-haul yeah we have 10 seconds
in there to make a decision you know
what I mean I said I'll just be dingly
rent no this is uh what a show seven is
amazing I hope Sam Savion had his
headphones on when we were making our
picks and he didn't hear us because I
don't want to run into him over there
he's looking around the bling I'll
making sure he had he had no ride did he
arrived like the second after he made
our picture Levy I think some people
would look at this position say wait a
second you're saying black is better but
look at these pawns on e4 D5 and F4 why
aren't these pawns that affectable the
simple reason is that they're totally
and completely blockaded yep an atom B7
guard C6 if you push E5 you lose the D5
Pawn if necessary black stroke could
come into E8 the Knight comes into C5
and just look at Black's extent of Queen
side control yeah Knight coming to D3
continue Levy no I was gonna say that
there's really like this looks
terrifying right like D6 and you move
the Rook I was gonna go to D7 okay you
can even attack it from from C6 as well
it looks like white just has a monster
over here but yeah just F6 yeah just I
mean you cannot have three of your four
pieces on the end game in the background
yeah one night I mean it's a queen it's
a queen but it's a knight okay it's like
buying a nice car parking it in the the
random parking garage right so it's uh
you're just gonna start losing your
pawns one by one this Rook will finally
make its first move after 33 turns so uh
it will get in the game at the right
yeah well the pawns on D6 and E5 are
kind of like what what happens when I
try to pair ballpark the ponds disappear
almost immediately Rook comes to E8 and
seven just saying I'm chilling I'm
applying pressure on White Center I
can't believe there's a four nothing
score on the screen I know it's it's the
cognitive dissonance that's created by
that we see those scores maybe in round
one of the cgc entitled Tuesday how we
know we we literally didn't we never saw
a score like dude is like the 10th
ranked player in the world just one uh
tournament yeah just one aim chest yeah
just one aim just like there's Carlson
and he beat me which is more impressive
yes of course no certainly if I was
there oh my God forget about it but
Hikaru won Fisher random World
Championship which is the pieces are not
set up the right way right the right way
is it set up in a different way you
could make the argument it's not going
to apply here it's four to nothing sorry
I know we got a game on the screen folks
no it's this is not supposed to happen
nobody's gonna begrudgeous if we talk
you know extra about about what we just
saw in hikaraduda but
no that was that was incredible nihal
has to save this game I think if he goes
down 3-1 and he loses another game of
the white pieces I mean
the path to a comeback is going to be
narrower than ever oh absolutely and
Savion hasn't lost control of a single
game yet which is what happened against
Levon like levon's style was very
provocative was the reason that he was
able to defeat Sam but Sam playing like
he got nothing to lose and yeah
very very strong performance that's our
game's not over though he's still got to
win it which is a skill in and of itself
that's very difficult I know and I think
nihal might have to play T6 and E5 right
now the party Force hanging and if you
play E5 you drop the pawn on Def if you
drop one of these pawns the game is is
over immediately I actually think the
only way to generate counter play Levy
if we go down this line D6 Rook D7 E5 F6
this is the position nihal might be
stuck on for yeah I think you have to
sack on C4 oh now it's not a Panacea it
doesn't it Forks the knights technically
but one night can drop back and defend
the other the other night defends A4 you
have a symbiotic relationship here but
maybe okay
you know I can try somehow to keep the
pawns alive but even if he finds all of
these moves with a minute 46 currently
on his clock I I don't see him pulling
this one out if the computer is saying
it's minus 1.6 or it would minus 1.8 and
this is what the computer is suggesting
it comes over the game is over well I've
seen Yeehaw pull out some crazy
comebacks certainly you have to
acknowledge that yes but but yes yeah
okay D6 Rook D7 on the board let's
follow this line now he's gonna play E5
I don't see an alternative now he could
play Knight C4 now yeah basically a
transposition and that's probably what
he's contemplating like do I I think he
sees this idea which is exciting because
it's the only move he has he can only
defend his Center upon or sack the
Knight he has no other moves he has no
time nope because otherwise
after E5 F6 yeah you lose the D6 Pawn
the D file opens up the Knight
infiltrates D3 and then it's like you
know rats descending Upon A Feast if I
if I said white could not take on C4
right now White's position is atrocious
it is like legitimately horrible because
white doesn't have the time to untangle
anything and attack the only weakness in
Black's position which is this Pawn
so what do you do yeah I have no idea
what you do neither it is knee Hall as
he drops to below a minute let's go back
to our bird's eye view because we have
two games other than this one that are
still underway and they're all very
exciting you have the top right of your
screen here Wesley trying to squeeze out
that advantage against Dimitri on draken
who cannot afford to lose and on the
bottom left you have timurujabov that
facing Anish gear yeah I was gonna say
the game on the bottom left might finish
right now okay let's go to that game
yeah can we just quickly pop into that
game we absolutely can hear in our job
of King F1 should just be a draw right
Rook C1 king of two and then just repeat
where we're waiting F1 I think there's
Rook oh he goes three I did not expect
that so now if rookie to check King D3
yeah exactly and then black gobbles up
the two pawns but white has the past D
Pawn I'm not sure why King F1 was not
possible it wasn't but I think he's
playing for a win I think he he saw the
draw I just didn't want to make the draw
okay that's entirely possible
oh I mean three pawns is three points uh
oh what oh Wesley won that wow he's that
one out oh that's unbelievable what went
wrong in that game I feel like it's been
so I feel like that game was just
balanced did I missed something oh
watching Wesley so there on the screen
getting up well it was balanced it was a
slightly better end game for black we
didn't think that Dimitri would lose it
though just because of how solid he is
but Wesley goes up three to one over
Dimitri on Drake and The Rock Levy at
the end of day one What A Strange Day
for Wesley because he's won two games
with black and Dimitri with white is
unable to create enough chaos it's
fascinating like sometimes when you play
Black it's easier to make nonsense
happen on the board and that's what
Dimitri's strategy has been but he
hasn't been able to win those games and
with white he's he's been well he
shouldn't have taken a draw in the last
round he had a chance he had an attack
with black but we have two games
remaining and they are very very sharp
right side you have knee all started the
white pieces trying to come back down a
piece now he did sack on C4 Levy and on
the left side I think this game is about
to end yeah we're gonna have a draw
momentarily in our rajab of giri game
but uh let's keep these two games open
for now because I don't know which one
of them is going to end first yeah this
uh Geary game is actually very tense
it's very easy to forget that end games
can be so tricky just think about Duda
Hikaru uh the game three so right now
Anisha is going to try to get these
pawns off the board and so is rajaba but
doesn't want all the pawns off the board
he just wants I think Rook A6 though
Le'Veon Rook takes H6 King D7 you grab
D6 and then even an opponent game if you
give up your F5 Pawn it's still gonna be
a draw sure exactly so these players
know how to simplify down to the fact
that even if they lose material it's
still a draw because you could draw with
just the king against the king in a pawn
if you know what you're doing which they
do and you could also Chuck the H Pawn
by pushing it up to H5 to force white to
ah leave your king alone and then play
King D7 and if you want to control rook
and game a pawn down yeah you can
display that with arrows yep okay he
gives a check on A3 also possible
literally anything draws yeah that this
game is purely like academic at this
point even result is not a question even
this is a good move for always getting
rookie 3 and forcing the king to be very
passive are you sure that's not your
twin brother and in there f4 on the
board yeah that's it yeah King D7 yeah
yeah and we can divert our eyes to the
right side
okay rookie three for example and
literally anything you could leave the
F4 Pawn take D6 you have a Philadelphia
position on steroids yeah just don't go
rookie three King F2 rookie six probably
and even that might I think even that is
a draw but this is just a very trivial
uh draw for these guys I don't know why
he played it that way though Levy now
his King is cut off I think the only way
to actually draw this is your Rook B7
and Rook E7 now
oh my God I think if you don't do that
White's gonna get his King around
through the king side F2 G3 G4 and then
eventually you're gonna get a Lucina
position oh I see what you're saying
yeah oh but Rook B3 now or Rook B7
rookie seven because the pawn is too far
in front
look at the other board by the way oh
yeah what's happening there there we
there we see Rook B7 The Retreat yeah
and the Hell's Pawns have made it
through this is actually a very bad sign
for Savion okay now Geary has indeed
played rookie seven clearing the path
for his King and that's okay we can
officially call that game a draw he's
not gonna lose that
what's happening in savionstar and E6 on
the board what happens if you take that
pawn Levy does why play D7 yes but don't
you have another Rook can't the other
Rook go back so we're saying Rook takes
C6 D7 and a draw greed by the way draw
Green and drop of Geary yep something
like this rookie six and there we see
Geary very productive day at the office
he is the leader in his match after the
first four games by a score of Two and a
Half one and a half that one's gonna go
easily seven or eight games if not more
all the games have been so close even
the one result of decisive game it was
the time scrambles with 40 move time
scramble and timory's gonna be
disappointed but man is this match close
speaking of close matches we have a must
save game essentially for any All-Star
and E6 is on the board Levy pick it up
from here you were talking about a line
exactly so if you play rookie six white
is going to try to sneak the pawn in
with D7 and you cannot capture because
obviously you have a hanging Rook here
but the move Rook B8 is possible and
after Rook takes Knight takes Rook C8
check it's actually not as dangerous as
it looks be because the promotion square
is covered yep and The Rook is defended
it's a crazy crazy sequence of moves
there and I I I could pull it up of
course he's actually he's actually
played Rook bb-8 yes so he hasn't taken
the pawn he hasn't taken either Pawn Sam
thinking that he can survive no matter
what three seconds on the clock oh but
Knight 67 yes 97. oh you can't take yeah
blundered that or maybe he has a trick I
don't think he had anything though
because if you had defended the D6 Pawn
you would have lost the other Pawn okay
I think the trick is he's gonna take on
A4 and he's going to try to hold us down
to piece which is not impossible he
still has that E6 Pawn he still has a
lot of Peace activity work is still
required here for sam7 but this is where
Seven's time management really steps in
he's got a minute 45 and that's really
plenty of time he needs a couple more
accurate moves here yeah I guess you
just go Knight dc5 or even Knight F6
because the Rook can't take aha and
Knight F6 if I go E7 I didn't think that
far uh but let's just Rook D7 again okay
he plays a very natural move Knight f8
oh Knight f8 wins the pawn oh Knight f8
but there's is there
E7 or something so Knight f8 and he goes
that F6 open Knight F5 and if you play
Knight takes E6 there's Knight E7 check
oh my goodness walks off The Rook oh my
God this is not over but there's Knight
E4 check for black now the Knight to see
the C is ce4 yeah King moves there's too
many Knights oh my god look this is made
Knight C4 King H4 G5 is literally Chuck
mate
Knight C4 King F3 your g-pawn is also
hanging and if black loses both of his
remaining pawns Levy then white gets
serious chances this is an awful spot uh
nihal has made this a complete mess and
he had 14 seconds versus three and a
half minutes this is a worst nightmare
scenario for Sam Savion who's his head
is in his hands he's he's not thinking
he's in any bad shape he's thinking I
might mess this up I got 45 seconds I
mean this is going to turn into a three
result game if Sabian drops to 10
seconds and I've seen crazier things
happen he finds Knight's Eve Fortress
that's a movie big Big Move that was the
only move actually to keep a decisive
Advantage but can he gather the guns to
take on E6 and he does does now King fa
best move Rook G6 try to go after Black
slash Five here maybe or Knight G5 check
I don't know dude let's take a second
just to appreciate how nihal is
defending this with no time he's finding
every last chance yeah I mean players
have skill sets and this is his skill
set and so I've been getting more and
more nervous as his clock ticking down
you can see the concentration 94 to G5
check might be the only way here to
tangle your pieces they're almost at the
same time this this is a disaster
there's some chances that nehal even
somehow pulls this off but I doubt that
happens but Never Say Never
oh my God Knight D5 check can you hold
get to that last Pawn without blundering
a fork I think he can I think he's gonna
win the pawn yeah the pawn on H6 is
falling oh Savion is gonna be so
frustrated here
let's hit H6 is falling but it's not
over yet because Black's still up a
piece he can torture him for 50 moves
here if he wants
yep Rook takes H6 I think it's safe to
capture two seconds D3 checking is gonna
go forward oh that's very important
otherwise you could get mated there this
is so absurd H5 how is he doing this
Levy whichever Knight gives the check on
F4 the King has only one Escape score
that's all it needs yes it's just
dancing between H4 and G5 seven has five
seconds
Rook F6 Jack G5 nehal is the one making
progress I know this so this is a
completely ridiculous just Sublime
superb defensive attempt defense here by
any All-Star and King G4 still not over
Knight D5 still not over
93 look at the look at the Knights off
yeah it's a draw but he should make 50
moves Yes actually you might not even be
able to win the pawn like this might be
an even easier draw than it is without
the pawn
this is okay can you all offering a drop
obviously Savion declines it yeah
but I think Levy G6 just forces black to
give the Knight away
how exactly like how is black gonna make
progress there's King G5 oh I see and
yeah that's it is this a nope he's still
trying Knight F4 if Savion wins the pawn
this game goes on for another 50 moves
yes and I think he actually just might
he says
Paul made it so far
you could get mated here yeah nehal just
gives the pawn away Knight okay
but the good news buckle your seatbelts
folks who are here for another 50 moves
yes you get to hear our voices little
ASMR there for you as we talk over this
fascinating end game here well but this
end game is much easier to defend than
rook and Bishop versus Rook yes I
remember when I defended it against
Robert Huebner in the Dortmund
tournament in 1975. Rook G4 and uh you
should play this out of course and and
the reason is so hard to defend imagine
the Knight was a bishop it would cover
the king's Escape it would be Checkmate
it was in a few moves you know so it
would uh yeah you're right Rook H1 would
literally be Checkmate if the Knight
were replaced with the bishop the only
way I've seen in the side of the night
lose this King G6 and forget one king
just oh my gosh did you just have to
it's been a long time I didn't say my
sentence because I yeah I saw the same
thing
yeah yeah no I see why I see why you
stopped there but the only way I've seen
people lose this is either on time or
you blunder a fork yeah it's almost
impossible to blunder Checkmate because
even if you set up a quote-unquote
mating net The Rook will always have a
lateral check to dislodge the king
that's yeah that's exactly what it is is
that black could set up various
checkmating ideas and if white allows
them well then you deserve to lose and
if you don't allow them then good job
you held the drawing out Savion is
completely not he's not doing anything
wrong okay playing a bong cloud in game
four and losing the match uh the way the
way it happened in duda's match yeah
that was probably doing something wrong
as Savion is completely within his right
to play and you never know what might
happen never know the internet right
might go out or something like that but
uh wow he could have been up three to
one and it's only a one uh one game
match I can't believe nihal is well I
don't want to jinx him it's not over yet
but if nothing crazy happens he's gonna
save the game listen if he comes back
tomorrow this game is a potential
turning point I mean he keeps the lead
to one point that just feels so
different right you come back tomorrow
morning you win one game and the match
starts Anew so huge huge defensive
effort here by nihal sarin he is just he
is as hard to bring down to see car
Nakamura yeah honestly really he his
defensive capabilities are amazing and
this does feel like a win in many ways
but a lot of good things going for
Savion number one still got a golden
ticket to return to this event number
two still up in this match yeah and
number three no more games today
so I don't know how mad Savion is going
to be about this because I if Savion
didn't win the game that where he was
winning it's a different story here it
wasn't like yeah it wasn't plus seven it
wasn't he all literally found that
Knight takes C4 move play that with five
seconds the board come on just
understand that you have to sack your
knight for Black's remaining pawns is a
hard thing to do in a classical game
much less with with the sort of pitiful
couple of seconds he had on his clock
and okay they're 115 moves in Levy they
I didn't see where the counter started
obviously the 50 move rule means that if
50 moves go by and a pawn does not move
and a capture does not take place uh the
draw is official I think he's made
something like probably 35 moves or so
it's it's probably in the 40s at this
point yeah
and that rule was put in place to
prevent situations like this from going
on for forever and there is and uh
called it wow that was so accurate yeah
it felt yeah Savion doesn't look uh
particularly unhappy he would be far
more unhappy if he needed to win that
game to like tie the match in the final
game but a very good day
for Sam Savion here in the first day of
the quarterfinals and just to be honest
with you just a fantastic welcome back
to the event yeah I mean high quality
high quality play in this match I mean
by both players a lot of effort a lot of
grit and uh just a very impressive game
too by by Sam Sevin I mean he came here
didn't expect to come he didn't have as
much time to prepare Levy so let's tip
our hats to sam7 and the guy is just
he's 21 years old and like I said
earlier he he plays with the positional
Acumen and the confidence of a seasoned
50 year old Soviet Grandmaster but he
has that tactical prowess in the opening
preparation of you know of a 21 year old
yeah it's amazing you got two young guys
playing in this event who bring
absolutely different styles to the table
and I said this in the pre-game show and
here we are at the end of day number one
of the Charles icon Global championship
finals and the question remains when's
the last time you saw a final eight
where the guy in one of the seeds just
got knocked out in his back we'll see he
might take this all the way he might and
it's the first time savian has
experienced something like this so he's
determined to make it count imagine what
a story it would be if if he wins the
whole thing I'm sure that's going
through Sam sevin's mind I'm sure he's
playing that scenario through and he's
saying hey I'm I got to give him my all
I've got to give it a shot yeah that's
uh super exciting to see what happens in
tomorrow's uh second day of the
quarterfinal but thus far a fantastic
start for him you can't ask for much
more one win in potential four against
nihal sarin who hasn't lost at all in
the chest like I'm Global Championship
good for Savion I know what a crazy
match can't wait for the second day and
we folks will be back in a bit for our
brave move of the day but for a recap of
this entire day of Epic action action
let's kick it back to Danny Robert James
Adam on in the playing Hall Danny we go
to you thank you Daniel wow what what
Wild games we just saw a lot to break
down like you said let's reintroduce our
chairs here we've got myself Danny
wrench Grandmaster Robert Hess v-day
Master James Camp D and now Grand Master
Iman Hamilton on the end uh there's guys
there's a lot to unpack I'm on to start
in reverse order with you your biggest
takeaway right now before we head into
day two
Sam Sevin underestimated you know I'll
even eat my own words there I had nihal
sarin in this match Danny and I can say
that his performance right now is the
most surprising and in some ways it's
the most consistent because we've seen a
lot of blunders uncharacteristic from
some of these other players this mate uh
you know material hanging and just
conversions failing so I think Sam seven
is playing one of the cleanest matches
so far
Canty I'm going to ask you in a second
for your biggest thought I want to
quickly point out that we do have all
four of the match scores before you of
course I'm on just talking about Savion
and the surprise performance right now
that is Geary also has the same lead
that Savion does over Sauron over
verjava Wesley so with a 3-1 lead and
surprising almost just kind of it ended
so quickly fashion and then you have
hikaranakamura with an absolute dominant
performance at 4-0
candy let's let's get the same answer
from you your biggest takeaway the
biggest match or moment of the day for
you at this point it's got to be because
Sam stole the day for me uh Sam and I
was thinking definitely thinking nehal
was you know at Indian water and that
Indian food over there I mean them boys
are good they really really good
especially Arjun and you see goo cast
2700s right so you see them eating up
everything here but nihal was unable to
to really hit hit uh Sam today so Sam
pushing forward and actually making it
further than what we thought Robert well
I predicted Sam yeah so did I by the way
well he did it by accident
yeah no but in all seriousness I thought
Sam put a very measured match yeah like
it's only halfway through but the way
the games went he had like the hold of
the position in game two that one that
he actually did win it felt like he
handled that opening surprise well and
then was able to even obtain more so I
like the way Sam seven is playing thus
far for the record even though it looked
like an accident on camera I did double
down and stay with my Savion pick and I
want to give one more point about this
savion's story we're all covering the
chess.com Global Championship was about
anyone having a chance to become a
global Champion who's the only player in
the field Still Standing who had to
qualify his way into the event Sam Sevin
I'm on your thoughts on that yeah that's
a great point I mean that's what makes
this tournament so interesting Danny
that we truly do have somebody
you know basically writing out that
storyline that everyone is like oh yeah
can that actually happen but it can Sam
is doing that right now but he's not
just here he's he's saying I don't
deserve to be here I deserve to be in
the next round he's basically making a
statement we'll see how far he can go a
person who also deserves to be here as
his play continues to show Hikaru
Nakamura with a 4-0 lead he caught up
with Nemo just a few moments ago and
let's take a listen in
hi I garu how do you feel about your
games today yeah I feel pretty good
obviously a somewhat unexpected score
but I played well and then you know
three good games in the last game dude I
decided to have some fun and it didn't
quite work out for him that is certainly
true so do you want to play the blonde
Cloud against you just now did you feel
disrespected or just confident you had
an easy position well I mean it was very
clear he was on tilt when he did this I
I thought that he would try to play
something more normal but again against
the player of your own caliber where
they can just play sensible moves it's
obviously absolute garbage so there's a
reason it's a meme
and this is also very true
um how are you feeling about your games
tomorrow
um well I mean I have to lose four games
to not advance so obviously I'm in as
good a situation as I could be uh just
overall I'm happy with how I've played
and I mean it's great to have ideas that
I didn't use before and be able to use
them here so I'm just pretty happy thank
you very much
guys all of us were standing together
along with a current U.S champion who
just got here we'll talk about that
later when Nakamura faced the bond cloud
and the facial expressions that Hikaru
only Hikaru can give uh had us all
reacting but your thoughts on what
Hikaru said about the bond Cloud about
facing it and the thoughts that maybe
Duda is just on Full Tilt right now well
I think hikar is proving that he won't
be distracted that there's gonna be a
lot of conversation oh this meme this
and that he's like I'm here to win the
global Championship he just won the
Fisher random World Championship why not
make it two in a row and it just goes to
show how professional he is when he sits
down at the board or the laptop and
plays these chess games
candy your thoughts on facing the bond
cloud with two hundred thousand dollars
in our first place how would you have
reacted in that moment first time I
thought it was a board glitch I was like
oh yeah hey get the security like we got
something's wrong with the board right
but it was nothing wrong with the board
he definitely played the bunk out there
you saw hey Carlos uh Facebook
expression and that uh he's checked out
I say dude is at this point but of
course Hikaru is playing great chess out
of his mind just one official random
he's hot off of that right now hot hand
today it's really tough and it
definitely got to do this today yeah
yeah I agree like the other thing is I
think Nakamura has an opportunity now
now hear me up he's a professional total
and the way he handled that was exactly
what you should you got to punish people
that play the bomb Cloud but now he's up
4-0 right I say he comes back first game
tomorrow bomb clap I was just gonna ask
that whether hikara would return the
favor we've seen him do it before in in
big online events so uh when you're up
4-0 I'm gonna guess Hikaru secures the
match first and foremost before we see a
bomb Club that's my guess Robert well do
they have to play all like games right
the match is done then it's done so he
might only have one chance and as he
himself said he's unlikely to lose four
straight games tomorrow so he can have
some fun with it it's gonna be a
relaxing night for him and then he's
gonna have to start preparing for either
Wesley or Dimitri likely Wesley at this
point well we're going to talk about all
that will be tomorrow's matchups in just
a moment but before we do let's send
things back over to Donya and Levy for
the brave move of the day thank you
Danny that was an awesome recap it is
now time for the brave move of the day
in which we highlight a key move or set
of moves that decided the outcome of one
of our matches today and it really
wasn't a decision at all there was one
move that we absolutely have to
highlight we dig into game three of
Hikaru nakamura's match against Jan
shistoff Duda and the position in front
of you is an opposite colored Bishop end
game that stemmed from some impressive
Berlin preparation by hikaranakamura
Levy he carves up a pond here but we
thought at this point that Yankee stuff
has excellent drawing chances and then
la lo and behold yeah and then here came
the one remaining trick of the position
Bishop to B5 with a seemingly just
innocuous pass back of let's trade all
the pawns we both understand what's
going on here and then savagery I'm
locking your Bishop away the tallest
room of the tallest tower you will not
get that key diagonal and I'm gonna walk
in there with my king and take care of
business with my bare hands like in a
good Mafia movie I love these types of
ideas the reason you don't play CB as
you pointed out Levy is that black
captures on A5 opens up the entire
diagonal for his bishop and then black
can use his King to stop the pawns on
the other side of the board after A6
after BC G4 Duda simply resigned because
all you can try to do is hold the black
the white king with the black king but
if you move your Bishop back and forth
white simply creates a passer on the
other side this is what I love the most
you create a passer and all you have is
one Pawn left you're gonna have one Pawn
left and you use it to win the game the
king gets to B7 knocking the Bishop out
and then you make a new Queen ladies and
gentlemen it's yeah such a disgusting
idea and I wish I was just completely
stunned when he he found it in basically
three seconds that's the whole reason he
put up Bishop B5 he could have retreated
the bishop basically anywhere and again
it just goes to show the level
difference it's this tiny little
sprinkle of salt at the at the ending
point of cooking the full meal and
Hikaru will find that Nuance better than
any other player in this field it's a
nightmare to get that deep into the game
against and that's why his playing style
is classified as intense because that
was an intense game it most certainly
was and that folks was our brave move of
the day remember it's time to make your
move from chrome to Brave try it now at
brave.com chess and now without further
Ado we send it back to our hosts in the
playing Hall Danny back to you
thank you Dania and Levy it was a it was
a joy to watch your guys commentary and
break down A6 uh definitely a worthy
Brave move the day that thing that thing
was nasty well all right let's talk
about tomorrow guys and get your
thoughts on each of the upcoming
matchups but before we do remind
everybody of the scores heading in it
will be a 4-0 perfect score for Hikaru
Nakamura over yon schustoff Wesley so in
about uh as commanding opposition as we
thought anybody would be before Hikaru
showed up and did his thing also with a
3-1 lead and two and a half to one and a
half is the score that both Geary and
Savion lead rajaba and Sauron uh both
those matchups I think are going to come
down to the wire let's talk about what
we're going to see tomorrow guys and uh
What uh what matchup are you circling
first and foremost Robert well I think I
have to look at the newcomer or the
re-entrant in Sam sevian against nihal
sarin it's been the talk of the day
outside of the Nakamura matchup against
Duda I think that Sam has proven himself
it just goes to show that anybody in the
cheslaco global Championship from the
round of 64 to the end can beat anybody
else and he may have lost Levon aronen
does not mean he's going to lose to
anybody if he wins are you still going
to say a fiction by accident forever you
figure that one out okay get to your
thoughts what match would be absurd yeah
uh looking at the uh Wesley so on Drake
and mass of course uh and Drake is
actually a very I love how he plays like
the tactics and the stuff that happens
in his games of course it didn't work
today Wesley so but we do have a bounce
back we got four games tomorrow maybe he
gets back and like looks at looks at
some lines maybe makes some corrections
and some better things and then coming
here you know stronger tomorrow so what
chances you give her job off to turn
things around against Gary I think he
has great chances Danny honestly I I
think first of all I think we're going
to see all the games played I think
we're going to see eight games in that
match it does seem to be the most even
of all the matches that we've seen Geary
has obviously played well he's got the
edge but I definitely think that rajabov
can make a comeback in that match and it
definitely has better chances than some
of the other matches which are a little
more one-sided yeah I'm I'm not going to
pick an epic comeback in the only
matchup we haven't covered yet for John
schistoff down for 4-0 is crazy but I am
going to say that you really need to be
careful if you're Sam sevy and not to
allowing up a comeback I think you need
to start off well tomorrow you need to
make sure that you come as poised and as
focused as we saw him today I think that
Soren was the favorite for most people
for a reason and if that matchup starts
with an early win for sarin
Savion you know he's got that shout in
the back of his head too right do I
belong here I'm here by accident I think
if he starts strong though we might see
the upset that the the people's champion
and everyone is looking for given that
he qualified his way into the event so
all right well
this has been awesome thank you guys
this has been quite the day the first
day of the chess.com Global Championship
we got so many more ahead five to be
exact but before we head out I want to
give a reminder to everyone that the
women's candidates has also kicked off
already it's reached the semi-finals for
pool a in fact Lei tenji versus onomusic
who will make it through to the finals
and one step closer to that coveted seat
across from world champion Jew in June
in the 2023 Women's World Championship
You Don't Want to Miss a Thing game
three is Friday November 4th here at
twitch.tv chess type the command women's
candidates in the chat for all the
details and make sure you tune in
alright everybody this has been awesome
that is going to complete our coverage
of opening day at the quarterfinals of
the cgc from Toronto thanks for the head
Bob Hikaru thanks for joining us
everybody our thanks to Robert Canty
Amon and all of our commentators here
this was a great day one make sure to
join us on Thursday that's tomorrow in
case your case you're lost on Twitch and
YouTube for our coverage games five
through eight how many matches will go
the distance we're gonna find out our
live stream starts at 2 30 Eastern time
that's 11 30 a.m Pacific and the chest
starts at noon Eastern 9 A.M Pacific
lots of exciting moments today there are
some players in good shape for tomorrow
others fighting for their lives I'm
Danny wrench this has been awesome and
this is good night from Toronto
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]